Donald Trump was probably the biggest
person ever to be removed from social
media do you understand why that was
done can you still man the case for it
and against it everybody who's watching
this around the world
basically saw
let's say U.S establishment or democrat
aligned folks just decapitate you know
the head of state from digitally right
like just boom gone okay and they're
like well if they can do that in public
to the US president who's ostensibly the
most powerful man in the world
what is the Mexican president stand
against that
nothing
regardless of whether it was Justified
on this guy that means they will do it
to anybody now the seal is broken just
like the bailouts as exceptional as they
were in the first everybody was shocked
about them then they became a policy
instrument and now this bailouts
happening every single bill is printing
another whatever billion dollars or
something like that
the following is a conversation with
Biology sir navasana an angel investor
Tech founder philosopher and author of
the network State how to start a new
country
he was formerly the CTO of coinbase and
general partner at Andresen Horowitz
this conversation is over seven hours
for some folks that's too long for some
too short for some just right
there are chapter timestamps their Clips
so you can jump around or like I prefer
to do with podcasts and audiobooks I
enjoy you can sit down relax with a
loved human animal or consumable
substance or all three if you like and
enjoy the ride from start to finish
biology is a fascinating mind who thinks
deeply about this world and how we might
be able to engineer it in order to
maximize the possibility that Humanity
flourishes on this fun little planet of
ours also you may notice that in this
conversation my eye is red that's from
jiu jitsu and also if I may say so from
a life well lived
this is Alex Friedman podcast to support
it please check out our sponsors in the
description and now dear friends here's
biology srinivasan
at the core of your belief system is
something you call the a prime number
maze I'm curious I'm curious we've got
it we gotta start there sure if we can
start anywhere it's with mathematics
let's go all right great a rat can be
trained to turn at every even number or
every third number in a maze to to get
some cheese but evidently it can't be
trained to turn at prime numbers
two three five seven and then 11 and so
on and so forth that's just too abstract
and frankly if most humans were dropped
into a prime number maze
they probably wouldn't be able to figure
it out either you know they'd have to
start counting and so and actually
pretty difficult to figure out what the
Turning you know rule was
yet the rule is actually very simple
and so the thing I think about a lot is
just how many patterns in life are we
just like these rats and we're trapped
in a prime number Maze and if we had
just a little bit more you know
cogitation if we had you know a little
bit more cognitive ability a little bit
more whether it's uh you know brain
machine interface or just better physics
we could just figure out the next step
in that prime numbers we could just see
it we could see the grid right and
that's what I think about like that
that's a big thing that drives me
is figuring out how we can actually
conceive understand that prime number
maze that we're living in so understand
which patterns are just complex enough
that they are beyond the limit of human
cognition yes and uh what do you make
that are the limits the human cognition
a feature or a bug
I think mostly a bug I admire vermonagen
I admire uh you know Feynman I admired
these great mathematicians and
physicists who were just able to
see things that others couldn't
and just by writing it down you know
that's that's the leap forward you know
people talk about it's not the idea it's
execution but that's for trivial ideas
for great ideas for Maxwell's equations
or Newton's laws or you know Quantum
electrodynamics or some of ramonigen's
identities that really does bring us
forward especially when you can check
them you don't know how they work right
you have the phenomenological but you
don't have the theory underneath it and
then that stimulates the advancement of
theory to figure out why is this thing
actually working that's actually you
know statmac you know arose in part from
the kind of phenomenological studies
that were basically being done where
people are just getting steam engines
and so on work and then they kind of
abstracted out thermodynamics and so on
from that right so the the practice led
the theory rather than vice versa to
some extent that's happening neural
networks now as you're aware right and I
think that's
um so just something that's true and
that works you know if we don't know yet
that's amazing and it pulls us forward
so I I do think that the limits are are
more of a bug than a feature is there
something that humans will never be able
to figure out about our universe about
the theory about the practice of our
universe yeah people will typically
quote credel's in completeness with for
such a question and uh yeah there are
things that are probably unknowable or
provably unprovable
um but I think you can often get an
approximate solution you know the the
Hilbert you know you know Hilbert's
problems like we will know we must know
uh at least we should know that we can
know push to get at least an approximate
solution push to know that we can't no
at least we push back that Darkness
enough so that we have lit up that
corner of the intellectual Universe okay
let's actually take a bit of a tangent
and explore a bit in a way that I did
not expect we would but let's talk about
the nature of reality briefly I don't
know if you're familiar with the work of
Don Hoffman no I don't I know Roger
Penrose has like his Road to Reality
series for like basic physics going up
to everything we know but go ahead tell
me it's even Wilder yeah in modern
physics we start the question of what is
fundamental and what is emergent in this
beautiful Universe of ours and there's a
bunch of folks who think that space-time
as we know it the four-dimensional space
is emergent it's not fundamental to the
physics of the universe and the same May
argue I think Sean Carroll is one of
them is that time itself the way we
experience it is also emergent it's not
fundamental to the way our universe
works anyway those are uh the technical
term I apologize for swearing those are
the Mind [ __ ] of modern physics but if
we stroll along that road further we get
somebody like Donald Hoffman who makes
the evolutionary case that the reality
we perceive with our eyes is not only an
abstraction of objective reality but
it's actually completely detached like
we're in a video game essentially that's
consistent between each consistent for
All Humans but it doesn't it's not at
all connected to physical reality
because it's an illustration version of
the simulation hypothesis is that his in
a very distant way but
as the simulation says that there's a
sort of computational nature to reality
and then there's a kind of a programmer
that creates this reality and so on no
he's he says that we humans have a brain
that is able to perceive the environment
and uh evolution is produced from
primitive life to complex life on Earth
produce the kind of brain that doesn't
at all need to sense the reality uh
directly so like this table
according to Donald Hoffman is not there
well so like not not just as an
abstraction like we don't sense the
molecules that make up the table but all
of this is fake interesting so you know
I I tend to be more of a hard science
person right and so
um you know so just on that people talk
about qualia you know like
is your perception of green the
different different from my perception
of green and you know my counter
argument on that is well we know
something about you know spectrum of
light and we can build artificial eyes
and if we can build artificial eyes
which we can you know they're like
they're not amazing but you can actually
you can do that you can build artificial
ears and so on obviously we can build
recording devices and you know for
cameras and things like that well
operationally the whole concept of your
perception of green you see green is
purple I see green is green or what I
call Green it doesn't seem to add up
because it does seem like we can do
engineering around it right so the
Hoffman thing I get why people more
broadly will talk about a simulation
hypo is because you know it's like fine
when many others have talked about how
uh math is surprisingly useful to
describe the world you know like very
simple equations give rise these complex
phenomenal Wolfram is also on this
um from it from a different angle with a
cellular automata stuff but um so
suspicious how well it works yeah but on
their hand it's like uh you know
it is
yet we're still also in a prime number
maze you know there's things we just
don't understand and um you know so also
the within the constraints of the
non-prime numbers
we find math to be extremely effective
surprisingly effective yeah exactly so
maybe maybe the math we have gets us
through the equivalent of the even turns
and the odd turns but there's math we
don't yet have that is more complex or
more complex rules for other parts this
is probably all our age and all just
threats in a cage I know it gets like
very abstract but you know there are
unsolved problems in in physics you know
like the condensed matter space there's
a lot of interesting stuff happening my
recollection I may be you know out of
date on this like things like Sony
luminescence we don't know exactly how
they work and sometimes those things
that are like at the edges of physics
you know in the late 1800s I think
Rutherford somebody I think as
Rutherford said you know basically all
physics is being discovered Etc and that
was obviously before quantum mechanics
you know that that sort of educates
people are looking at the bomber and the
passion series and seeing you know this
weird thing you know with the hydrogen
Spectrum it was quantized and you know
that led to uh like the sort of
phenomenological set of observations
that led to quantum mechanics and and
everything and you know sometimes I
think the UAP stuff might be like that
right people immediately go to aliens
for UAP like the unidentified aerial
phenomena right and people have been uh
there's surprising amount of stuff out
there on this the UK is Declassified a
bunch of material you know Harry Reid
was the sender has talked about this
it's not obviously it's not obviously
political thing it which is good it's
something that
is is there something happening there
right and people have thought for a long
time that the UAP thing was a like
American
um kind of counter propaganda to cover
up their new spy planes that were spying
over the Soviet Union to make anybody
who talked about them seem
you know crazy and and hysterical or
whatever but
if the UAP thing is real
it could be atmospheric phenomena like
you know like the Aurora Borealis or the
northern lights but some things we don't
understand it could be something like
the uh the bomber and passion series uh
you know which were the observations of
like emission Spectra before quantum
mechanics so that's like another option
as opposed to doesn't exist or Little
Green Men it could be physics we don't
understand yet that's one possible do
you think there's alien civilizations
out there
so there's a lot of folks who have kind
of written and talked about this is you
know the Drake equation which is like
you know the multiplying all the
probabilities together there's perhaps
more sophisticated takes like the uh the
Dark Forest you know which says that if
the universe is like a dark Forest where
the dumb ones that aren't hiding our
presence
um there's one calculation I saw and I
haven't reproduced myself but basically
says that the uh the assumption that
other civilizations have seen hours is
wrong because when you have like a
spherical radius for like the you know
electronic magnetic radiation that's
leaving our planet as that sphere gets
larger and larger it gets like smaller
and smaller amounts of energy so you
know you get farther out you're not
getting enough
um you know uh you know photons or or
would have you to actually uh detect it
um I you know I don't know I actually
haven't looked into the math behind it
but I remember remember seeing that
argument so actually it is possible that
it's so diffuse when you go past a
certain you know number of light years
out that people you know that alien
civilization wouldn't be able to detect
it right that's the that's another
argument that's more basically about
signals from them from us yeah to be
able to signals colliding enough to uh
find the signal from the noise right
exactly intelligent signal yeah Hanson
noise Hanson has a article called grabby
aliens
um have you seen his thing yes right and
so there's been on this podcast oh great
he's brilliant I'd like him he he pushes
you know boundaries in interesting ways
in every ways in all of the ways in all
the ways that's right I I like morale
he's he's you know he he's NASA team
Andy gravity aliens so he has he has
this interesting idea that uh the
civilizations
uh quickly learn how to travel close to
the speed of light right so we're not
going to see them until they're here
yeah that's possible I mean one of the
things is so here's for example a
mystery that we haven't yet Done Right
which or we haven't really figured out
yet which is
um
a biogenesis in the lab
right we've done lots of things where
you've got you can show macromolecules
binding to each other you can show you
know evidence for the so-called RNA
world abiogenesis is to go from you know
like non-life to life right in the lab
you can show microevolution obviously
with bacteria you can do artificial
selection on them lots of other aspects
of
um you know fundamental you know
biochemistry origins of Life stuff have
been established there's a lot of
plausibility arguments about the
Primitive environment and nitrogens and
carbons snapping together to get you
know the you know the RNA world is the
the initial hypothesis but to my
knowledge at least we haven't actually
seen abiogenesis demonstrated now one
argument is you need just like this
massive world with uh you know so many
different reps before that actually
happens and
um one possibility is if we could do
atomic level you know simulations of
molecules bouncing each other it's
possible that in some simulation we
could find a path a represent path to
abiogenesis and then just you know
replicate that in the lab right
um I I don't know okay uh but that seems
to me to be like a mystery that we still
don't fully understand like an example
of the prime number maze right one of
the most fascinating Mysteries one of
the most important yeah yeah and and
again there may be some biochemists
who's like oh about you you didn't know
about X Y and Z that happened in the day
by agencies field I I freely confess I'm
not like at you know oh current on it
the last thing I remember looking at it
is still Quran to mean like up to the
moment oh nice that's a nice word that's
a current yeah I'm probably
mispronouncing it but yeah um we'll edit
it in post so sure correctly with AI
yeah yeah it will copy your voice and it
will pronounce it perfectly correctly
yeah in post one thing that I do think
was interesting is uh Craig Venter a
while back tried to make a minimum
viable sell
um where he just tried to delete all of
the genes that were that were not
considered essential and so it's like a
new life form and this was like almost
20 years ago and so on and that thing
was it was was viable in the lab right
and so it's possible that you could you
kind of reverse engineer so you're
coming at the problem from different
directions like RNA molecules can do
quite a lot you've got some you know
reasonable assumptions as to how that
could come together uh you've got like
sort of stripped down minimum viable
life forms and so there's it's not there
isn't stuff here you can see
microevolution you can see at the
sequence level you know if you do
molecular phylogenics you can actually
track back the bases there's actually so
it's not like there's no evidence here
there's a lot of tools to work with but
this in my view is a fascinating area
and actually also relevant to AI because
another form of abiogenesis would be if
we were able to give rise to a different
branch of life form the Silicon based as
opposed to carbon based you know to
stretch a point
um you give rise to something that
actually does meet the definition of
life for some definition of Life what do
you think that definition is for an
artificial life form because you
mentioned Consciousness yeah when will
it give us pause that we created
something
foreign
that feels
by some definition or by some
spiritual poetic romantic philosophical
mathematical definition that it is alive
right and we wouldn't want to kill it so
a couple of remarks on that one is
um Francis Crick of of Watson and Crick
uh before he died I think his last paper
was published on something called the
claustrum okay and the thing is that you
know sometimes in biology or in any you
know domain people are sort of
discouraged from going after the big the
big questions right but he proposed the
claustrum is actually the organ that is
the seat of Consciousness it's like this
sheath that like covers the brain and uh
for mice if you and again and maybe
recollecting this wrong so but you can
look at it my recollection is
um in mice if you disrupt this the mouse
is like very disoriented right it's like
it's the kind of thing which you know
Watson Creek we're all about structure
implies function right they found the
structure of DNA this amazing thing and
you know they were marked in this very
under understated way at the end of the
paper that well obviously the this uh
gives a basis for how the genetic
material might be replicated and error
corrected because you know Helix unwinds
and you got Pace right so he was a big
structure function person and that
applies not just at the protein level
not just at the level of DNA but
potentially also at the level of organs
like the colostrum is kind of this
system integrated level right it's like
the the last layer in the neural network
or something you know
um and uh and so that's that's the kind
of thing that I think is worth studying
um
so Consciousness is another kind of big
abiogenesis a big question the prime
number is consciousness is a big
question
um and uh you know then definition of
life right uh there's folks gosh there's
I think so this one is something I'd
have to Google around but there was a
guy I think at Santa Fe Institute or
something who had some definition of
life and like some thermodynamic
definition
um but you're right that it's going to
be a multi-feature definition we might
have a Turing test like definition
frankly which is just if enough humans
agree it's alive it's alive right and
that might frankly be the operational
definition because you know viruses are
like this boundary case you know are
they are they alive or not most people
don't think they're alive but they're
they're they're on they're kind of
they're more alive than a rock in a
sense well I think uh
in a world that we'll talk about today
quite a bit which is the digital world I
think the most fascinating
philosophically and technically
definition of Life Is Life in the
digital world
so chat Bots
essentially creatures whether they're
replicas of humans or totally
independent Creations perhaps in an
automatic way
I think there's going to be chat Bots
that we would ethically be troubled by
if we wanted to kill them
they would have the capacity to suffer
they would be very unhappy with you
trying to turn them off and then there
will be large groups of activists that
will protest and they'll go to the
Supreme Court of whatever the Supreme
Court looks like in in 10 20 30 40 years
and they will demand that these chat
Bots would have the same rights as us
humans do you think that's possible I
saw that Google engineer who's basically
saying this had already happened and I I
I was surprised by it uh because it just
I when I looked at the chat logs of it
it didn't seem particularly interesting
on their hand I can definitely see I
mean gp3 for people who you know haven't
paid attention shows that serious
step-ups are possible and obviously you
know you've talked about AI on your
podcast a ton
um
is it possible that gpt9 or something is
is kind of like that or GPT 15 or gpt4
maybe
but yeah for people just listening
there's a deep skepticism in your face
yeah you know the reason being because
um you know what's possible it's
possible that you have like a partition
of society on literally this basis you
know
um that's one model where there's some
people just like there's vegetarians and
non-vegetarians right there may be
um
machines have life and machines are
machines you know like or something like
that right uh you know you could you
could definitely imagine some kind of
partition like that in the future where
your fundamental political social system
that's a foundational assumption and you
know
is AI does it you know deserve the same
rights as like a human or for example a
corporation is an intermediate uh do you
see the thing which is how human is are
different corporations have you seen
that infographic it's actually funny so
it's a spectrum there's a spectrum so
for example Disney is considered about
as human as like a dog but like Exxon I
may be remembering this wrong but they
had like a level with like human at one
end and like rock at the other does it
have to do with corporate structure what
what I think it's about people's empathy
for that Corporation their brand
identity but it's interesting to see
that first of all people sort of do
think of Corporations as being more or
like The Branding is really what they're
responding well that's what I mean
they're also responding you know I have
a brand of human that I'm trying to sell
and it seems to be effective for the
most part sure although it has become
like a running joke that I might be a
robot right which means there's the
brand is cracking because it's seeping
through but I mean in that sense I just
I think I don't see a reason why chat
Bots
can't manufacture the brand of Being
Human of being sentient I mean that is
the Turing test but it's like the
multiplayer touring test now that
actually a fair number of chat Bots have
passed a Turing test I'd say there's at
least two steps up right one is
um a multiplayer touring test where you
have chatbots talking to each other
and then you ask can you determine the
difference between in chat Bots talking
to each other and clicking buttons and
stuff in apps and and humans doing that
I think we're very far off I shouldn't
say very far off at least I don't know
how far we are in terms of time but
we're still far off in terms of
a group of n chat Bots looking like
their digital output is like the group
of Inhumans like a go from the Turing
test to the multiplayer turn test that's
one definition another definition is
you know to be able to kind of swap in
and you're not just convincing one human
that this is a human for a small you
know session you're convincing all
humans that this is a human for end
sessions remote work actually makes this
possible right that's another definition
of a multiplayer touring test where
basically you have a chat bot that's
fully automated that is earning money
for you as an intelligent agent on a
computer that's able to go and get
remote work jobs and so on I would
consider that next level right if you
could have something that was like that
that was competent enough to I mean
because everything on a computer can be
automated right literally you could be
totally hands-free just like autonomous
driving you could have autonomous
earning as a challenge problem
if you're a Microsoft or apple and you
had legitimate access to the operating
system just like apple says can you send
me details of this event a decentralized
thing could in theory log you know the
actions of ten thousand or a hundred
thousand or a million people
and with cryptocurrency you can even
monitor a wallet that was on that
computer and you could see you know what
long run series of actions were
increasing or decreasing this digital
balance you see what I'm saying right so
you start to get at least conceptually
it'd be invasive and you know there'd be
a privacy issue and so on conceptually
you could imagine an agent that could
learn what actions humans were doing
that resulted in the increase of their
local cryptocurrency balance okay there
may be better ways to formulate it but
data considered a challenge problem is
to go from the Turing test to a genuine
intelligent agent that can actually go
and make money for you if you can do
that that's a big deal people obviously
have trading Bots and stuff but that
would be you know the next level is
typing out emails it's creating
documents it's actually mimic human
behavior in its entirety yeah that's
right and it can it'll schedule zooms
it'll send emails it'll essentially
because if you think about it a human is
hitting the keys and clicking the mouse
but just like a self-driving car the
wheel rotates by itself right those keys
are effectively just it's like uh like
the odd automator app in in apple right
um everything's just moving on the
screen you're seeing it there and it's
just an AI it's kind of hilarious that
the I'm not a robot click thing actually
works because I I actually don't know
how that's how it works but I think it
has to do with the movement of the mouse
the timing and they know that it's very
difficult for currently for a bot to
mimic human behavior in the way they
would click that little checkbox yeah
exactly I think it's something I mean uh
again my recollection on that is it's
like a pile of Highly obfuscated
JavaScript with all kind it looks like a
very simple box but it's doing a lot of
stuff and it's collecting all kinds of
instrumentation and yeah exactly like a
like a robot is just a little too
deterministic or if it's got noise it's
like gaussian noise and the way humans
do it is just not something that you
need to be able to do without collecting
thousands and thousands and thousands of
human traces doing it but it is a
predator prey on that well in the
computer or billions interested I don't
know the computer just sees the
JavaScript it needs to be able to
look outside the simulation for the
computer the world is like right it
doesn't the computer doesn't know about
the physical world so you have to look
outside of its world and introspect back
on this simple box right is which is
kind of you know I think that's exactly
what mushrooms do or like psychedelics
is you get to go outside and look back
in and that's what a computer needs to
do I you know I do wonder whether they
actually give people Insight or whether
they give people the illusion of insight
uh is there a difference yeah because uh
well actual Insight you know actual
Insight is
again Maxwell's equations you're able to
shift the world with that there's a lot
of practical devices that work the
illusion of insight is
I'm Jesus Christ and nothing happens
right so I don't know I think this is
quite different uh I don't know I I
think you can fake it till you make it
on that one which is
um Insight in some sense is revealing a
truth that was there all along yeah so I
mean I guess like I'm talking about
technical Insight where you you have
this is the thing you know we were
talking about actually before the
podcast like technical truths versus
political truths right some truths
they're they're on a spectrum and
there's some truths that are actually
entirely political in the sense that if
you can change the software in enough
people's heads you change the the value
of the truth for example the location of
a border is effectively consensus
between large enough groups of people uh
who is the CEO that's you know consensus
among a certain group of people what is
the value of a currency or any stock
right that market price is just the
psychology of a bunch of people like
literally if you can change enough
people's minds you can change the value
of the Border or the position the
hierarchy or the value of the currency
those are purely political truths then
all the way on the other end our
technical truths that exist independent
of whatever any one human or All Humans
think like uh the gravitational constant
right or the diameter of a virus those
those are just those exist independent
of the human mind change enough human
Minds doesn't matter those remain
constant and um
and you have things that are
interestingly in the Middle where
cryptocurrency has tried to pull more
and more things from the domain of
political truths into technical truths
where they say okay the one social
convention we have is
um that if you hold this amount of
Bitcoin or that if you hold this private
key you hold this Bitcoin and then we
make that very hard to change because
you have to change a lot of technical
truths so you you can push things
to this interesting intermediate Zone
did the question is how how much of our
world can we push into that right and
that takes us
in a non-linear fascinating Journey to
the question I wanted to ask you in the
beginning which is uh this political
world that you mentioned in the world of
political truth
as we know it in the 20th century in the
early 21st century what do you think
works well and what is broken about
government the fundamental thing is that
we can't
easily and peacefully start new opt-in
governments
and startup governments yeah and what do
I mean by that is basically
um
you can start a new company you can
start a new community you can start a
new currency even these days you don't
have to beat the former CEO in a duel to
start a new company
um you don't have to become head of the
World Bank to start a new currency okay
because of this
yes if you can if if you're if you want
to you can join I don't know
uh Microsoft or name some company that's
a GameStop and you can try to reform it
okay or you can start your own and the
fact that both options exist mean that
you know you've you can actually just
start from scratch and that's just I
mean the same reason we have a clean
piece of paper right I've mentioned this
actually in in the network State book
I'll just quote this bit but we want to
be able to start a new state peacefully
for the same reason we want to Bear plot
of Earth a blank sheet of paper an empty
text buffer a fresh start or a clean
slate because we want to build something
new with that historical constraint
right for the same reason you hit plus
and do docs.new you know like create a
new DOC for the same reason right
because you know in backspace you don't
have just like
128 bytes of space 120 kilobytes and
just have to backspace the old document
for creating the new one so that's a
fundamental thing that's wrong with
today's garments and it's a meta point
right because it's not any one specific
reform it's a meta reform of being able
to start new countries
okay so that's one problem but there you
know you could push back and say that's
that's a feature because you know a lot
of people argue that tradition is power
through generation if you try a thing
long enough which is the way I see
marriage there's value to this struggle
and the journey you take through the
struggle and you grow and you develop
ideas together you grow until actually
philosophically together and that's the
idea of a Nations that spans Generations
that you have a tradition that becomes
more
that that strives towards the truth and
is able to arrive there or no not arrive
but take steps towards there through the
generations so you may not want to keep
starting new governments you may want to
uh stick to the old one and improve it
one step at a time so just because
you're having a fight inside a marriage
doesn't mean you should get a divorce
and go on Tinder and start dating around
that's the uh that's the pushback so
it's not obvious that there's a strong
feature to have sure to launch new
governments there's several different
kind of lines of attack or or debate or
whatever on this right first is uh yes
there's obviously value to tradition and
uh you know people say this is Lindy and
that's Lindy it's being proven for a
long time and so on but of course
there's a tension between tradition and
Innovation you know like going to the
Moon wasn't Lindy just it was awesome
and you know like artificial
intelligence is something that's very
new new is good right and this is a
tension within Humanity actually itself
because you know it's way older than all
of these nations I mean humans are tens
of thousands of years old answers to
humans are millions of years old right
and you go back far enough and the time
that we know today of the sessile farmer
and Soldier
is if you go back far enough you want to
be truly traditional well we're actually
descend from hunter-gatherers who are
mobile and wandered the world and there
weren't borders and so on they kind of
went where they want right and you know
people have you know had done historical
reconstructions of like skeletons and
and stuff like that and
uh many folks who report that the
transition to Agriculture and being
sessile
um resulted in you know diminution of
height you know people had like tooth
decay and stuff like that the skeletons
people had traded off upside for
stability right that's what the state
was that was with these sessile kinds of
things were now of course
um they they had more likelihood of
living uh consistently you could support
larger population sizes but it had lower
quality of life right and so the
hunter-gatherer error you know maybe
that's actually our Collective
recollection of a Garden of Eden where
people you know just like a a spider
kind of knows innately how to build webs
or a beaver knows how to build dams you
know some people theorize that uh the
entire Garden of Eden is like
um a sort of built-in neural network
recollection of this you know
pre-sessile era we're able to roam
around just pick off fruits and so on
low population density so point is that
I think what we're seeing is a V3 you go
from the hunter-gatherer to the farmer
and Soldier the sessile nations are here
and they've got borders and so on to
kind of the V3 which is the digital
Nomad the new hunter-gatherer we're
going back to the future because you
know it's even older than Nations is no
Nations right even more traditional than
tradition is
you know being International right and
so we're actually tapping into that
other huge thread in humanity which is
the desire to explore Pioneer wander
innovate you know kind of thing that's
important to make America great again is
to dissolve it completely into Oblivion
no that's a joke I know it's a joke well
humor I'm learning this new thing yes a
new thing for the role the chatbot
emulation isn't fully working there yeah
yeah glitch that's we're in the in the
beta and let me say one other thing
about this which is
you know there are I mean everybody in
the world to for okay let's say I don't
know what percentage let's say
99.99 uh or it's rounds to that number
of
political discourse in the US focuses on
trying to fix the system if those folks
I mean 0.01 of the energy is going
towards building a new system that seems
like a pretty good portfolio strategy
right or 100 are supposed to go and edit
this code base from 200 something years
ago I mean the most American thing in
the world is going and you know leaving
your country in in search of a better
life America was founded 200 years ago
by the founding fathers it's not just a
nation of immigrants it's a nation of
immigrants right immigration you know
from other countries to the US and
actually also immigration within the US
there's this amazing YouTube video
called
um it's like 50 states U.S population I
think 1792 it says 2050s they've got a
simulation so you just stop it at 2019
or 2020. but it shows that like Virginia
was like number one early on and then it
lost ground in like New York gained and
then like Ohio was a big deal in the
early 1800s and it was like father of
presidents in general all these
presidents and later Illinois and
Indiana and then California really came
up in the 20th century like during the
Great Depression and now we're entering
the modern era where like Florida and
Texas have risen in New York and
California have dropped and so
Interstate competition it's actually
just like inter-currency competition you
know you've got trading pairs right you
you know sell BTC by eth you sell you
know a Solana or Zeke you know sell
Monero by Z cash right each of those
trading pairs gives you signal for today
on this currency is down or up relative
to this other currency in the same way
each of those migration pairs someone
goes from New York to Ohio Ohio to
California gives you information on the
desirability of different states you can
literally form a pairs Matrix like this
over time very much like link Matrix
that's shaped American a huge way and so
you know you ask a if this niche of
immigrants that was founded by men
younger than us by the way the founding
fathers were often in their 20s right
who
um you know endorse the concept of a
proposition Nation who've given rise to
a country of Founders and and Pioneers
uh who've literally gone to the Moon
right
um those folks would think that this is
the end of History
that that's it we're done like we we've
done everything else I mean there's
people in technology who believe and I
agree with them that we can go to Mars
they might be able to end death but we
can't innovate on something that was 230
years old
you know
so there is a balance certainly to
strike uh the the American experiment is
fascinating nevertheless so one argument
you can make is actually
that were in the very early days of this
V2 if so what you describe as V2 you
could make the case that we're not ready
for V3 that we're just actually uh
trying to figure out the V2 thing you're
trying to like skip when are we ever
ready
now again we'll go back to marriage I
think and having kids kind of thing I
think everyone who has kids is never
really ready to be kids this whole point
you dive in okay but the
I mean you you mentioned that you can't
watch is there other criticisms of
government that you can provide as we
know it today before we kind of outline
the ideas of of V3 let's stick to V2
I'll give a few right and so a lot of
this stuff will go into the version so
I've got you know this book the network
State
um which which covers some of these
topics does Network State have a
subtitle
um it is uh the network State how to
start a new country how to start a new
country and but um I just have it at the
networkstate.com I should say it's an
excellent book that you should get I
read it on Kindle but there's also a
website and uh Balaji said that is
constantly working on improving it
changing it but but by the time the
whole project is over it'll be a
different book than it was yeah in the
beginning I think it's always shedding
its old skin well I I wanted to get
something out there and get feedback and
whatnot just like an app right you know
you again you have these two polls of an
app is highly Dynamic and you're you're
a cost him to having updates all the
time and a book is supposed to be static
and there's a value in something static
something unchanged and so on but in
this case I'm glad I kind of shipped a
version 1.0 and uh you know the the next
version
um you know I'm gonna split into like uh
tentatively motivation theory and
practice like motivation like what is
the sort of political philosophy and so
on that motivates me at least do this
which you can take or leave right and
then Theory as to why Network state is
now possible and I can Define it in a
second and then the practice is zillions
of practical details and everything from
roads diplomatic recognition and so on
um funding founding all that stuff a lot
of stuff actually I left out of V1
simply because I wanted to kind of get
the desirability of it on the table and
then talk about the the feasibility I
should actually Linger on that briefly
in in terms of things we can
revolutionize like um one of the biggest
Innovations I think that Tesla does
with the way they think about the car
with the deploy the car is not the
automation or the electric to me it's
the uh over the air updates right be
able to send
instantaneously uh updates to the
software that completely changes the
behavior the ux everything about the car
and so I do think it would be
interesting because books
a representation of human knowledge a um
a snapshot of human knowledge and it
would be interesting that we if we can
somehow figure out a system that allows
you to do sort of like a GitHub for
books like if I buy a book on Amazon
without having to pay again
can I get updates like V Point V 1.1 V
1.2 and there's like release notes right
that that would be that would be
incredible it's not not enough to do
like a second edition or a third edition
but like minor updates that's not just
on your website but actually go into the
the model that we use to buy books right
so I spent my money maybe I I'll do a
subscription service for five bucks a
month where I get regular updates to the
books and then there's an incentive for
authors to actually update their books
such that it makes sense for the
subscription and that that means your
book isn't just a snapshot but it's a
lifelong project right you still care
enough about the book so I think there's
a lot that can mean on there because
actually in going through this process
in many ways the most traditional thing
I did was a self-published eBook on
Kindle right uh why because basically
like you know if you actually ink a deal
with a book publisher first they you
know they'll give you some advance I
didn't need the advance or anything but
second is all these constraints
um oh you know you want to translate
into this or you want to do this other
format or you want to update it you have
to go and now talk to this other party
right you know and uh also the the
narrowing window of what they'll
actually publish it gets narrower
narrower you can see all these you know
meltdowns over young adult levels and
stuff on Twitter but it's it's more than
that so you know actually having an
Amazon page it's just like a marker that
a book exists okay and uh now I've got
an entry point where if someone says
okay I like this tweet but how do I kind
of get the
um that that might be a concept from
like the middle of chapter three right
how do I get the thing from front to
back I can just point them at the
network state.com that is import this
right this one entry point okay and um
you mentioned like subscription and and
money and so and so forth and I think
people are paying for Content online now
with newsletters and so on but I've
chosen to and it will always have the
thing free
um and I want it on all right you can
get the Kindle version on Amazon simply
because you have to kind of set a price
for that but the network state.com what
I want to do is have that optimized for
every Android phone so people in India
or Latin America or Nigeria can just tap
and open it gonna do translations and
stuff like that uh Greg foder of
allspace VR you know founder of us is
very you know he sold that in uh he
coded the website and um you know worked
with him on it and there's another
designer who
Elijah and uh it's basically just a
three-person group and we thought we had
something pretty nice but one thing I
was really uh pleasantly surprised by is
how many people got in touch with us
afterwards and asked us if we could open
source the software to create this this
website right because it's actually you
can try it on mobile I think it's
actually
um in some ways a better experience in
Kindle and uh so that was interesting
because
um I do think of the website as like a
V1 version of uh this concept of a book
app right for example imagine if you
have
the Bible and the Ten Commandments
aren't just text but there's like a
checklist and there's a gateway to a
Christian Community there and
um you know the practice is embedded
into the thing you know like if you know
brilliant.org amazing site I love this
site brilliant is basically mobile
friendly tutorials and you can kind of
just swipe through you know you're in
line at Starbucks or you know getting on
a plane or something you just swipe
through and just get really nice micro
lessons on things and it's just
interactive enough that your brain is
working and you're problem solving and
sometimes you'll need a little pen and
paper but that format
um of sort of very mobile friendly just
continuous learning
I I'd like to do a lot more with that
and so that's kind of where we're going
to go the the book at so the there's a
lot of fun stuff about the way you did
at least V1 of the book which is you
have like a one sentence summary one
paragraph summary
tldr and like one image summary
which is
um
I think honestly it's not even about a
short attention span it's a really good
exercise about summarization
condensation and yeah like helping you
think through what is the key Insight
like we mentioned the the prime number
maze that reveals something Central to
The Human Condition which is struggling
against the limitation of our of our
minds and in that same way you summarize
the network state in the book so let's
actually jump right there and
let me ask you what is the network State
what is the network state so I'll give
it a sentence and also give it an image
right so the informal sentence a network
state is a highly aligned online
community with a capacity for Collective
action that crowdfunds territory around
the world and eventually gains
diplomatic recognition from pre-existing
States okay so just taking those pieces
highly aligned online community that is
not Facebook that is not Twitter people
don't think of themselves as facebookers
or twitterians right that's just a
collection of hundreds of millions of
people who just fight each other all day
right It's a Fight Club a company is
highly aligned where you know you'll put
a task into the company slack and
on your if you're doing all hands about
100 of the people in the company stock
will do it they're highly aligned that
way but online communities don't tend to
be highly aligned online communities
tend to be like a Game of Thrones fan
club or something like that or you know
a Twitter account you might get point
one percent of people engaging with
something it's not 100 if you combine
the degree of alignment
of a company with the scale of a
community that's like what a highly
aligned you know online community is
right start to get a thousand or ten
thousand people who can collectively do
something as simple as just all liking
something on Twitter for example why
would they do that they're a they're
Guild of electoral Engineers they're a
guild of graphic designers and you've
got a thousand people in this Guild and
every day somebody is asking a favor
from The Guild and the other 999 people
are helping them out for example I've
just launched a new project or I'd like
to get a new job can somebody help me
and so on and so you kind of give to get
your you know you're helping other
people in the community and you're kind
of building up Karma this way and then
sometimes you spend it down like stack
Overflow has this Karma economy it's not
meant to be an internal economy that is
um like making tons and tons of money
off of is sort of a keep score right
that's a highly aligned online community
part then capacity for Collective action
I just kind of described that which is
at a minimum you you don't have a highly
aligned online community unless you have
a thousand people and you paste in a
tweet and a thousand of them RT it or or
like it okay if you can't even get that
you don't have something if you do have
that you have the basis for at least
Collective digital action on something
okay and you can think of this as a
group of activists you can think of it
as for example let's say I mentioned a
guild but let's say they're a group that
wants to raise awareness of the fact
that life extension is possible right
every day there's a new
um tweet on I don't know whether it's a
metformin research or Sinclair's work or
David Sinclair right Andrew hubman has
good stuff here you know or um there's a
longevity VC there's a bunch of folks
work in this area every day there's
something there and literally the
purpose of this online community is
raise version of longevity and of the
thousand people 970 go and like that
that's pretty good right that's solid
you've got something there you've got it
you've got a laser right you've got
something which you can focus on
something because most of the web 2
internet is in Tropic you go to Hacker
News you go to Reddit you go to Twitter
and you're immediately struck by the
fact that it's like 30 random things
random it's just a box of chocolates
it's meant to be you know where some of
them look delicious some look delicious
novelty we can over consume novelty
right so you know we were talking about
earlier the balance between tradition
and Innovation right here is a different
version of that which is
um entropy going in a ton of different
directions due to novelty versus uh like
Focus you know it's like it's like Heat
versus work you know heat is entropic
and work forced along a distance you're
going in in a direction right and so if
those 30 links on you know the next
version of Hacker News or red or
something like so brilliant it's just
that's leveling you up the the 30 things
you click you've just gained a skill as
a function of that right so these kinds
of online communities I don't know what
they look like they probably don't look
like the current social media they just
like for example I know it's a
meta-analogy but in the 2000s people
thought Facebook for work would look
like Facebook and you know David sax you
know found and sold a company Yammer
that was partially on the basis it was
fine it was a billion dollar company but
Facebook for work tended was actually
slack right it looked different it was
more chat focused it was less image
focused and whatnot
what does the platform for a highly
aligned online community look like I
think Discord is the transitional state
but it's not the end State Discord is
sort of Chatty the work isn't done in
Discord itself right the cryptocurrency
for tracking or the crypto karma for
sure tracking people's contributions is
not really done in Discord itself this
group is not built for that and I don't
know what that ux looks like maybe it
looks like tasks uh you know like uh
maybe looks something different okay so
let me Linger on this thing we're
actually
uh that some people might not be even
familiar with Discord or slack or so on
even these platforms
have like communities associated with
them yes
meaning the the big like The Meta
community of people who are aware of the
feature set and that you can do a thing
that this is a thing and then you could
do a thing with it Discord like when I
first realized that I think it was born
out of the gaming world yes is like holy
[ __ ] this is like a thing there's a lot
of people that use this right there's
also a culture that's very difficult to
escape that's associated with Discord
that spans all the different communities
within Discord Reddit is the same even
though there's different subreddits
there's still because of the migration
phenomena may be there's still a culture
to Reddit and so on yes so I I'd like to
sort of try to dig in and understand
what's the difference between
the online communities that are formed
and the platforms on which those
communities are formed sure really
important yes it is it is so for example
an office a good design for an office is
frequently you have
um you know the uh the commons which is
like the lunchroom or the Gathering area
then everybody else has a cave on the
border they can kind of retreat to cave
in the gums I love by the way I was
laughing internally about the Heat
versus work I think that's gonna stick
with me that's such an interesting way
to see Twitter yeah like is this heat or
is this is this thread
like because there's a lot of stuff
going on right
is it just heat are we doing some like
is it is there a directed thing that's
gonna be productive at the end of the
day that's right love is um loversy
anyway it's a cave in the Commons is a
really nice
uh so that has to do with the layout of
an office that's effective that's right
and uh so you can think of many kinds of
social networks
um as being on the cave and Commons
Continuum for example Twitter is just
all Commons the caves are just like
individual DMS or DM threads or whatever
but it's really basically just one
gigantic Global public Fight Club for
the most part right then you have for
love Club well some would love but
mostly fight or actually I love
aggressively that's all yeah I mean the
way I think I mean Twitter is like a
cross between
uh you know a a library and a civil war
you know it's something where you can
learn and but but you can also fight if
you choose to fight right
um yeah well I mean it's um uh because
of its the commons structure of it it's
a mechanism of virality of
anything yeah so you just describe the
kind of things that become viral yeah
meaning no no offense to liberians it's
like a library and Liberia Liberia was
racked by Civil War for for many years
right uh libraries is one of my favorite
sets uh for porn just kidding jokes I'm
learning is that's probably crossing the
line uh for the engineers working on
this humor module maybe take that down
yes
um gosh uh we're just talking about oh
yeah so continue going continue to
Commons yeah so tutors are commons and
Facebook is like it's got all these
Warrens and stuff Facebook is very
difficult to reason about uh like
privacy on that and the reason is I
think it's easy to understand when
something is completely public like
Twitter or completely private like
signal and those are the only two modes
I think in which one can really operate
when something is quasi-private like
Facebook you have to just kind of assume
it's public because if if it's
interesting enough it'll go outside your
friend Network and it'll get
screenshotted or whatever and posted and
so you know Facebook is sort of sort of
forced into default public despite its
privacy settings uh you know for anybody
who says something interesting you know
if it's like uh you can figure out all
their dials and stuff like that but just
hard to understand unless it's totally
private or totally public right you have
to basically treat it if it's totally
public if it's not totally private okay
at least under a real name I'll come
back to pseudonym so you've got Twitter
that's that's total Commons Facebook
which is like a Warrens you know it's
like you know it's like rabbit worms or
like a ant colony where you don't know
where information is traveling then
you've got Reddit which has serve your
Global Reddit and then all the
subreddits that's a different model of
cave and Commons
I think one of the reasons it works is
that you have individual moderators
where something is totally off topic and
acceptable uh totally off topic and
unacceptable in this subreddit and
totally on topic and acceptable another
that's like kind of a you know a
precursor of the digital societies I
think that we're going to see that
actually become physical societies like
lots and lots of subreddit like things
you know become physical societies then
you start going further into like
Discord where it's it's more full
feature than
um you know as you go Twitter Facebook
Reddit now you jump into Discord and
Discord is a bunch of individual
communities that are connected and you
can easily sort of jump between them
right and then you have slack and you
know yes you can use
um slack to go between different company
slacks but slack historically at least
I'm not sure what their current policy
is historically they discourage public
slacks so there it's mostly like you
have your main slack for your company
and then you sometimes may jump into
like uh let's say you've got a design
consultant or or somebody like that
you'll jump into their slack but Discord
is you've got way more discords usually
that you jump into than slacks right
well and let me ask you then on that
point because there is a culture one of
the things I discovered on Reddit and
Discord of anonymity or pseudonyms or
usernames that don't represent the
actual name I'll select as an example of
one because I think I did a I used to
have a slack for like deep learning
course that I was teaching and I was
like very large like 20 000 people
whatever
but so you could grow quite large but
there's a culture of like I'm going to
represent my actual identity my actual
name and then the same stuff in Discord
I think I was the only [ __ ] using my
actual name on there it's like everybody
was using uh pseudonyms so what's what's
the role of that in the online community
well so I actually gave a talk on this a
few years ago called uh the pseudonymous
economy okay and um it's come back
faster than I expected uh but I did
think it was going to come about fairly
fast and essentially the concept is
obviously we've had so first antonym
pseudonym real name right can you
describe the difference between
difference Anonymous is like 4chan uh
where there's no tracking of a name
you're you know
there's your reputation associated with
an identity right pseudonymous is like
much of Reddit where there's a
persistent username and it has Karma
over time but it's not linked to a the
global identifier that is your state
name all right so your quote real name
even the term real name by the way is a
misnomer because it's like your Social
Security name like social security
number it's your official government
name it's your it's your state name it
is the tracking device it's a it's an
air tag that's put on you right why do I
say that right another word for a name
is a handle and so just visualize like a
giant file cabinet there's a handle with
Lex Freeman on it that anybody the
billions of people around the world can
go up to and they can pull this file on
you out images of you things you said
like billions of people can stalk
billions of other people now that's a
very new thing and I actually think this
will be a transitional era in like human
history we're actually going to go back
into a much more encrypted world
another way to see
real names is the label on a thing that
can be canceled yes that's right in fact
there's a book called seeing like a
state which actually talks about the
origins of surnames and whatnot like if
you have a guy who is that guy with
brown hair that's like an analog
identifier it could be in 10 different
people in a village but if you have a
first name last name okay that guy can
now be conscripted you can go down with
a list a list of digital identifiers
pull that guy out pull him you know into
the military for conscription right so
that was like one of the purposes of
names was to make masses of humans
legible to a state right hence seeing
like a state you can see them now right
see digital identifier is that one thing
that people don't usually think about is
pseudonymity is itself a form of
decentralization so you know people know
Satoshi Nakamoto was pseudonymous they
also know he's into decentralization but
one way of thinking about it is let's
say his real name okay or his state name
is a node okay attached to that is uh
every database you know his uh his Gmail
his you know Facebook if he had one
every government record on him right all
of these databases
have that state name as the foreign key
right
um and so it can go and look things up
in all of those uh databases right and
so it's a think of it as being the
center of a giant network of all of
these things when you go and create a
pseudonym you're butting off a totally
new node that's far away from all the
rest and now he's choosing to attach
bitcoinetalk and bitcoin.org and the gpg
signatures of the code if you choose to
do that
all those things digital signatures are
all attached to this new decentralized
name because he's instantiating it not
the government right one way of thinking
about it is the root administrator of
the quote real name system is the state
because you cannot simply edit your name
there right you can't just go you can't
log into usa.gov and backspace your name
and change it moreover
um your birth certificate all these
stuff that's fixed and immutable right
whereas we take for granted that on
every site you go to you can backspace
you can be like call me Ishmael you know
walk into a site you use whatever name
you want you just have to use the same
Name Across multiple sites you can do
that and if not you don't have to one
thing that we're seeing now actually is
at the level of kids you know the
younger generation
um Eric Schmidt several years ago
mentioned that you know people would
like change their names when they became
adults so that they could do that this
is kind of already happening people are
using a market that's been years ago
search resistant identities okay why
they have their finsta which is their
quote fake name Instagram M and rinsta
which is their real name Instagram this
is cool okay and what's interesting is
on their rinsta they're their fake self
because they're in their Sunday Best and
you know smiling and this is the one
that's meant to be search indexed right
on the finsta
with their fake name this is just shared
with their closest friends they're their
real self and they're you know hanging
out at parties or whatever you know and
so this way they've got something which
is the public Persona and the private
Persona right the public Persona that's
search indexed and the private Persona
that is private for friends right and so
organically people are you know like
Gene Jacobs she talks about like cities
and how you know they're organic and
when I like some of the mid 20th century
guys the architecture they had removed
shade from uh you know like like awnings
and stuff like that got removed so this
is like the restoration of like awnings
and shade and structure so that you're
not always exposed to the All-Seeing web
crawler that I have sore on which is
like Google botched indexing everything
these are search resistant identities
and that like I just sort of passes over
you like you know in The Terminator like
the Terminator I just kind of passes
over you right so Searchers and identity
is non-poled up it's not indexed right
and now you can be your real self and so
we've had this kind of thing for a while
while with communication the new thing
is that cryptocurrency has allowed us to
do it for transaction hence the
pseudonymous economy right and
um should go from Anonymous pseudonymous
real name these each have their
different purposes but
the New Concept is that pseudonym you
can have multiple of them by the way
your ens name you could have it under
your real name or state name like Lex
friedman.dth but it could also be uh
punk6529.eath okay and now you can earn
you can sign documents you can boot up
stuff you can have a persistent identity
here okay which has a level of
indirection to your real name why is
that very helpful because now it's
harder to both discriminate against you
and cancel you concerns of various
factions are actually obviated or at
least partially addressed by going
pseudonymous as default right it is the
opposite of bringing your whole self to
work it's bringing only your necessary
self to work right only show those
credentials that you need right now of
course you know anybody who's in
cryptocurrency understands social
Nakamoto and so on is for this but
actually many progressives are for this
as well why you don't ban the boxes
it's like you're not supposed to ask
about like felony convictions when
somebody is you know being hired because
they've paid they've served their time
right or
um you're not supposed to ask about
immigration status or marital status in
an interview
um and uh you know people have this
concept blind auditions where you know
uh if a woman is auditioning for for a
like a violin seat they put it behind a
curtain so they can't downgrade you know
her for playing her performance is
judged on the merits of its audible
quality not in terms of who who this
this person is so this way they don't
discriminate versus male or female for
um
for who's uh you know getting a violent
position so you combine those Concepts
like ban the Box not asking these
various questions blind auditions and
and then also the concept of implicit
bias like if you if you you know believe
this research people are unconsciously
biased towards other folks right okay so
you take all that you take Satoshi and
you put it together and you say okay
let's use pseudonyms that actually takes
unconscious bias even off the table
right because
um now you have genuine Global equality
of opportunity moreover you have all
these people billions of people around
the world that might speak with accents
but they type without them and now if
they're pseudonymous you aren't
discriminating against them right
moreover with AI very soon the AI
version of Zoom you'll be able to be
whoever you want to be and speak in
whatever voice you want to speak in
right and um you'll be and they'll
happen in real time uh so I mean this is
really interesting but I
for finsta and rinsta there's some sense
in which the fake Instagram
you're saying is where you could be a
real self well my question is under
uh under pseudonym or when you're
completely Anonymous is there some sense
where you're not actually being your
real self that as a social entity
it is human beings are fundamentally
social creatures and for us to be social
creatures there is some sense in which
we have to have a consistent identity
that can be canceled that can be
criticized uh or applauded in society
and that identity persists through time
so is there some sense in which we would
not be our full beautiful human selves
unless we have
a lifelong consistent real name attached
to us in a digital world so this is a
complicated topic but let me make a few
remarks versus real names quote unquote
state names were not built for the
internet they were actually state names
right it's actually a great way of
thinking about social security name
right
um so your state name your official name
was not built for the internet why they
give both too much information and too
little okay so too much information
because uh someone with your name can
find out all kinds of stuff about you
like for example uh someone doesn't want
to be stalked right
the real name is out there the stalker
knows it they can find address
information all this other kind of stuff
right
um and with all these hacks that are
happening just every day we see another
hack massive hack Etc uh that real name
can be indexed into Data That was
supposed to be private right like for
example you know the office of personnel
management like the government the US
government many governments actually are
like a combination of the uh
surveillance State and the Keystone Cops
right why they they slurp up all the
information then they can't secure it so
it leaks out the back door okay they've
they basically have you know 100 million
records of all just very 300 million
records all this very sense of data they
just get owned hacked over and over
again right and so really there should
be something which totally inverts the
entire concept of kyc and what have you
um and of course comply with the
regulations as they are currently
written but also you should argue
privacy over kyc the government should
not be able to collect what it can't
secure it's slurping up all this
information it's completely unable to
secure it it's hacked over and over
again you know China probably has the
entire OPM file and it's not just that
like Texas is hacked
um and some of these hacks are not even
detected yet right
and these are just ones that have been
admitted and so you know what happens is
criminals can just run this stuff and
find you know okay so that guy who's got
that net worth online and emerges
various databases they've got a bunch of
addresses to go and hit okay so in that
sense real names were not state names
were not built for the internet they
just give up too much information and R
actually existing internet environment
they give up too much information on the
other hand they also give too little why
if instead you give out uh Lex
friedman.eath okay or a similar crypto
domain name or Urban name or something
like that now that's actually more like
a DNS okay first if you've got a let's
like streaming.eth what can you do that
um some you can do today some you'll
soon be able to do uh you can pay live
stream you can message livestream.ed you
can
um look it up like a social profile you
can send files to it you can upload and
download basically it combines aspects
of an email address
um a a a website a username Etc et
cetera where you you know eventually I
think you'll go from email to phone
number to ens address or something like
that as the primary online identifier
because this is actually a programmable
name right whereas a state name is not
you know think about it like a state
name will have apostrophes perhaps in it
or is that your middle name or this and
that that was a format that was
developed for the paper world right
whereas the ens name is developed for
the online world now the reasons say ens
are something like it
you know somebody at a in a village
they'll their name might be Smith
because they were a blacksmith or Potter
because they were Potter right and same
way I think your surname
right now for many people it's not Ethan
that reflects the ethereum community
your surname online will carry
information about you like dot Saul says
something different about you dot BTC
says yet something different I think
we're going to have a massive
fractionation of this over time we're
still in the very earliest days of our
internet civilization right 100 200
years from now those surnames may be as
informative as say Chen or Friedman or
stream of Austin in terms of what
information they carry because the
protocol is the civilization
fundamentally that you're associated
with right right so that there's some
improvements to the real name that you
could do in the digital world but do you
think there's value of having a name
that's persists throughout your whole
life that is shared
between all the different digital I
think you should have the community I
think you should be able to opt into
that right at which at which level in
terms of the society that you're joining
wait a minute so can I murder a bunch of
people in society one
and then go to society too and be like
I'm murder free my no my name is I don't
mean it like that no yeah so but just by
that that's the application I'm
interested in okay well so what what
resistance
I would like you to talk about me sure a
person who's clearly bad for society
sure from doing that sure sure murder is
going to be against the rules in almost
every society and I mean basically I
mean people will argue yeah yeah most
likely right and um animals well I'm
thinking of like the Aztecs or the Mayas
or you know something like that there's
various you know Soviet Union there's
weird there's weird edge cases yeah
there's societies unfortunately that
have actually that's why that's why I
asked Tristan but let's say
murder is um something that society1
probably has effectively a social smart
contract or a social contract that says
that's illegal therefore you're in jail
therefore you're deprived of the right
to exit but upon entry into that Society
in theory you would have said Okay I
accept this quote social contract right
obviously if I kill somebody I can't
leave okay so you've you've accepted
upon crossing the border into there
right now
um as I mentioned you know uh like what
is murder like people will I mean
there's an obvious answer but as I said
there's been human sacrifice in some
cities communism they kill lots of
people Nazism they kill lots of people
unfortunately there's quite a lot of
societies you know I wanted to say it's
an edge case but maybe many of the 26th
Century societies around the world have
institutionalized some kind of murder
whether it's a Red Terror you know in
the Soviet Union or obviously the
Holocaust or you know the cultural
revolution or year zero and so on and so
forth right so my point there
is that who's committing all those
murders it was the state it was the
organization that one is implicitly
trusting them to track you right and how
do they commit this murders well how did
Lenin you know uh you know the hanging
order I'm talking about the hanging
order for the cool locks yes okay the
famous hanging order which actually
showed they were actually bloodthirsty
the key thing was he said here's a list
of all the quote rich men the cool locks
go and kill them the real names the
state names were facilitated the murder
didn't prevent the murderers there right
so my point is
just in the ethical waiting of it it's a
two-sided thing right you're right that
the tracking can you know prevent
disorganized murders but the tracking
facilitates unfortunately organized
murders lists of undesirables were the
primary tool of all of these oppressive
states in the 20th century
you see my point I I see your point and
it's a very strong point
in part it's a cynical point
which is that the rule of
a centralized state
is
more negative than positive
I think it is a it is like it's like
nuclear energy okay it's it's or it's
like fire
it is something which
um you're gonna keep having it reform
because there's there's good reasons
where you have centralization
decentralization recentralization but
power corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely and you just have to be very
suspicious of this kind of centralized
power the more trust you give it often
the less trusted it deserves
it's like a weird feedback loop right
the more trust the more it can do the
more it can do
the more bad things it will do so okay
there is a lot of downside to the state
being able to track you right and
history teaches us lessons one at a
large scale especially in the 20th
century at the largest of scale a state
can do commit a large amount of murder
and suffering and by the way history
isn't over if you think about what the
Chinese are building on this right that
surveillance state
it's not just tracking your name it's
tracking everything on you you know like
WeChat is essentially like it
it is all the convenience and none of
the freedom so that's the downside but
don't you the question is about is I
think probably fundamentally about the
human nature of an individual
of how
much murder that would be if we can just
disappear every time we murder well I
mean at the individual level so the
issue is basically like once once one
realizes that the moral trade-off has
two polls to it right and moreover that
basically centralized organized murder
has I mean if we add up all the
disorganized murder of the 20th century
it's probably significantly less than
the organized murder that was that these
states facilitated right and probably by
you know RJ Rommel has this thing called
democide right the thing is it's so Grim
right because you know it's saying like
one one death is a tragedy a million is
a statistic right these are just like
just incalculable tragedies that we
can't even you know uh understand but
um you know nevertheless engaging with
it like you know I don't know it's a
ratio 10x is it 100x I wouldn't be
surprised if it's 100 yeah but have you
seen the viciousness the negativity the
division within online communities that
have an anonymity so that's the thing is
basically you there's also a Scylla and
a charybdas I'm not you know when you
when you see what centralization can do
and you correct in the direction of
decentralization you can over correct
with decentralization and you get
Anarchy and this is basically then you
want to recentralize right and this is
the you know uh I think it's a Romance
of three kingdoms uh the Empire long
United must divide the Empire long
divided must unite that's always the way
of it right so it's going to happen is
we will state certain verbal principles
right and then the question is where in
state space you are are you too
centralized well then okay you want to
decentralize and are you too
decentralized and we want to centralize
it may track more right and people opt
into more tracking because they will get
something from that tracking which is a
great reduced societal stability so so
it's kind of like saying are we going
north or south and the answer is like
what's our destination where's our
current position in the in the
civilizational state space well my main
question I guess is
um does creating a network State Escape
from the some of the flaws of human
nature the reason you had got Nazi
Germany is a large-scale resentment with
different explanations for that
resentment that's ultimately lives in
the heart of each individual that made
up the entirety of Nazi Germany and it
had a charismatic leader that was able
to channel that resentment into action
into actual policies into actual
political and Military movements can't
you not have the same kind of thing in
digital communities as well have you
heard the term argumentum ad hitlerum or
like Godwin's law or something like you
know it's something where if the
reference point is Hitler it's just it's
this thing where a lot of things break
down but I do think I mean look is there
any
uh did Bitcoin manage to get where it
was without a single shot being fired to
my knowledge yes right it's a Google
manage to get to where it is without
shots being fired absolutely
um and while a lot of shots were being
fired elsewhere in the world sure and
but who's firing those shots right yeah
but that's because Bitcoin and Google
are a tiny minority of communities
that's it's like the the icing on the
cake of human civilization sure and
basically any technology I mean like you
can use uh you can use a hammer to go
and hit somebody with it right I'm not
I'm not saying every technology is
equally destructive or what have you but
you can conceive of it's kind of like
rule 34 but for technology right you
okay very you can you can probably
figure out the ability to reference
brilliant things throughout is quite
admirable yes but anyway sorry rule 34
for technology rule three four but for
abusive technology you can always come
up with a black mirror version of
something and in fact there is this kind
of funny tweet which is like a Sci-Fi
author my book don't invent the torment
Nexus was meant to be a cautionary Tale
on what you know would happen if Society
invented the trauma neckness and then
it's like uh Tech guys at long last we
have created the torment Nexus I don't
know right and uh so the thing is that
simply describing something some abuse
unfortunately
um after the initial shock wears off
people will unconsciously think of it as
sort of an attractor in the space right
it's like I'll give you some examples
like uh you know Minority Report had the
gesture thing right and the connect was
based on that so it's a dystopian movie
but had this cool kind of thing and
people you know kind of keyed off it
right or you know people have said that
movies like um you know full metal
jacket that was meant to be in my my
understanding is meant to be like an
anti-war movie but lots of you know
soldiers just love it you know despite
the fact that the drill sergeant is
actually depicted as a bad guy right for
the sort of portrayal of that you know
kind of kind of environment right so I'm
just saying it's like giving the vision
of like the digital Hitler or whatever
is not actually a vision I want to paint
I do think is it is it everything is
it's possible obviously you know isis
uses the internet right like is it yeah
I'm not I'm not bringing up Hitler
in a shallow argument we're bringing up
Hitler in a long empathetic relaxed
discussion which is which is where
Hitler can live in a healthy way so that
there is a there's deep left lessons in
Hitler and Nazi Germany
yes okay so in many ways uh you know and
this is a very superficial way of
talking about it but this is
um exit is the anti-genocide technology
right because exit is the route of the
politically powerless exit is not people
always say oh exit is for the rich or
that's actually not true most immigrant
most immigrants equals most immigrants
are not rich they're politically
powerless you can describe exit what is
exit so uh there's this you know book
which I reference a lot I like it um
called uh exit voice and loyalty by
Albert hirshman okay and he essentially
says
um and you know I I gave this talk uh in
2013 that that goes through this uh at
uh YC Straub school but just to describe
these
voices reform exits alternatives for
example in the context of an open source
project voices uh submitting a bug and
exit is forking in a company
um voices uh you're saying you know hey
uh here's a
um here's a ticket okay that I'd like to
get solved and exit is taking your
business elsewhere okay
um you know at level corporate
governance voices you know board
directors vote and exit is selling your
shares right in a country voices a vote
and exit is migration okay and
um I do think that the two forces we
talk about a lot democracy and
capitalism are useful forces
um but there's a third which is uh
migration right so you can vote with
your ballot you vote with your wallet
you can vote your feet wallet has some
aspects of exit built into it
um but voting your feet actually has
some aspects of voice built into it
because when you leave it's like an
amplifier on your vote you might say 10
things but you actually leave then
people take what you said seriously
you're not just like complaining or
whatever you you actually left San
Francisco because it was so bad on this
and this issue and you've actually voted
with your feet it is
um manifest preference as opposed to
state of preference so Voice versus exit
is this interesting dichotomy do you try
to reform the system or do you exit it
and build a new one or seek an
alternative and then loyalty modulates
this where if you are a patriot as part
of the initial part of your conversation
right like you know uh are you are you a
Trader you know you're giving up on our
great thing or whatever right
and you know people push those buttons
to get people to stick that's like you
know I should say the bad version let's
say a common version Sometimes good
sometimes bad
um then uh but then there's the good
version which is oh you know maybe the
price is down right now but you believe
in the cause so even if they're uh you
know on paper you you would rationally
exit you believe in in this thing and
you're gonna stick with it okay so
loyalty can be again good and bad but it
kind of modulates the trade-off between
voice and exit Okay so given that
framework we can think of a lot of
problems in terms of am I going to use
voice or exit or some combination drive
because they're not mutually so that
it's kind of like you know left and
right subjects needs to build together
I think that one of the biggest things
the internet does is it increases
microeconomic leverage and therefore
increases exit in every respect of life
for example
um you know on every phone you can pick
between Lyft and Uber right when you're
at the store uh you see a price on the
shelf and you can comparison shop right
if it's Tinder you can swipe right if
it's Twitter you can click over to the
next account the back button is exit the
The microeconomic Leverage leverage in
the sense of Alternatives right this is
like the one of the fundamental things
that the internet does it puts this tool
on your desktop and now you can go and
talk to an illustrator or you can kind
of build it yourself right by by typing
in some you know characters into Dolly
and that makes the positive forces of
capitalism more efficient uh increase in
microeconomic leverage and it's
individual empowerment right and so our
sort of Industrial Age systems were not
set up for that level of individual
empowerment just to give you like one
example to think about we take for
granted every single website you go and
log into you can configure your Twitter
profile and you can make it dark mode or
light mode and your name all this stuff
is editable right how do you configure
your USA experience
is there a usa.gov that you edit can you
even edit your name there doc mode uh
for USA but I mean just your profile is
there is there like a national profile I
mean there's like driver's license point
is that it's assumed that it's not like
individually customizable quite in that
way right of course you can move around
your house and stuff like that but it's
not like your experience of the US is
like configurable you know uh let me
think about that let me let me think
about sort of the analogy of it so the
microeconomic leverage you can switch
apps
can you switch your experience in in
small ways efficiently multiple times a
day in inside the United States
um well the physical world you do yeah
under the constraints of the physical
world you do like micro migrations so
this is coming back to the
hunter-gatherer farmer Soldier digital
Nomad kind of thing right the
the digital Nomad combines aspects of
the V1 and the V2 for a V3 right because
digital Nomad has the mobility and
freedom of the hunter-gatherer but some
of the consistency of the the
civilization of the farmer and Soldier
right but coming back to this like one
other thing about it is in the 1950s if
a guy in assembly line might literally
push the same button for 30 years okay
whereas today you're pushing a different
key every second
right that is that's like one version of
like microeconomic Leverage another
another version is you know in the 1980s
I mean didn't have Google Maps right so
you couldn't just like discover things
off the path people would just
essentially do you know home to work and
work to home and home to work and a trip
had to be planned right they were
contained within a region of space or
you do home to school school to home
home to school you know it wasn't like
you went and explored the map most
people didn't right they were highly
canalized okay meaning you know that it
was just back and forth back and forth
very routine just like the push the
button push the button trapped within
this very small piece and also trapped
within this large country because it was
hard to travel between countries and so
on again you know of course there were
vacations of course there was some
degree of news and so on your Mobility
wasn't completely crushed but it was
actually quite low okay relatively
speaking just the you you were you were
trapped in a way you weren't even really
thinking about it okay and now that map
is opened up now you can see the whole
map you can go all over the place
um you know I don't have the data to
show it but I would I'd be shocked if
people the average person didn't go to
more places wasn't you know doing more
you know going to more restaurants and
things like that today than they were in
the 80s simply because the map is open
okay and the the map is made more open
through the digital world the digital
world exactly so we're reopening the map
like the hunter-gatherer okay because
you can now think about every site for
very low cost that you can visit right
the digital world you can I mean how
many websites have you visited I don't
know hundreds of thousands probably at
this point over your life right how many
places on the services you're actually
unusual you might be like a world
traveler would have you right but still
even your even your physical Mobility is
less than your digital Mobility right
you can just essentially I mean the
entire Consular like Nations and borders
and whatnot didn't exist in the
hunter-gatherer hour right because you
couldn't
um you couldn't build permanent
fortifications and whatnot even even
Nations as we currently think of them
with like demarcated borders
um you did cartography you needed Maps
right that stuff didn't exist for a long
time you just had sort of a fuzzy area
of we kind of controlled this territory
and these guys are on the other side of
the river okay I think uh just I don't
want to digress too much but yeah we're
digress away I think entirety of life on
Earth is is a kind of a digression which
creates Beauty and complexity as part of
the digression I
I think your vision of the network state
is really powerful and beautiful I just
would want to linger on this let's talk
about it real name issues let me just
give you some data a personal anecdotal
experience data there's a reason I only
do this podcast in person
there is something lost in the digital
space oh sure and I find now I
personally believe
to play Devil's Advocate Against The
Devil's Advocate that I'm playing
I personally believe that this is a
temporary thing we will figure out
technological solutions to this but I do
find that currently people are much more
willing to be on scale cruel to each
other online yes and they are in person
uh the only the way to do that just
visit Ukraine went to the front the way
you can have people be cruel to each
other in the physical space is through
the Machinery of propaganda that
dehumanizes the other side right all
that kind of stuff that's really like
hard work to do online I find just
naturally the individual scale people
uh somehow start
to easily engage in the drug of mockery
derision and cruelty yes when they can
hide behind anonymity I don't know what
that says about human nature I
ultimately believe most of us want to be
good and have the capacity to do a lot
of good but sometimes it's fun to be
shitty to [ __ ] on people to be cruel I
don't know what weird is it's weird
because I think you know one of my
sayings is just like the internet
increases in microeconomic leverage the
internet increases variance for anything
that exists before you have you know the
zero and 100 versions of it I'll give
some examples and I'll come to this for
example you go from the 30-minute sitcom
to the 30 second clip or the 30 episode
Netflix binge right you go from guy
working 95 to uh the guy who's the you
know 40 years old and and has failed to
launch hasn't you know the doesn't have
a job or anything and the 20 year old
Tech billionaire okay you go from all
kinds of things that were sort of
gaussian in or kind of constrainable
location to kind of extreme outcomes on
both sides okay and uh applying that
here you are talking about the bad
outcome which I agree does happen with
the internet in some sense makes people
have very low empathy between others but
it also is the other extent where people
find their mental soul mates across the
world someone who's living in Thailand
or in you know like Latin America who
thinks all the same stuff just like them
wow you never met this person before
right you get to know them online you
mean in person it's like you know the
brains have been communicating for two
years three years you've been friends
and you see in person it's just great
right so it's actually it's not just the
total lack of empathy it is
frankly far more empathy than you would
be able to build usually with an
in-person conversation in the 80s or the
90s with someone on the other side of
the world because you might not even be
able to get a visa to go to their
country or not even know they existed
how would you be able to be able to find
each other and so on and so forth right
so it is kind of both it is tearing
Society apart and it's putting it back
together both at the same time my main
concern is this what I see
is that young people are for some reason
more willing to engage in the drug of
Cruelty online under the veil of
anonymity that's what you're seeing
publicly but you're not seeing the
private chats
like there's this it's kind of it's a
it's a I I work for the intelligence
agency
I'm collecting all of your data uh yeah
yes but you can Intuit stuff and I don't
think I'm being very selective I mean I
I if you if you just look at the Young
Folks I mean I am very concerned
about
the uh the intellectual
psychological growth of young men and
women so I'm I'm not disagreeing with
you on this I am saying however there is
a positive there that once we see it we
can try to amplify that yeah with
technology yes yes I'm just saying the
very very basic technology I give stuff
I I caught up over the weekend kind of
thing I think if I throw an anonymity on
top of that
it will lead to many bad outcomes for
young people anonymity yes pseudonymity
maybe not because Reddit is actually
fairly polite right
um the entirety of Reddit just chuckled
as you said that well well within it
within a subreddit it's actually fairly
polite like they say you're not usually
seeing it depends on which subreddit of
course there's a consistency there's a
right that uh the I think definition of
politeness is interesting here because
it's polite within the culture of that
subreddit yes the abide by let me put it
a different way they abide by the social
norms of that subreddit right and that's
the definition of politeness yeah or
civility is that right so there is an
interesting difference between
pseudonymous and Anonymous you're saying
it's possible that
pseudonymity
you can actually avoid some of the
negative aspects absolutely we're
re-dumbarizing the world in some ways
okay with China being the big
exceptional outlier you know the Dunbar
number 150 people
if you know that's that's like roughly
the scale of your Society right
um
or that's the number of people that a
human can kind of keep in in their brain
that's you know whether a Pocketful or
not I think I think it's probably
roughly true
and uh
we're re-dumbarizing the world because
a we're making small groups much more
productive and B we're making large
groups much more fractious right so you
have an individual like Notch you can
program Minecraft by himself or Satoshi
you could do V1 a Bitcoin by himself or
you know Instagram which is just like 10
people or Whatsapp which is like 50
people when they sold
um but the other hand you have huge
quote countries of hundreds of millions
of people that are just finding that the
first and second principle or the the
you know they're just splitting on
principal components you know whether
Scott Alexander thinks of them as
scissor statements you know the
statements that one group thinks is
obviously true one group thinks is
obviously false you can think of them as
political polarization you think of it
in terms of Game Theory there's lots of
different reasons you can get for why
this happens but those large groups now
are getting split and so you have both
the unsustainability of these large sort
of artificial groups and the
productivity of these small organic ones
and so that is kind of it's like sort of
obvious that's the direction of
civilizational rebirth we just need to
kind of lean into that
this is the statements there's so many
beautiful just like
um you know we mentioned chocolates
right advertising themselves your
entirety speech is an intellectual like
box of chocolates but okay so I don't
think we finished
defining the network State let's like
Linger on the the definition you gave
the one sentence statement which I think
essentially encapsulated the online
nature of it I forget what else
uh can we just try to bring more uh
richness to this definition of how you
think about the network State absolutely
so that informal sentences a network
state is a highly aligned online
community with a capacity for Collective
action that crowdfunds territory around
the world and eventually gains
diplomatic recognition from pre-existing
States so we talked about was the
alignment of online communities and the
capacity for Collective action well one
Collective action it could be a thousand
people liking a tweet right if you can
get a thousand of a thousand people
doing it but a much higher level much
higher bar is a thousand people
crowdfunding territory and actually
living together just like people
currently physical space in physical
space and not all in one place that's
critical just like Bitcoin is a
decentralized currency the network sees
a recipe for a decentralized state-like
entity okay where it starts with
um you know for example two people just
get you know they become roommates they
meet in this community they become
roommates okay they get their place
together or 10 people get a group house
or eventually 100 people just buy a
small apartment building together and
guess what they start getting Equity not
just paying rent okay these are all
people who share their values and now
they can crowdfund territory together
now of course they don't just jump
straight from a thousand people liking
something to a thousand people
crowdfunding something what I described
in the middle is you do a lot of meetups
you get to know these other people
before you decide to live you know
collectively with them but once you live
with them you start to get a network
effect for example if those 100 people
want to learn Spanish or Turkish or
Vietnamese they could all have a
building where they're doing Vietnamese
immersion right and that's something
which they get a benefit from being
physically around the other people that
the pure digital wouldn't give them to
quite the same extent right
um and so crowdfund territory around the
world crucially not just one place
they're all connected by the internet
just like Hawaii is 2 000 miles away
from the Continental us but both sides
think of them as American but the people
on Hawaiian people in the continent yes
what's the role of having to have
territory if most of the exchange so
presumably as technology gets better and
better the communication the intimacy
the exchange of ideas all happens in the
digital world what's the importance of
being able to crowd fund territory well
because we're still physical creatures
you you can't reproduce yet digitally
right there's still lots of things it's
all about sex well that's got to be part
of it you're going to want to you know
reproduce are we talking about a cult
well like what is that it's not a call
you know why can't you just like take a
trip why is it not a cult it's not
called because a cult is very internally
focused and it's it's it tries to close
its members off from the outside world
this is much more how America itself was
populated where there were lots of towns
like Penn is named after William Penn or
the founder of Texas like Sam Houston
right lots of towns like the Oneida
commune in in you know Northern New York
they've recruited and they became a town
and they became actually the Oneida
um glassware company kind of you know
makes makes glassware out of there all
of these communities are opt-in
voluntary communities
we're not simply like Cults that were
closed off from the world they were
meant to set an example to the world of
what virtuous living looked like and
they were trying to recruit from the
rest World they were exporting Goods to
the rest of the world right so it is um
it's yes reproduction it's you know
marriage and kids and so on but it's
also just hanging out and it is just the
physical world is very high bandwidth
there's lots of stuff you know it's fun
to just go and have a dinner in person
just to hang out and build things
moreover there's also lots of innovation
that can only take place in the physical
world
um you know look I'm you know one of my
sayings in the book is cloud first land
last but not land never
okay in many ways what one of the
problems the book solves is Teal's
problem of you know we have innovation
in bits but not in atoms right we can
build a billion dollar Company online
but we need a billion permits to build a
shed in San Francisco right how do you
reconcile that well
what is stopping the Innovation atoms it
is a Thicket of regulations what are
those regulations ultimately a social
construction if you lean into the you
know whole deconstructionist you know
School of thinking you can deconstruct
and then reconstruct the state itself
given sufficient social consensus online
okay if the population Nevada had 100
consensus you could just dissolve every
law in Nevada in theory and then build
new ones okay so the online consensus of
getting people to agree on something is
Upstream of what happens offline
so once you have consensus in bits the
human consensus also you know
cryptographic consensus cryptocurrency
consensus
then you can reshape the world of atoms
the reason we can't reshape the world of
atoms right now is because you don't
have that consensus of Minds okay for
example in SF anything you do there's
going to be 50 of people who are against
you like so that's just a recipe for
gridlock whereas if you have a bare
piece of land that everybody agrees on
you can get you know 70 000 units get
set up in burning man in just a few days
okay that's the power of what when you
actually have human consensus and one
way I talk about this also in the book a
little bit and this isn't going to go
much more into detail into V2 I think
that this says 100 democracy as opposed
to 51 democracy 51 democracy which is
the current form of government is 49
dictatorship because the entire premise
of democracy is about the consent of the
government right that's actual
legitimating underpinning principle and
uh in so far as 49 did not consent to
the current you know president or prime
minister or whatever
um let's say presidential system first
pass the post okay
um insofar as 49 did not consent or in a
in a prime minister system it could be
like 60 or more didn't consent to the
current leader those folks are having
something imposed on them that they did
literally did not vote for moreover
campaign promises are non-binding so
whatever they voted for they can
effectively be defrauded you know the
actual voter fraud is when a politician
promises X but does not do it it's as if
you bought a can of orange juice and it
actually drinking its milk or it's
nothing right so all of that is
routinized all of that is accepted we
have this thing which is just the
minimum possible amount of democracy of
51 okay and what happens is then that 50
interested to Ram something down the 49
throat and then the next election it's
now 51.49 the other way and then they
Ram it back and that's how you get the
Seesaw that is just splitting countries
apart right the alternative to that is
you build a consensus online you go and
get some God forsaken patchy territory
actually the worst the territory the
better why because it's like burning man
nobody cares right the nicer the piece
of land the more the people are going to
argue about it but starlink has repriced
the world basically all kinds of pieces
of territory that were previously you
know they're far away from natural ports
they're far away from natural resources
all kinds of pieces of territory around
the world now have satellite internet
and so what you can do is again the map
is being reopened right we were talking
about earlier the map is being reopened
you can gather your community online
they're now capable of collective action
you can point here this place has great
Starling coverage you go there like the
Verizon guy you know can you hear me now
good right you see that the coverage is
good there you drive out there you test
it out maybe you do it with mobile homes
first right this by the way is its own
thing
there's DMB and there's there's nimbi
and there's EMB but I actually also like
himbi okay
what are those so NIMBY is not in my
backyard don't build in cities yimby is
let's build high density buildings
really tall buildings and so on cities
there's a third version which uh is
Hindi uh it's my little coinage which is
horizontal sprawl is good why horizontal
small because to build a skyscraper to
build a tall building in a city you have
this enormous permitting process all of
this stuff which has to get done it's
expensive it's time consuming the way
that cities were built if you go back to
the V1 what does the startup City look
like it looks like something like
burning man it looks like the cities of
the Wild West they were not multi-story
buildings right they were basically
things that were just like one story and
someone could have it there in the dust
and then you build roads and stuff
between them they can move them around
it was a much more Dynamic geography and
so when you have that as a vision of
what a startup City looks like right now
you've got something there's there's a
company I found it called kift which is
like van life there's a lot of stuff in
construction that that makes us feasible
there's so-called man camps uh for for
fracking um where people can just do
like like companies like a Greco their
power uh you can bring water all the
stuff on site so it's easy to actually
snap this stuff to grid relatively
speaking if you've got horizontal space
you pick the space you crowd from the
territory now you've got a city okay and
the last bit is uh eventually again's
diplomatic recognition from pre-existing
States and this is the part that people
you know different people will be with
me up to this point and then they'll say
okay that's the part I disagree with or
how are you going to ever do that right
they'll say yeah you can build an online
community I believe you can get them to
do Collective action and of course
people have crowdfunded land and moved
in together doing at a larger scale all
that I believe how are you possibly ever
going to gain diplomatic recognition
from pre-existing States you dumb
delusional Tech bro right that's a
common thing okay that's about the tone
of it as well right and so first I would
say uh sovereigns are already out for
business they're inking deals okay uh
Nevada aimed to deal with Tesla to build
the geiger Factory El Salvador has
Bitcoin as its National currency Wyoming
has done the Dow law where ethereum is
now recognized where you can have
on-chain incorporations that are
recognized by Wyoming law
um Virginia and New York negotiate with
Amazon for hq2 tuvalu signed a deal with
GoDaddy for the dot TV domain Columbia
signed a deal for the dot Co domain and
on and on on sovereigns are open for
business sovereigns are doing deals with
companies and and with currencies
sovereigns at the level of cities like
Miami or New York where the Mayors are
accepting their their salary in Bitcoin
um States like you know Wyoming or
Nevada has its new private cities
legislation or entire countries like El
Salvador So when you say Sovereign by
the way you mean the old school physical
nation states governments Fiat States
Fiat States okay but but the Fiat isn't
the thing that makes a state well maybe
no it's a state's geographical location
it is is something where uh they're both
right so basically it's a play on word
so just like fiat currency and
cryptocurrency we will have Fiat oh
country right and crypto country right
and in fact you can think of the Fiat
and crypto version of almost anything
one thing I'll come to later is a big
thing the big thing I think comes after
digital currency is digital passports
okay so and that's a big part of this
this whole networks I think we should
come back to but
so that last bit the reason I just
mentioned all those deals between
sovereigns whether at the city
U.S state or U.N listed country level
okay and on the other hand so that's on
one side of the market and the other
side are the
um companies and the currencies why
could we not have online communities
right so so let me uh making those sales
so uh diplomatic recognition
but are aren't you still
attached to the responsibilities uh that
come from being a member of a sovereign
old-school nation-state so can you
possibly Escape that so yes and let me
give you a concrete example Israel okay
why
um you know people talk about you know a
lot of people are like oh abology just
he took this from snow crash or some
sci-fi book they'll reference remember
actually if there's many different
references of the book this is not the
only reference but a very important
reference that I think is much more
important to me than snow crash which is
which is good a good book whatever but
it's fictional is George by Theater
herzl which translates as the Jewish
State and that led to the foundation of
Israel and that's very real it's worth
reading because it's amazing theater
herzl was like a tech founder okay in
the book he was writing about the death
of distance in 1897 why because
steamships could take you across you
know countries okay and he like it's
just you know amazingly smart and
practical guy we just handled all these
various objections and he said look
you know the Jewish people you know our
choices are either a assimilate and get
up the culture or B some people are
thinking communism is a good idea I
distribute that we should do c build our
own country right and that was
considered totally crazy what we did was
he a wrote a book b started to fund C
organized a semi-annual conference the
you know World Zionist Congress and the
fund and the Congress are still going
today crucially there were a bunch of
intermediate stages between the book and
the idea and then the actual state of
Israel in 1947 for example
um that you know the folks who were
committed zionists got together and
started crowdfunding territory in what
is now Palestine and in fact though
Palestine was only one choice in the
book they also had Argentina as a choice
this is my concept Cloud first land last
and lands a parameter you can choose
right other places that were considered
at various points like Madagascar
birobitzen and the former Soviet Union
right so the land was a parameter
Palestine went out because of its you
know historical religious importance now
by the way one thing I'm sure are some
like some fraction of yours will be like
oh my God like all the bad stuff to have
I'm obviously not denying that there's
enormous amounts of controversy and so
on that attends Israel I consider myself
generally produce really I'd also
consider myself Pro Palestinian I fund
lots of Palestinians and so so I've I'm
leaving that part out that huge conflict
or you know for for now okay and you
might say that's airbrushing it I don't
mean it to do that I'm saying here is
the positive things they did can we take
the positive and not have the negative
and I'll come back to how we we might
swap those parts out but let me just
talk about this a little bit more so one
of the things that happened was
committed zionists went in crowdfunded
territory in what is now Israel and they
knit it together right why because when
you're physically present on territory
yes in theory like the the British
Empire wasn't controlled Over The
Sovereign okay in practice who were the
boots on the ground the facts on the
ground right there's the people who are
actually tilling the land and building
the buildings and so and so forth it
like who had the claim there it's like
the people who are present okay now
um this this territory this network of
territories eventually
um became the basis for or part of the
basis for what became Israel now
I'm fully aware that the exact
configuration of what territory belongs
Israel what territory belongs
Palestinians this is an enormous topic
of dispute okay but I just point this
out to say the process going from book
to crowdfang territory to a sovereign
state where people were now citizens of
Israel as opposed to the British Empire
is not some fictional thing but did
happen and within the lifetimes of some
of the older you know they're in their
80s now but in the lifetimes of some
older people okay so so it's not
impossible in fact it has happened right
okay but for that step then perhaps
hopefully is a better example because in
this particular like you said land last
if I were to set up it was if I was an
alien and arrived at Earth and say
choice of land maybe if you were
interested in uh create choosing a land
that represents a network state where
ideas that unites a people
uh based on ideas maybe pick a land that
doesn't lead to uh generational conflict
and War so I'll get to that destruction
and suffering and all that also that's
right so
so now that I've set what are you know
the positive things about Israel and I
think there's a lot to admire initial as
I said I think there's also a lot to
matter in the Palestinians and so on I'm
not taking any position on that there's
other Inspirations for the network State
the second major inspiration is India
which managed to achieve independence
non-violently
right that's very important right so can
you can you fuse these things right
State started with a book that achieved
Independence non-violently okay and that
managed to build this polyglot you know
Multicultural democracy right that does
you know like you know India has its
flaws but it does manage to have you
know human rights of lots of people
respected and what have you right
and um has managed to you know there
were times like emergency in the 1970s
in their Gandhi declared emergency there
were times when seeing touch and go but
overall with fits and starts this flawed
thing has kind of made its way through
and you know the third inspiration is
Singapore with Lee Kuan Yew who built a
city-state from nothing you know I
shouldn't say it for nothing okay there
was something there but let's say I
built one of the richest countries in
the world without like huge amounts of
Natural Resources in the middle of a
Zone where there was lots of Communist
Revolution going on
um and so he was the CEO founder
essentially of this amazing startup
country right and
um you know finally of course America
which has too many influences to name
things we talked about the nation of
immigrants obviously the Constitution
and so on and you think okay can we go
you think of uh you know these
Inspirations what's interesting about
these four countries by the way Israel
India Singapore and the US they have
something in common you know what that
is who's that they're all Forks of the
UK codebase
we think obviously you know the UK was
sort of the ancestor of America but
Israel was a former British colony right
the India was a British colony and so
Singapore right and for people who don't
know what fork and code base means it's
uh language from versioning systems
particularly git represented online on a
website called GitHub and a fork means
you copy the code and all the changes
you make to the code now live in their
own little world so America took the
ideas that defined the United Kingdom
and then
forked it by evolving those ideas in a
way that didn't affect the original the
original country that's right and what's
interesting about this is and of course
I'm saying that in a somewhat playful
way right but I think it's a useful
analogy interesting analogy right so you
have the Americans who forked you know
the UK code base and then you have you
know the Indians Israelis and the
singaporeans who also made their own
modifications and in some ways each
Society has pieces that you can take
from them and learn from them and try to
combine them right so you have a state
that is started by a book that
um non-violently assembles that
crowdfunds territory around the world
that is led by a CEO founder
um and that is also governed by
something that's like a constitution but
just like you went from you know I talk
about the V1 V2 and V3 a lot right like
V1 is gold and V2 is Fiat and V3 is
Bitcoin right or V1 is hunter gatherer
and b2's farmer Soldier V3 is digital
Nomad or Sovereign Collective okay which
is not just an individual but a group
um here V1 is UK common law they don't
have a constitution it's all precedent
going for many years right V2 is the US
Constitution and V3 is the Smart
contract the social smart contract which
is a you know Fusion obviously of
Rousseau's concept of the social
contract and the smart contract the
social smart contract is like written in
code okay so it's like even more
rigorous in the Constitution and in many
ways you can think of going from the
United Kingdom of uh England Wales you
know Scotland Northern Ireland the
United States of America the network
states of the internet okay where you go
from the rights of Englishmen with the
Magna Carta to Europeans
African-Americans all the immigrants to
the the you know the Americans or the um
you know North America then you've got
all the people of the world
and uh so you you basically are more
democratic and you're more capitalist
because you're talking about internet
capitalism not just Niche and state law
capitalism in a sense it's the V3 right
another way it's a V3 only about two
percent of the world
um is uh over 35 native born American
can qualify to be president of the
United States
but 100 of the world you could become
the president of a network state there
might be a you know Palestinian
Washington or a you know Brazilian
Hamilton right and now rather than say
okay maybe you're maybe you have a small
percentage chance of immigrating to the
US and a small percent chance of your
descendant you know becoming like you
know a president now we can just say you
can start online
and you know what maybe this person is
so exceptional they have Americans
coming to their you know Network state
right you don't think that kind of thing
is possible with like the rich get
richer in a digital space too the people
with more followers
uh have friends that have followers and
they like I don't think it's a rich get
richer I think what happens is
um so this is an important concept it is
it's multi-axis right that is to say for
example
um just the introduction of the Bitcoin
axis right uh and those you because it
didn't exist pre-2009 now it exists
um those people who are rich in BTC
terms are only partially correlated with
those who are rich in USD terms there's
all these folks essentially BTC is
Bitcoin and USD is US dollar yes
so that's a new axis and eth is yet
another axis right you ethereum eth is
ethereum right so you are essentially
getting
new social systems which are actually
net inequality decreasing because before
you only had USD Millionaires and now
you have a new track and then another
track and another track right you have
different hierarchies different ladders
right and so on net you have more
ladders to climb and so it's not the
rich getting richer in fact old money in
some ways is a last to cryptocurrency
um old money and old States I think
those people who are the most focused on
you might call it reform I would call it
control okay the most focused on control
the old world who have the least
incentive to switch
they will the rich will get poorer
because it will be the poor or those who
are politically powerless politically
poor who go and seek out these new
States yeah I I didn't mean in the
actual money but yes okay there's other
ladders I meant in in terms of influence
political and social influence in uh
these new network States you you I think
said that basically anybody can become
president of a network State just like
anybody can come see you have a startup
company of course whether people follow
you it's another matter but anybody can
go and found one go ahead sorry oh from
the perspective that anyone can found
one anyone could found
I see we don't think it's implausible
that uh you know somebody from Brazil or
Nigeria I mean most quote billionaires
in the world are not American and in
fact actually here's another important
point it's far easier to become a tech
billionaire than become or a billionaire
period than become president of the
United States there's less than 50 U.S
presidents ever all time okay it is a
much more realistic ambition to become a
billionaire than become president
there's like thousands of billionaires
for what in fact 75 of them are outside
the US and many of those have been you
know some of them are like energy and
oil which is often based on political
connections but a very large chunk of
the rest are Tech okay and uh that's
something where you're mining but you're
mining online by hitting Keys as opposed
to with the pickaxe you know in Granite
right so the point is that we think it's
totally understandable today for there
to be a you know huge founder who comes
out of Vietnam or you know South America
like that like you can name Founders
from all over the world right
exceptional people can rise from all the
world to run giant companies why can
they not rise to run giant new countries
and the answer has been developed a
mechanism yet right
um and just as another example I talked
about this in the book
the talibutarin is far more qualified
than Jerome Powell right or anybody at
the Federal Reserve he actually built a
car and managed a monetary policy in a
currency from scratch
okay as a 20-something
right obviously that's a more
accomplished person than somebody who
just inherited an economy this is a lot
of people can push back at that and say
that the the people that initially build
a thing aren't necessarily the best ones
to manage a thing once it scales and
actually has impact sometimes sometimes
but Zuck has done a good job of both I
think vitalik has done a good job of
both right that's not an inherent truth
well so actually you built the thing you
will be the best person to run it I will
agree with you on that and actually I
talk about this in the book uh or I've
got an essay on this called founding
versus inheriting okay and the premise
is actually that the classic example you
know the saying shirt sleeves to shirt
sleeves in three generations it means
the guy who starts out poor and builds a
fortune his son maintains it and his
dissipate grandson dissipates it right
why is short sleeves a symbol of poverty
well back in the past it was kind of
like you know you're just working with
your you're not you're not white collar
you're back to working with your hands
you're just oh
yeah yeah we're working class or
something like that right so essentially
that the the grandson squanders it right
and you know in sense by the way
um just to talk about that for a second
if you have two children and four
grandchildren and eight
great-grandchildren and 16 and so on and
an older family is you know they were
much bigger right six you know children
is not uncommon whatever Fortune you
have is now split six ways and then six
ways and six ways again so with the
exception of primogeneature where the
oldest son inherits all the way down the
majority of your descent is just a few
Generations out have probably inherited
none of that fortune unless it has
compound to such an extent that it's
like up 6X over 20 years right so it's
actually hard to maintain a quote rule
in class in the sense that this person
who's like four generations down has you
know uh like 1 16 of the DNA you know
one over two to the fourth right
of their their cyan who built a fortune
so it's not even like the same is it the
same family even right is the fortune
actually in the family so most people
don't think a few Generations out they
just kind of think oh Marx is right
there's always been a rich and a poor
it's actually much more Dynamic than
that because you literally like what is
even the family when it's diluted out
you know 1 16th right
um if you're 1 16 the Rockefeller are
you a rock filler whether you're 15 16
something else would you have the
Rockefeller Fortune probably not right
now are there's again primogenitor where
the guy who inherits the name all the
way through
um
that would be one way to pass it down
but even that person doesn't necessarily
have the qualities of the guy who you
know the cultural qualities of other
qualities guys like four generations
past they tend to squander it right so
this actually brings us to you know
coming back up to governance the system
the the guys who built the United States
you know like Washington and Hamilton
these are giants right these are
founders and the the folks today are
like not the the grandson but like the
40th generation heir of a factory that
somebody else built like think about a
factory and you have you know this
grandchild or great grandchild that
inherits a factory most the time it's
just cranking out widgets and the Greek
grandson is cashing checks they have
been selected as legitimate Heir because
it's the you know the founder passes
down to his son Pastor Jones's grandson
just great grandson so legitimacy is
there they've got title they can show I
own this Factory okay
they can cash the checks there's
professional managers there everything
seems fine until one day that factory
has to go from making you know widgets
to making masks for covet or something
else it has to change directions to do
something it hasn't done before none of
that capability for invention and
reinvention is present anymore these
people have inherited something that
they could not build from scratch
because they could not build from
scratch they can't even maintain it this
is an important point the ability to
build from scratch is so important
because if some part breaks and you
don't know why it was there can you even
maintain it no you can't okay unless all
the replacement parts in the know-how to
fit them together is there you can't
repair this so in 2009 Mother Jones had
a story that said that the U.S military
had forgotten how to make some kinds of
nuclear weapons because there's a part
where all the guys who knew how to make
it had like aged out or left okay and
this was some like Arrow gel or
something like that it was it was
rumored okay
thing is
um you're seeing you know increasingly
for example you've got uh wildfires in
California you've got you know water
that's not potable in Jackson you've got
power outages in Texas
um you're seeing a lot of the
infrastructure of the US is just less
functional
I think probably part of that is due to
civil engineering not being that sexy
field people aging out and just domain
knowledge being lost and The Heirs who
win you know the role of mayor or
whatever of this town don't have the
ability to build it from scratch or just
selected for legitimacy not competence
okay so once you think about this
concept of founding versus inheriting
and I've got the whole essay which talks
about this
um of course the alternative to somebody
who's legitimate but not competent what
people will say is oh we need like uh
you know an authoritarian to be in
control of everything and then their
their hope is that that person is
competent but they don't have legitimacy
because if they're just installed it's
just like a authoritarian ruler 50 of
the population is really mad at them
they don't have title just grab the
title you know maybe they can exert
enough Force but that's the problem with
kind of the authoritarian you know
dictator or takeover right so the
alternative the third version is the
founder who combines both legitimacy and
competence because they start from
scratch and they attract people to their
vision and they build it from scratch
and so you need is the ability to
constantly do refoundings rebirths so if
you imagine a world that is primarily
Network States
can you help me
imagine what that looks like
now there's several ways to imagine
things which is how many of them are
there and how often do they the new ones
pop up there could be thousands given
seven billion people eight billion
people on Earth yeah yeah so there's
Network state in the like the precise
definition I have in the book which is a
diplomatically recognized entity and
there's never seen sort of the loose
definition where you know one thing
that's interesting is this term has
become a lowercase term really fast okay
yeah like in the sense of Google became
lowercase Google for like Googling or
like uber became lowercase Uber like if
you go to the networkseed.com front
session reviews or you go to
search.twitter.com and put put in
network State you'll see it's just
become like a word or a phrase okay so
that means it's sort of whatever I
intend it to mean people will use it to
mean what they want it to me right okay
right the internet you've become well
first like you're a meme and this book
is a meme am I a meme okay maybe I mean
but the the book is a book that I think
is a good meme that's actually why I
wanted to make it free I wanted people
to take it out there make it their own
and one of the things I say at the
beginning and I'll come back to this
thing is it's a toolbox not a Manifesto
even if you dislike 70 of it eighty
percent of it 90 of it if there's
something that's useful to you you can
take that and use it just like a like a
library you know a software Library you
might just use one function there great
I'm glad I've delivered you some value
right that's my purpose in this right
you're not iron Rand no I'm not Iran
basically the whole point of this
actually is it's it's polytheistic poly
statistic poly domestic it's genuinely
is it polyamorous it's not polyamorous
okay
um though somebody might have love
advice in the book I didn't I didn't see
it so did you talk about love and I do
not talk about love uh rather maybe not
to you not that I don't believe in love
love is great all right I will accept
you offer to write a guest chapter in
your in your V2 book about love all
right great
um uh because there is some aspect
that's very interesting which at which
parts of human civilization require
physical contact physical uh because it
seems like more more can be done in a
digital space yeah but as I said we work
for example but you're not going to
build a self-driving car city in digital
space you're not going to be able to do
all cars at all well you're well sure
sure but let's say you're not going to
be able to get to Mars in a purely
digital thing you need to build you know
you have a little rocket launch pad
you're not going to be able to do all
the Innovative biomedicine whether it's
you know all the
um you know have you seen bioelectricity
or there's there's stuff on regenerative
medicine stems all this stuff you you
just can't do that digitally right we're
still physical beings you know so you
need physical space but how do we get
that right so that this is this is meant
to wind its way through various
roadblocks in the so-called you know
actually my term from many years ago the
idea is it's been to wind its way
through that year maze to find how to
use bits to re-lock unlock innovation in
atoms the idea is within the bigger
prime number maze or go back to
visualizing the number of states and how
often are they born so let me first let
me first anchor this because people just
to give some numbers right how many U.N
listed countries are there like 196 193
okay and there's some that are on the
border like Taiwan or Israel right uh
where they're not I mean Israel is a
country but it's not recognized by every
country or what have you right is Texas
a country
no but um right okay so within that list
of about 200 countries okay I've got a
graph in the book that shows that most
countries are actually small countries
um about there's 12 countries that have
less than 100 000 people by the UN
definition of a country there's another
20 something that have between 100 000
and 1 million
a generator 50 or 60 something that have
between a million and 10 million so most
countries
in the UN are less than 10 million
people there's only 14 countries that
are over 100 million people okay so most
countries are small countries is kind of
surprising to us because most people
live in big countries okay and uh so now
you're like okay well I've built social
networks that are bigger than that I've
you have a following this bigger than a
hundred thousand people you're following
that's bigger than you know a small
country like cure body or what have you
right and uh okay so that that first
change is feasibility you think of a
country as this huge huge huge thing if
it's actually smaller than many many
countries are smaller than social
networks that you've built okay number
one uh number two
is the number of U.N listed countries
um even though it's been flat-ish for
the last 30 years with like you know a
few things like South Sudan and East
Timor that that have come online there's
a graph that I posted which shows that
it's increased by about from about 40 or
50 something at the end of uh World War
II
um when the end was set up to 197 today
there's been like kind of a steady
increase in particular with all the
decolonization all the countries that
got their independence first from the
British Empire and then from the Soviet
Empire right that imperial breakup led
to new countries okay and so the
question is is that flat forever
well the number of new currencies
similarly increased for a while roughly
one per country or thereabouts
and then it was flat for a while and
then suddenly it's gone completely
vertical
that's an interesting graph right where
it's like linear ish then it's flat and
then it just goes like this now you can
Define you can you can argue where the
boundary is for quite a new currency
okay
um but I think Bitcoin certainly counts
I think ethereum certainly counts in
terms of just its scale and adoption
worldwide so at least you have two
if you take the broad Church view you
have a thousand or something like that
right somewhere in between you might say
how many currencies are above the market
cap of an existing previously recognized
fiat currency like which got onto the
leaderboard right there's a website just
like coinmarketcap.com that's like a
site for like cryptocurrency tracking is
very popular okay there's a fun site
called fiatmarketcap.com which shows
where Bitcoin is relative to the Fiat
currencies of the world and it's like
last night checklist number 27 somewhere
in between
um the Chilean Peso and the Turkish lira
or something okay and had previously
been close to crack in the top ten okay
and I think it will will again at some
point so we know that you can have a
currency out of nowhere that ranks with
the Fiat currencies of the world could
you have a country out of nowhere that
ranks with the countries of the world so
this is this is maybe the fastest way
you probably should have said this at
the very beginning if you go to the
network state in one image okay that
kind of summarizes what a number state
looks like in a visual just one single
Visual and the visual is of a dashboard
and the dashboard shows something that
looks like a social network except
you're visualizing it on the map of the
world
and it's got Network nodes all over the
place 100 people here a thousand people
there they're all connected together the
total population of the people in this
social network is about 1 million uh
people so 1.7 million people in this
example
and some of the buildings are some of
the people are just Singletons they're
just folks in their apartment who can
conceptualize themselves as citizens of
this network State and they've got the
flag on their wall right and the digital
passport on their on their uh
um phone along with the digital currency
others are groups of hundreds or
thousands or even tens of thousands of
people that have all taken over a
neighborhood just like chinatowns exist
right just like you know
um uh intentional communities existed uh
they just basically you know go in
crowdfund lane together right and these
are all networked together you know just
like the islands of Indonesia are
separated by ocean these are islands of
this network state that are separated by
internet okay so it conceptualize
themselves as something and at the very
top of the dashboard there's something
very important which is the population
annual income and real estate footprint
of this network shape so population we
already discussed you can build an
online social network we know you can
build something which has a population
that's bigger than these hundred
thousand or million person countries
one of the new things contributions in
network state has
say that you cannot just succeed in
population you can exceed in real estate
footprint because one way to think about
it is
um I don't exactly know the numbers on
foreign ownership in Estonia but let's
say to first order the million something
estonians own and could afford Estonia
okay a million people
could buy a territory that is the size
of Estonia right that's probably true to
for sure there might be some overseas
ownership but it's probably true okay
you probably find a country for which
that's true what that means is
a million people digitally could buy
distributed territory that is probably
greater than or equal to the size of
Estonia especially if they're buying
like desert territory or stuff like that
which means now you have a digital
country that is ranking not just in
people
not just in real estate footprint you
know so so it's also in real estate with
the with the countries of the world so
you start ranking and you're bigger than
these unlisted countries in your
population and your real estate and the
third is income okay you can prove on
chain that you have a income for the for
the digital population that is above a
certain amount right this is what I call
the census of the network State and it's
actually such a crucial component that I
have it in you know the essay uh the
Network's in a thousand words the post
office and census were actually
important enough to be written into the
US Constitution okay
um partly because it was like for
apportionment of Representatives partly
because there's a feedback mechanism and
so that census was done every 10 years
and it's provided a crucial snapshot of
the US for the last several hundred
years okay now here this this census of
a digital State could be done every 10
seconds okay conducting it is actually
not the hard part you know the hard part
is
proving it because
how will the world believe that you
actually have a hundred thousand people
spread across countries couldn't there
all be Bots could be ba AIS proof of
human
proof of income and also proof of real
estate start to actually rise
dramatically in importance because
you're saying we're going to rank this
digital State on the leaderboard of the
the Fiat States okay and so it means
that people will start to at first
they'll just laugh at it once you start
claiming you have 10 000 citizens
people are going to start poking and be
like Is that real prove that it's real
okay
so I have a whole talk on this actually
I'm giving it this uh channeling
conference but essentially how do you
prove this right the short answer is
crypto oracles plus auditing the summer
longer answer is
you put
these assertions on chain these proof of
human
um these proof of real estate Etc
assertions on chain okay and there's
people who are writing to the to the
blockchain and they are digitally
signing their assertions now of course
simply just putting something on chain
doesn't make it true it just says you
can prove not that the what is written
on chain is true but that the metadata
is true you can show who wrote it the
other digital signature what they wrote
their hash and when they wrote their
timestamp so you can establish those
things in metadata of who what and when
was written Who's the who in that
picture so for example how do you know
it's a one human
great question so let's say you've
bought a bunch of your pieces of
territory from Blackstone okay as a
function of that
blackstone.eth
signs
and on-chain receipt
that says
this
Lex friedman.e bought
this piece of property from us and it
has you know like it's a thousand square
meters and and this is put on chain they
sign it okay that's a that's their
digital receipt just like you might get
an email receipt when you buy a piece of
property or something okay it's just put
not online but on chain and it's signed
by Blackstone or whatever real estate
vendor you you buy it from it could be a
company it could obviously be an
individual right and so you have a bunch
of these assertions you let's say
there's 47 different real estate vendors
I know vendors in atypical term there
but just bear with me right 47 different
real estate
um sellers that you've bought all of
your territory from each of them put
digital signatures that are asserting
that a certain amount of real estate was
bought and at square meters its location
or whatever unless they want to prove
the sum of all that is now your real
estate footprint okay and now the
question is was that real well because
they signed what they put on chain you
can do things like you can audit let's
say Blackstone is signed
500 000 properties and they've sold them
and put them on chain and I'm not
talking about 2022 or 2023 but 2030
right it'll be a few years out but
people are doing this type of stuff
they're putting this up on you so you
get that on chain receipt they've got
500 000 of these what you can do is uh
just sampling okay you pick a subset n
of them
let's say 500 properties around the
world you go there you actually go and
independently look at what the square
footprint is and then from that you can
see what was the actual your measurement
versus their reported and then you can
via Cisco inference extrapolate that if
they were randomly selected to the rest
of the properties and get a reliability
score for blackstone's reporting of its
real estate square footage who does the
so that's the auditing stuff that's the
auditing step so the the crypto Oracle
is the auditable on chain uh what did
you say assertions that's right yeah
about like who bought stuff with who I
still have to get to the proof of human
but auditing there's a bunch of people
randomly checking that you're not full
of [ __ ] that's right so who is in charge
of the auditing though so it could be a
big four like a PWC and uh basically the
the accountants that do corporate
balance sheet and cash flow and and
keeps them in check
corruption I'm just imagining a world
full of network States yeah it's a good
question so you know at a certain point
you get to who watches the Watchers
right yeah and oh well the government is
meant to keep the accountants
accountable and you know Arthur Anderson
actually did have a whole flame out in
you know the
um around the time the Enron thing
um so it is possible that there's
corrupt accountants or bad accountants
or what have you but of course the
government itself is corrupt in many
ways and prints all this money and
seizes all these assets and surveils
everybody and so on and so forth so uh
you know the answer to your question is
going to be
um probably exit in the sense that if
those accountants
they are themselves going to digitally
sign a report and put it on chain okay
so they're going to say we believe that
x y and Z's
um you know reports are on chain were
this reliable and here's our study if
they falsify that well if somebody finds
that eventually then that person is down
weight and then you have to go to
another accountant right is there ways
to mess with this I mean I just
let me breathe in and out as I mentioned
some of the heaviest [ __ ] I've ever read
uh so because I visited Ukraine I've
read read famine by an Applebaum
bloodlands yep and it's just a lot of
coverage of the senses I mean there's a
lot of coverage of a lot of things but
in Ukraine in the
1930s uh Stalin messed a lot with the
senses to hide the fact that
sort of a lot of people died from
starvation they did that with the
cooperation of Arthur g salzburger's New
York Times company Like Walter Durante
falsified all those reports there's
several parties involved is there can
there be several parties involved in
this case that manipulate the truth as
as it is represented by the crypto
Oracle And as it is checked by the
auditing mechanism it is possible but
the more parties are involved in
falsifying something the more defections
there are so that's why you basically
have you know
um another level of auditing you know
it's fundamentally the answer right and
really I think what it comes back to is
if you're showing your work right this
is the difference between crypto
economics and Fiat economics you know
the the Bitcoin blockchain anybody can
download it and run verification on it
okay this is different than government
inflation stats which people don't
believe right because the process is
just you know it is true that CPI
methodology is published and so on but
it is not something which people feel
reflects their actual basket of goods
right and so the independent
verifiability is really the core of what
true audibility is and so then to your
question it's hard for some group to be
able to collude because the blockchain
is public and everything they've written
to it is public and so if there's an
error it's easier in some ways to tell
the truth than to lie because the truth
is just naturally consistent across the
world whereas lies can be found out even
you know ciscal Tesla you know benford's
law
uh yes right it's something where the
digits in like a real
um if you take the last digit or the
first last year the first digit I think
I think it's the first first digit right
so you take the first digit in
um an actual financial statement you
look at the distribution
of like how many ones and how many twos
how many threes the percentages
um it has actually a you you'd guess it
might be oh each one will be equally
random it'd be ten percent it's not like
that actually uh there's a certain
distribution that it has and fake data
um doesn't look like that uh but real
data does that's weird it's interesting
right bedford's law also called the
first digit law states that the leading
digits in a collection of data sets are
probably going to be small
for example most numbers in a set about
30 will have a leading digit of one yeah
so that's a great example of what we're
talking about earlier the observational
leading to the theory oh there's a
benfer's law of controversy I'm looking
that up
but for his long controversy bedford's
law of controversy is an adage from the
1980 novel Timescape stating passion is
inversely proportional to the amount of
real information available
the adage was quoted in an international
drug policy article in peer-reviewed
Social such can I just say how much I
love Wikipedia I have the founder
Wikipedia coming on this very podcast
very soon and uh I think the world is a
better place because Wikipedia exists
one of the things you wanted to come on
and talk about is the ways that he
believes that Wikipedia is going wrong
so in technical truth it's great
remember things I remember I think
earlier on like technical truths versus
political truths and Technical truths
it's great on political truths it's like
a defamation engine
um just as one example okay this is
something that you know I was gonna
write up but there was a scam called hpz
token that managed to edit Wikipedia
nobody detected it it said that I was
like the founder of hbz token that you
were the founder yeah I had nothing to
do with this and people were scammed out
of it because Google just pushes
Wikipedia links to you know High to high
on Google and people like well it's in
this Wikipedia therefore it's real right
Wikipedia as the bio of living persons
thing they should just allow people to
delete their profile because they have
zero quality control and it's literally
facilitating fraud right where people
will maliciously edit and then do things
with them and nobody cares or is looking
at it Beyond you know the fraudsters and
this is happening if that was happening
that was like undetected I wasn't paying
attention to this this was like there
for for like I don't know weeks or
months totally undetected that literally
facilitated fraud right and
fundamentally the issue is that
Wikipedia doesn't have any concept of
who's editing or property rights or
anything like that right it is also
something which is it used to be
something in the early 2000s mid-2000s
people said oh you know it's Wikipedia
how trustworthy can be Britannic is
reviewed and that's being forgotten and
now it's become over trusted right
remember the things like the more trust
something gets the less trustworthy it
often becomes it kind of abuses the
power right so
um what I'm interested in you know
Google actually had a Model A while back
called knol knol uh null was something
where when there were different versions
of of a Wikipedia style page you had
Google Docs like permissions on them for
example you might have 10 different
versions of the israeli-palestinian
conflict
okay and each one had an editor and
folks that they could Grant edit rights
and so on but this way you would
actually be able to see different
versions of a page and they might have
different versions of popularity but
this way you wouldn't have edit words
you'd have Forks right and they would
all kind of you know coexist and then
people could review them and now you can
see different versions of something
versus the thing that just kind of
rewards dog and persistence or being an
editor or something like that the other
thing is a lot of the folks who have
editorial privileges at Wikipedia are
there from the early 2000s
and most of India wasn't online then
most of Africa wasn't online then right
so there's this inherited power
that exists which uh again was fresh and
Innovative 10 or 20 years ago but
um it's now kind of outdated yeah I want
to see some data though I want to see
some data because we can always
um I mean this is the the here here's we
we often highlight small anecdotal okay
I'll give you uh cases hold on a second
uh we often highlight
issues in society in the world in
anything by taking a specific example
taking anecdotal data and saying there's
a problem here I want to know on net how
much positive is being added to the
world because of it my experience that I
try to be empathetic and open-minded my
exploration of Wikipedia has been such
that it is a breath of fresh air
in terms of
the the breadth and depth of knowledge
that is there now you can say there's
bias built in there's Wars that are
incentivized not to produce truth but to
produce a consensus around a particular
narrative but that is how the entirety
of human civilization operates and we
have to see where is it better and where
is it worse in terms of platforms I
think Wikipedia was an improvement over
what came before but has a lot of flaws
you're right that absolutely
um sometimes people can over fixate on
the anecdotal but sometimes the
anecdotal illustrates a general pattern
okay for example one thing that happens
frequently in Wikipedia is
um there are editors who will plant a
story and then they will then go and use
that story as like a neutral third party
to win an edit War so here's a
phenomenon
that happens in Wikipedia you have an
editor who has whose privilege above
just random users okay who will plant a
story and then cite that story as if it
was a neutral third party so there's a
site called wikipediaocracy okay and it
discusses the case of a person named
peppermint who had a name that they
didn't want included their so-called
dead name on their Wikipedia profile and
there's a Wikipedia editor named
tenebrae who people allege was a Newsday
reporter or or writer that put a piece
into Newsday that dead name that dead
name peppermint and then was able to
cite it on the Wikipedia article as if
it was like a neutral third party when
it actually wasn't when when people
alleged it was the same guy okay now
that is not an uncommon thing that
actually that's what I wanted on okay I
know how many articles I'm not uh who's
auditing I'm dancing with you not
against you sure okay I'm saying how
many articles have that kind of of War
where douchebags are manipulating each
other so that's the question what's the
audit has Wikipedia actually been
audited right who are the editors like
who's actually writing this stuff it is
actually something where uh again on
technical topics I think it's pretty
good on non-technical topics there's
something called uh the Wikipedia
reliable sources policy it's a
fascinating page okay so it actually
takes a lot of the stuff that we have
been you know the world has been talking
about in terms of what's a reliable
source of information and you know so
and so forth It's called the Wikipedia
reliable sources perennial sources okay
and if you go to this page okay which
I'm just going to send to you now all
right you will literally see every media
Outlet in the world
and they're colored gray green yellow or
red okay
um and so red is like untrustworthy
green is trust where the yellow is like
neutral okay now this actually makes
Wikipedia's epistemology explicit
they are marking a source as trustworthy
or untrustworthy for example you are not
allowed to cite social media on
Wikipedia
which is actually an enormous part of
what people are posting you will you
instead you have to cite a mainstream
media outlet that
puts the Tweets in the mainstream
article and only then can it be cited in
Wikipedia by the way to push back this
is a chance
um that those are rules written on the
sheet of paper I have seen Wikipedia in
general
play in the gray area that these rules
create oh well if you are an editor then
you can get but you can use the rules
and you can because there's there's a
lot of contradictions within the rules
you can use them to in in the ways you
said to achieve the ends you want it
really boils down to the incentives
the motivations of the editors and one
of the magical things about Wikipedia
the positive versus the negative is that
it seems like a very small number of
people same with stack Overflow can do
uh an incredible amount of good editing
and
um aggregation of good knowledge now as
you said that works seems to work much
better for technical things over which
there's not a significant division the
yeah so uh some of that has to do less
with the rules and more with the which
is the human beings involved well but
here's the thing is
um so first let me take this I should
finish off this point of reliable source
perennial sources right so if you go to
this you'll see that Al Jazeera
is marked green but let's say uh the
Cato Institute is marked
um yellow right the nation is marked
holy [ __ ] oh snap okay okay sure yes
right the nation is Mark green but
National Review is Mark yellow okay you
could probably go and do so what's good
about this is it makes it epistemology
explicit right you could actually take
this table and you could also look at
all the past edit Wars and so on over it
and take a look at what things are
starting to get marked as red or yellow
and what things try and get marked as
green and I'm pretty sure you're going
to find some kind of partisan
polarization that comes out of them
right number one uh number two is
once something gets marked as being
yellow or red yeah then all links and
all references to it are pulled out for
example coindesk okay was marked as
being like uh gosh I think it's marked
as red
coindesk which is actually like I get a
lot of useful information from coinda
that's right but it's marked as red why
because there's some Wikipedia editors
who hate cryptocurrency
it's a cryptocurrency on Wikipedia has
been a huge topic where they've just
edited out all the positive stuff and
these are senior editors of Wikipedia
who can control what sources are
considered reliable so now knocked out
quindesk they've knocked out social
media they only allow mainstream media
coverage and not even all mainstream
media only those they've marked as green
yeah this is the manipulation of I want
to know how many articles are affected
by it and hundreds of Nets hundreds of
thousands you could just say that
randomly
affected there's different levels of
effect in terms of it actual having a
significant impact on the quality of the
article let me give you an example let
me cover example right
um the fact that people cannot cite
direct quotes on social media but can
only cite the rehash of those quotes in
a mainstream media outlet and not just
any mainstream media outlet but those
that are colored green on the Wikipedia
reliable perennial sources policy is a
structural shift on every single article
to make Wikipedia aligned with U.S
mainstream media corporations right I am
as often Playing devil's advocate to
counter a point so that the disagreement
reveals some profound
wisdom that's what I'm doing here but
also in that
task here I'm trying to understand
exactly how much harm is created by the
bias
within the team of editors that we're
discussing and how much of Wikipedia is
technical knowledge
for example
the Russian invasion of Ukraine mm-hmm
the Wikipedia article I've seen there
now that changes very aggressively a lot
and I hear from every side on this
but it did not seem biased to me
here's like as compared to uh mainstream
media in the United States so now I'm
going to sound extremely woke yeah okay
um
if you go and look at this all right
times of India is yellow but Mother
Jones Jacobin okay they are green right
so a niche mostly white Western like
partisan left Outlet is Mark green but a
billion people you know like the times
of India is marked yellow right that's a
structural bias towards Western media
Outlets and Western editors when much of
the rest of the world hadn't gotten
online or I would just love to see in
terms of the actual article what ideas
are being censored sheltered shifted
okay I would love I just think it's an
open I'm not uh sort of uh edit logs are
there that logs are public yeah it would
be fascinating yeah is there a way to
explore the ways that narratives are
shifted because of short so a very
simple one is if you were to pull all
the logs of Wikipedia you could see how
many times are social media links
disallowed
okay like first of all think about like
this how many I mean just the fact that
social media is not allowed to like be
cited on Wikipedia or inconsistently you
think that's a problem it's a huge
problem you can't cite let's say Jeff
bezos's own tweet you have to cite some
random media questions here's the thing
uh and sorry sorry if I'm interrupting
please uh hopefully I'm adding to it I
think I think they're trying to create
friction as to
uh the source is used because if you can
use social media then you can use
basically Bots to create a bunch of
sources right and then that you can
almost automate the editor War right
like here's the thing is basically
Wikipedia initially you know like said
oh we'll only cite mainstream media uh
as a way of boosting its credibility in
the early 2000s okay when it's
credibility was low now it's sort of
become
merged with the US establishment and it
only cites these things whose trust I
mean have you seen the graphs on trust
in mainstream media like it's plummeted
it's down to like 10 or something like
that right so the most trusted sources
for Wikipedia are untrusted by the
population yeah true that that feels
like it's a fixable technological
problem I think I'm underinformed and my
gut says
we're both together under informed to do
a rigorous three to four hour discussion
about Wikipedia hold on a second I I I I
think I have a gut
uh sort of developed feeling about which
articles not to trust in Wikipedia I
think I need to make that explicit also
I have a kind of an understanding that
you don't go to this don't go to
Wikipedia for this particular topic like
don't go to Wikipedia for an article on
Donald Trump or Joe Biden there's going
to be if I did I would go to maybe
sections that don't have room for
insertion of bias or like the section on
controversy or accusations of racism or
so on or sexual assault are usually not
trust Wikipedia on those sections like
math that'll be great right Wikipedia is
great for that on many topics that do
not have
a single consensus truth it's
structurally shifted towards
um basically white Western liberals will
quits right fundamentally that's the
demographic of the Wikipedia what kind
of Articles do you think are affected by
this let's let's like think about like
everything that's not math and
Technology I think that's the strong
statement so we can
like I said uh war in Ukraine I I I sure
um I think that's the strongest
statement I there's so much
effect I guess I'm saying affected to a
large degree
even his uh major battles in history
battle Stalingrad or sure like uh that's
not math so you think all of that is
affected to a point
where it's not a process Source
absolutely if you look at the edit words
for example in Stalin versus Hitler
Hitler's the tone on Hitler starts out
legitimately and justifiably as
basically genocidal maniacal dictator
with Stalin there's a fair number of
Stalin apologists that edit out mention
of genocide from the first few
paragraphs
I am playing Devil's Advocate in part
but I also amped too underinformed to do
the level of Defense I would like to
provide
for the wisdom that is there for the
knowledge that is there I don't want to
use the word truth but sure for
some level of knowledge that is there in
uh Wikipedia I think I really worry
about I know you don't mean this but a
cynical interpretation of what you're
saying which is don't trust anything
right now Wikipedia I think you're being
very consistent and eloquent in the way
you're describing the issues Wikipedia
and I don't have enough
um foreign
actual specific examples to give where
there is
some like still battle for for truth
that's happening that's that's outside
of the bias of society I just I I think
if we naturally distrust every source of
information there is a general
distrust of institutions
and a distrustless source of knowledge
that
leads to an apathy in the cynicism about
the world in general
if you believe if you believe a lot of
conspiracy theories you basically tune
out from this Collective Journey that
we're on towards the truth and that
that's that like if it's not it's not
even just Wikipedia I just think
Wikipedia was at least for time and
maybe I tuned out uh maybe because I am
too focused on computer science and um
engineering and Mathematics but to me
Wikipedia for a long time was a source
of
calm Escape
from the from the political battles of
ideology
and as you're quite eloquently
describing it is not it has become part
of the battleground of political
ideology I just would love to know where
the boundaries of that are you know
Glenn Greenwald has observed this
um lots of other folks you know for
example I'm definitely not the only
person who's observed that Wikipedia a
lot of let me just State because I'm
sensing this and because of your
eloquence and clear Brilliance here that
a lot of people are going to immediately
agree with you okay and this is what I
am also troubled by not this is not you
sure but I often see that people will
detect cynicism especially when it is
phrased as eloquent it's yours and will
look at a
natural dumbass like me and think that
Lexi's just being naive look at him
trusting Wikipedia let me argue here let
me argue okay can you please do that
because you could do that better than me
no no no Alexa I enjoy talking to you
and I'm doing Devil's Advocate a little
bit because I I do really want to be I
am afraid about the forces uh that like
of basically editors talk of authority
of talking down to people and censoring
information yeah so let me first argue
your side and let me say something okay
which is
what you are
reacting to is
oh even those things I thought of as
constants are becoming variables where
is the Terra Firma if we cannot trust
anything then everybody's just it's
Anarchy and it's chaos like there's
literally no consensus reality and
anybody can say anything and so on and
so forth right and I think that there's
two possible deviations from you know
let's say that the mainstream you know
obviously people talk about like Q Anon
for example is like this kind of thing
where people just
make things up you know they just go
totally quit supply chain independent
from mainstream media and if mainstream
media is a distorted gossamer of
quasi-truth these guys go to Just total
fiction as opposed to like right the
alternative to Q Anon is not blue and on
mainstream media but satoshienon
okay which is an upward deviation okay
not a downward deviation to say there is
no such thing as truth but rather the
upward deviation is decentralized
cryptographic truth not centralized
corporate or government truth okay so
how does the decentralization of
Wikipedia look like great question it's
this concept of The Ledger of record
first whether you're Israeli or
Palestinian Japanese or Chinese Democrat
or Republican
those people agree on the state of the
Bitcoin blockchain hundreds of billions
of dollars is managed without weapons
okay
um across tribes with wildly varying
ideologies right
and what that means is that is a
mechanism for getting literally
consensus it's called consensus
cryptographic consensus proof of work
and when people can get consensus on
this what they're getting consents on
are basically bytes that determine who
holds what Bitcoin this is exactly the
kind of thing people would fight Wars
over you know for hundreds of billions
of dollars alone millions of dollars
people will will kill each other over
that in the past right so hundreds of
billions of dollars people can get
consensus truth on this in this highly
adversarial environment right
so the first generalization of that is
it says you can go from bytes that
reflect what Bitcoin somebody has
to bytes that reflect what stocks bonds
other kinds of assets people have that's
the entire defy ethereum that whole
Space okay basically the premise is if
you go from consensus on one byte by
induction you can go to consensus on
invites depending on the cost of getting
that consensus right and almost anything
digital can be represented you know or
everything digital can be represented as
bytes right so now you can get consensus
on certain kinds of digital information
Bitcoin but then also any kind of
financial instrument
and then the next generalization is
What I Call The Ledger of record many
kinds of facts
can be put partially or completely on
chain it's not just proof of work and
proof of stake there's things like proof
of location proof of human proof of this
proof of that the auditable oracles I
talked about extend it further lots and
lots of people are working on this right
proof of solvency seeing that some actor
has
um enough of a bank balance to
accommodate what they say they
accommodate you can imagine many kinds
of digital assertions can be turned into
proof of X and proof of Y you start
putting those on chain you now have a
library of
partially or completely provable facts
okay this is how you get consensus as
opposed to having a
white Western Wikipedia editor or mostly
white Western U.S media Corporation or
the US government
simply say what is true in a centralized
fashion
so do you think
truth is such an easy thing as you get
to higher and higher questions of
politics is the problem that the
consensus mechanism is being hacked or
is the problem that truth is a difficult
thing to figure out was the 2020
election rigged or not is the earth flat
or not that's a scientific one that's
why this is my technical versus
political truth Spectrum yeah but even
the Earth like well that that one is
yeah never mind that's a bad example
because that is very
uh you can rigorously show that the
Earth is not flat but
um what there's some social phenomena
political phenomena philosophical one
that that will have a lot of debates
historical stuff about uh
uh about the different forces operating
within Nazi Germany and uh stalinist
Soviet Union and I think there's
probably a lot of yeah like the
historians debate about a lot of stuff
like uh
Blitz the book that talks about the
influence of drugs in the Third Reich
right were they on math or something
yeah they are there's a lot of debates
about how how truth what is the
significance of meth on the actual
behavior and decisions of Hitler and so
on so there's still a lot of debates I
is it so easy to fix with um
decentralization I guess is the question
so I actually have like basically
chapter two of the network State book is
on essentially this topic and so it's
like 70 Pages or something like that so
let me try to summarize what I think
about on this the first is that there
was an onion article that came out I I
can't find it now anymore but it was
about historians in the year 3000
writing about the late 90s and early
2000s and they're like yeah clearly
Queen Brittany
was a very powerful Monarch we can see
um how many girls around the world
worshiped her like I got and so it was
very funny because it was a plausible
Distortion of you know the current
Society by you know a human civilization
picking through the rubble a thousand
years later yeah having no context on
anything right and it's a very
thought-provoking article because it
says well to what extent is that us
picking over Pompeii or the pyramids or
even like you know the 1600s or the
1700s like a few hundred years ago were
basically sifting through artifacts and
um you know Osama Berger actually has
this concept like uh which is is obvious
but it's also useful to have a name for
it's like I think he calls it like dark
history which is
and again it might be getting this wrong
but it's like only a small percentage of
what the Greeks wrote down you know has
come to us to the present day right so
perhaps it's not just the winners who
write history it's like the surviving
records we have this extremely partial
fragmentary record of history and
sometimes there's some discovery that
rewrites the whole thing don't like
Gobekli tepies everything I know about
that is from Rogan because he's a huge
fan of that that kind of stuff yeah that
like rewrites it and then there's a lot
of debates there there's a lot of
debates basically it's like the
discovery of this site in Northern
turkey that totally shifts our estimate
of like when civilization started maybe
pushing it back many thousands of years
further in the past right you know the
past it's like an inverse problem in
physics right we're trying to
reconstruct this from limited
information right it's like x-ray
crystallography it's an inverse problem
right
um it's it's Plato's Cave you know we're
trying to reconstruct what the world
looks like outside from these Shadows
these these fragments that have been
um given to us right or that we've found
and
um so in that sense as you find more
information your estimate of the past
changes right oh wow okay that pushes
back civilization farther we thought
that one Discovery just changes it so
you want to try to given all the gaps
in the data we have you want to try to
remove bias from the process of trying
to fill the gaps well so here's the
thing um I think we're very close to the
moment of it and that's why it'll sound
crazy when I see it now but our
descendants I I really do think of
what the blockchain is and
cryptographically verifiable history as
being the next step after written
history it's like on par with that
because anybody who has the record the
math is not going to change right math
is constant across human time and space
right so you know the value of pi is
constant that's one of the few constants
across all these different human
civilizations okay
um so
somebody in the future assuming of
course the digital record is actually
intact to that point because you know
the uh in theory digital stuff will
persist in practice you have lost data
and floppy drives and stuff like that in
a sense in some ways digital is more
persistent in some ways physical is more
persistent okay but assuming we can
figure out the the archival problem
somehow then
this future record at least it's
internally consistent right you can run
a bunch of the equivalents of checksums
right the Bitcoin verification process
just sum it all up and see that okay
it's F of G of H of X and boom that that
at least is internally consistent okay
again it doesn't say that all the people
who reported it were uh you know they
could have put something on chain that's
false but at least you know the metadata
is likely to be very difficult to
falsify and this is a new tool it's a
really a new tool in terms of a robust
um history that is expensive and
technically challenging to edit and
alter and that is the alternative to the
stalin-esque rewriting of History by
centralized power
yeah I'm gonna have to do a lot actually
reading and thinking about I'm actually
as as you're talking I'm also thinking
about the fact that I think 99 of my
access to Wikipedia is is on technical
topics
um because I basically use it very
similarly to stack Overflow and even
there it doesn't have unit tests for
example one thing that's a good way to
put it right so one thing I remember
again I might be wrong on this but I
recall that the Kelly Criterion it's a
it's actually quite a useful thing to
know it's like how to optimally size
your bets okay and you can have
um given your kind of probability that
some investment pays off or assume
probability you can have bets that are
too large bets are too small sometimes
the Kelly Criterion it goes negative and
actually it says you should actually
take leverage you're so sure this is a
good outcome that you should actually
spend more than your current bankroll
because you're going to get a good
result right so it's a very
sophisticated thing and as I recall many
sites on the internet have the wrong
equation and I believe that was
reprinted on Wikipedia the wrong
equation was put on Wikipedia as the
Kelly Criterion for a while it's funny
okay and so without unit tests see math
is actually the kind of thing that you
could unit test right you could
literally have the assert on the right
hand side today right the modern version
we've got Jupiter we've got replit we've
got all these things the modern version
of Wikipedia
um there's sites like golden.com for
example like a you know the
um there's there's a bunch of things I'm
funding lots of stuff across the board
you know on on this
um and you know I'm not capitalizing
these companies or capitalized
independently but I'm trying to see if
you know not just talk about a better
version it's hard to build something
better so actually go and build it and
what you want is assertions that are
actually reproduced you you don't just
have the equation there you have a
written down code you can hit enter you
can download the page you can rerun it
it's reproducible so the problem with
that kind of reproducibility is that it
adds friction it's harder to put
together articles that do that kind of
stuff unless you do an incredible job
with ux and so on I the the thing thing
that I think is interesting about
Wikipedia on the technical side is that
without the unit tests without the
assertions
it still often does an incredible job
because the reason it's the the people
that write those articles and I've seen
this also in stack Overflow is are the
people that care about this most and
there's a pride
to getting it right okay so let me agree
and disagree with that right so
absolutely there's there's some good
there there's uh I mean again do I think
Wiki is a huge step up from what
preceded it in some ways on the
technical topics yes
however you talk about the editing
environment right like the markup for
Wikipedia it's very you know mid-2000s
right it is not it's a Craigslist yeah
exactly if for a minimum for example
it's not wysiwyg right so uh like medium
or something like that you you know or
ghost
um you can just go in and type and it
looks exactly like it looks on the page
here you have to go to a uh a markup
language where there can be editor
conflicts and you hit enter and someone
is over in your edit or something like
that and you don't know how it looks on
the page you might have to do a few you
know previews or what have you it's
number one so editing you talk about
bearish ending that's that's the thing
um number two is
given that it might be read a thousand
times for every one time it's written it
is important to actually have the
mathematical things unit tested if they
can be given that we've got modern
technology and that's something that's
hard to like retrofit into this because
it's so kind of ossified right right
there's the the interface on every side
for the editor even just for the editors
to check that say the editor wants to
get it right we make it we want to make
it really
uh or not it should be easy but easier
to check their work that's like
debugging like a nice IDE for the
that's right and the thing about this is
um as I said because the truth is a
global constant but like incorrectness
you know right go ahead every happy
family I love I love to think that like
truths will have a nice debugger well so
here's right so the thing is that what
you can do is uh let's say you did have
like a unit tested page for everything
that's on Wikipedia first of all it
makes a page more more useful because
you can download it you can run it you
can import it and so on second is it
leads into one of the things that we can
talk about I've sort of like a road map
for building alternatives to not just
existing companies but to many existing
U.S institutions from media and tech
companies to courts and government and
you know Academia and non-profits the
Wikipedia discussion actually relates to
um how you improve on Academia right and
so Academia right now one of the big
problems this is kind of related to the
oh boy okay the current institutions we
don't have trust in them because the
answer is is that the answer to trust no
one right and I think the alternative is
decentralized cryptographic trust or
verification how does that apply to
Academia
first observation is
we are seeing
science
being abused in the name of quote quote
unquote science okay capital S science
is Maxwell's equations that's that's the
good one that's a good one right
quote-unquote science is a paper that
came out last week
and the key thing is that capitalist
science real science is about
independent replication not prestigious
citation
that's the definition like all the
journal stuff the professors all that
stuff is just a superstructure that was
set on top to make experiments more
reproducible
and that superstructure is now like
dominating the underlying thing because
people are just fixating on the prestige
and the citation and not the replication
right so how does that apply here once
you start thinking about how many
replications does this thing have
Maxwell's equation I mean there's
trillions of replications every time us
speaking into this microphone right now
you know we're testing
um you know our theory of the
electromagnetic field right uh or
Electro and magnetic fields every single
time you pick up a cell phone or use a
computer you're you're putting our our
knowledge to the test right whereas some
paper that came out last week in science
or nature may have zero independent
replications yet it is being cited
publicly as prestigious scientists from
Stanford and you know Harvard and MIT
all came up with X right and so the
prestige is a substitute for the uh the
actual replication so there's a concept
called good heart's law okay I'm just
going to quote it when a measure becomes
a Target it seems to be a good measure
Okay so
for example uh
backlinks on the web were a good signal
for Google to use when people didn't
know they were being used as a signal
yeah you were talking you talked about
uh quantity versus quality and pagerank
was a pretty good approximation for
quality yes such a fascinating thing by
the way but yeah it's a fascinating
thing we can talk about that but
basically once people know that you're
using this as a measure they will start
to game it and uh so then you have this
cycle where you know sometimes you have
a fixed Point like Satoshi with proof of
work was miraculously able to come up
with a game where the gaming of it was
difficult without just buying more
compute right so it's actually it's a
rare kind of game where knowledge of the
game's rules didn't allow people to game
the game yeah but a brilliant way to put
it yeah which is one of the reasons
that's brilliant is that it's you can
describe the game and you can't mess
with it exactly it's very hard to come
up with something that's stable in this
way it's actually
on The Meta Point uh gosh there's a game
where the rule of the game is to change
the rules okay
um it is uh you mean human civilization
or what well yeah gosh it just called
something nomik
okay and oh um I see nomeg is a game
where the rule of the game is to change
the rules of the game yeah at first it
seems insane then you realize that's
Congress
yeah right yeah literally What It Is So
Meta because there are laws
for elections that elect the editors
of those laws who then change the laws
that get them elected with
gerrymandering and other stuff right
that's a bad version we have to think
about everything that the other way of
thinking about it is this is what every
software engineer is doing you are
constantly changing the rules by editing
software and pushing code updates and
and so on right
so you know many games devolve into the
metagame of who writes the rules of the
game right become essentially games of
nomic proof of work is so amazing
because it didn't devolve in such a way
right it became very hard to rewrite the
rules once they got set up very
financially and technically expensive
that's not to say it will always be like
that but it's very hard to change if we
could take a small tangent we'll return
to Academia I'd love to ask you about
how to fix the media as well after we
fix Academia yeah these are all actually
related related yeah Wikipedia media and
Academia are all related to the question
of
independent replication versus
prestigious citation sure so that the
problem is Authority and Prestige as you
see it from Academia and the media and
Wikipedia with the editors we have to
have uh
a mechanism where sort of um
the data and the reproducibility is what
dominates the discourse that's right and
so when we think about this is a citizen
in um I think a tweeted this or
something but Western Civilization
actually has a break last vacation
emergency button it's called
decentralization right Martin Luther hit
it when the Catholic church was too
ossified and centralized decentralized
with a Protestant Reformation okay he
said you know at the time people were
able to uh pay for indulgences like that
is to say they could sin they could say
okay I sinned five times yesterday
here's you know the equivalent of 50
bucks okay I'm done with my sin I can go
and send some more okay this is really
by their way out of sin okay now people
debate as to how frequent those
intelligence were these are one of the
things he invade against in the 95
Theses so decentralization boom break
away from this ossified church start
something new right and in theory the
quote religious wars of the 1600s that
ensued were about things like where you
know the wafer was a body of Christ or
what have you but
in part they were also about power and
whether the centralized entity would
write all the rules or the decentralized
one would and so what happened was
obviously Catholicism still exists but
protism also exists okay and uh
similarly here you've got this ossified
Central institution where you know
forget about I mean there's complicated
studies or difficult to summarize but
when you have the science saying masks
don't work and then they do
okay which everybody saw and this is not
like you know everybody knew that there
was not like some massive study that
came out that changed our perspective on
mask wearing it was something that was
just insistently asserted as this is
what the science says and then without
any acknowledgment the science said
something different you know the next
day right I remember because I was in
the middle of this this debate
um and I think you could justify masks
early in the pandemic as a useful
precaution and then later you know
post-vaccination perhaps not necessarily
I think that's like the rational way of
thinking about it but the point was that
such levels of uncertainty were not
acknowledged instead people you know
were basically lying in the name of
Science and public policy uh was you
know it was wasn't uh Public Health it
was political Health okay so something
like that you're spending down all the
credibility of an institution for
basically nothing okay and so in such a
circumstance what do you do
break glass decentralized what does that
look like Okay so
let me just describe what I call crypto
science uh by analogy to you know crypto
just like the Fiat science crypto
science right Fiat economics okay so
um in any experiment any paper when it
comes out right
it's you can sort of divide it into the
analog to digital and the purely digital
okay so the analog digital is you're
running some instruments you're getting
some data okay and then once you've got
the data you're generating figures and
tables and text and a PDF from that data
right
leave aside the data collection set for
now I'll come back to that right just a
purely digital part what does the ideal
quote academic paper look like in
2022-2023 first uh there's this concept
called truly called reproducible
research okay
reproducible research is the idea that
the PDF should be regenerated from the
data and code okay so you should be able
to hit enter and regenerate it why is
this really important as a concept John
Claire Boo and Dave Donahoe at Stanford
20 years ago pioneered this in stats
because
the text alone often doesn't describe
every parameter that goes into a figure
or something right you kind of sometimes
just need to look at the code and then
it's easy and without that it's hard
okay so reproducible research means you
regenerate the PDF from the code and and
the data you hit enter okay now
one issue is that many papers out there
science nature Etc are not reproducible
research moreover the data isn't even
public uh moreover sometimes the paper
isn't even public the Open Access
movement has been fighting this for the
last 27 years there's various levels of
this like green and gold Open Access
okay so the first step is the code the
data and the PDF go on chain step number
one okay the second thing is once you've
got so you can anybody who is and that
could be the ethereum chain it could be
its own dedicated chain whatever okay it
could be something where there's a just
the URLs or on the ethereum chain and
stored on filecoin many different
implementations but let's call that on
chain broadly okay
not just online on chain when it's on
chain it's public and anybody can get it
so that's first second is once you've
got something where you can regenerate
the code
um or the PDF from the code and the data
on chain guess what you can have uh
citations between two papers turn into
import statements yeah that's funny
that's cool right so now you're not just
getting composable Finance like D5 where
you have like one interest rate
calculator calling another
you have composable science
and now you can say this paper on this
especially in ml right you'll often cite
a previous paper in its Benchmark or its
method right you're gonna You're Gonna
Wanna scatter plot sometimes your paper
your algorithm versus theirs on the same
data set that is facilitated if their
entire paper is reproducible research
that is generated you can just literally
import that Python and you know then you
can you can generate your figure off of
it right moreover think about how that
aids reproducibility because you don't
have to reproduce in in the literal
sense every single snippet of code that
they did you can literally use their
code import it okay people start
compounding on each other it's better
science okay now I talked about this but
actually there's a few folks who have
been actually building this
um
so there's use scholar.org which
actually has a demo of this like just a
V1 like kind of prototype where it shows
two stats papers on chain
um and uh one of them is citing the
other with an import statement there's
also a thing like called I think dsi.com
which is trying to do this all right
decentralized science so
this itself changes how we think about
papers and actually by the way
um the inspiration for pagerank was
actually citations it was like the
impact factor out of Academia that's
where Larry Page and sergeyman got the
concept out of right so now you've got a
web of citations that are import
statements on chain in theory you could
track back a paper all the way back to
its antecedents
okay so if it's citing something you can
now look it up and look it up and look
it up and a surprising number of papers
actually
um you know their antecedents don't
terminate or the the original Source
says something different or it just kind
of got garbled like a telephone game and
uh you know there's this famous thing on
like uh the spinach
um like uh it does actually have iron in
it or something like that I I forget the
details on this story but it was
something where you track back the
citations and people are contradicting
each other okay but it's just something
that just gets copy pasted and it's a
fact that's not actually a fact because
it's not audited properly this allows
you to cheaply audit in theory all the
way back to Maxwell or Newton or
something like that okay now what I'm
describing is a big problem but it's a
finite problem it's essentially taking
all the important papers and putting
them on chain it's about the scale of
let's say Wikipedia okay so it's like I
don't know a few hundred thousand a few
million papers I don't know the exact
number but it'll be out of that level
okay so now you've got number one
these things that are they're on chain
okay number two they're you've turned
citations into import statements number
three anybody
can now at a minimum download that code
and while they may not have the
instruments and I'll come back to that
point but let me know the instruments
they can do internal checks the
benford's law stuff we were just talking
about
you can internally check the consistency
of these tables and graphs and often
you'll find fraud or things that don't
add up that way because all the code and
the data is is there right and now
you've made it so that anybody in Brazil
in India and Nigeria they may not have
an academic you know like uh Library
access is on but they can get into this
all right now how do you fund all this
well
good thing is crypto actually allows
tools for that as well Andrew huberman
and others have started doing things
like with nfts
um to fund their lab I can talk about
the funding aspect there's things like
researchhub.com which are trying to
issue tokens for labs but a lab isn't
that expensive to fund maybe it's a few
hundred thousand a few million a year
depending on where you are crypto does
generate money and so you can probably
imagine various tools whether it's
tokens or nfts or something like that to
fund
finally
um what this does is it is not Q Anon
right it is not saying don't trust
anybody neither is it just trust the
centralized academic establishment
instead of saying trust because you can
verify because we can download things
and run them The crucial thing that I'm
assuming here is the billions of
supercomputers around the world that we
have all the MacBooks and iPhones that
can crank through lots and lots of
computation so everything digital we can
verify it locally okay now there's one
last step which is I mentioned the
instruments right whether it's your
sequencing machine or your accelerometer
or something like that is generating the
data that you are reporting in your
paper when you put it on channel okay
basically you think that's the analog
digital interface
we can crypto find that too why
for example an Illumina sequencing
machine has an experiment manifest and
when uh that's written to there's a
website called ncbi National Center for
biotechnology information you can see
the experiment metadata
on various sequencing runs it'll tell
you what instrument and what time it was
Ron and who ran it and so and so forth
okay
what that does is allows you to correct
for things like batch effects sometimes
you will sequence on this day and the
next day and maybe the humidity or
something like that makes it look like
there's a ciscally significant
difference between your two results but
it was just actually batch effects okay
what's my point point is if you have a
crypto instrument
you can have you know various hashes and
stuff of the data as a chain of custody
for the data itself that are streamed
and written on chain that the
manufacturer can program into this for
anything that's really anything you
might say well boy that's Overkill right
I'm saying actually not you know why if
you're doing a study whose results are
going to be used to influence a policy
that's going to control the lives of
millions of people every single step has
to be totally audible you need the glass
box model you need to be able to go back
to the raw data you need to be able to
interrogate that and again this is
anybody who's a good scientist will
Embrace this right yeah so first of all
those a brilliant exposition of a future
of science that I would love to see
um the the pushback I'll provide which
is not really a pushback is like
what you describe is so much better than
what we currently have that I think a
lot of people would say any of the sub
steps you suggest are already going to
be a huge Improvement so even just
sharing the code yes or sharing the data
you said like off it's I think it would
surprise people how often it's hard to
get data uh is it like the actual data
or specifics or a large number of the
parameters not the you'll share like one
or two parameters that were involved
with running the experiment you won't
mention the machines involved except
maybe at a higher level but the versions
and so on the dates when the experiments
will run so don't mention any of this
kind of stuff right so there's there's
several ways to fix this
and one of them
I think implied in what you're
describing is a culture
that says it's not okay
exactly to like so first of all there
should be even if it's not perfectly
Unchained to where you can automatically
import all the way to Newton
is it just just even the
the act of sharing the code sharing the
data Maybe in a way that's not uh
perfectly integrated into a larger
structure is already a very big positive
step saying like if you don't do this
then
this doesn't count and because in
general I think my worry
uh I you know as somebody who's a
programmer who's OCD I love the the
picture you paint that you can just
import everything into all automatically
checks everything my my problem is is
that makes incremental science easier
and revolutionary science harder oh I
actually very much just screwed that I
would love to hear you I'll give you
guys let me just kind of collaborate
sure
um why sometimes you have to think in
this gray area of fuzziness and you're
thinking in totally novel ideas and when
you have to concretize in data like some
of the greatest papers I've ever written
are they don't have data they're in the
space of ideas almost like you're kind
of sketching stuff and there could be
errors but like Einstein himself with a
famous five papers I mean they're
they're really strong but they're
they're fuzzy they're they're a little
bit fuzzy and so I I think uh you know
even like the Gan paper you're often
thinking of like new data sets new ideas
and
I think maybe as a step after the paper
is written you could probably concretize
it integrate it into the rest of science
sure like you shouldn't feel that
pressure I guess early on I well I mean
there's there's different each each of
the steps that I'm talking about right
there's like
the day of being public and everything
just that just having the paper being
public that's like V1 right then you
have the thing being regenerated from
code and data like the PDF being
presented from code data then you have
the citations as import statements then
you have the full citation graph as an
important statement so you just follow
it all the way back right and uh and now
you have that gives you audibility
then you have the off chain you know the
the analog digital crypto custody right
like where you're hashing things and
streaming things so you have the chain
of custody each of those is kind of like
a level up and adds to complexity but it
also adds the audibility and the
verifiability of the reproducibility but
you know one thing I'd say I wanted to
respond to that you said was uh that you
think this would be good for incremental
but not Innovative actually it's quite
the opposite I think
Academia is institutional and it's not
Innovative for example NIH has this
graph which is like I think it's age of
recipients of r01 Grants okay and what
it shows is basically it's like a hump
that moves over time roughly plus one
year forward for the average age as the
year moves on okay I'll see if I can
find the gif
what this why is this let me see if I
can find actually look at this movie
just for a second it's a ridiculously
Powerful movie and it's 30 seconds
extension WhatsApp the name of the video
is age distribution of NIH principal
investigators in Medical School faculty
and it starts out on the x axis age with
the distribution and percent of pis
and from 19 early 1980s moving one year
at a time
and the mean of the distribution is
moving slowly approximately as Bellagio
said about one year per year uh per year
now this is 10 years ago one year in age
per year of time and notice how first of
all the average age is moving way upward
before you you know become an HPI second
is it's a court of guys people who are
just aborting grants to each other yeah
that's clearly what's happening you know
that's that's the underlying Dynamic
they're not awarding grants to folks who
are much younger okay because those
folks haven't proven themselves yet
right so it is this this is what happens
when you get prestigious citation rather
than independent replication the age
just keeps creeping up and this was 10
years ago and it's gotten even worse
it's become even more democratic even
more High bound right and so the thing
is the the structures that van of our
Bush and others set up the entire
post-war science establishment one thing
I'll often find is people will say
biology
the government hath granted us the
internet and uh you know self-driving
cars and space flight and so on how can
you possibly be against the US
government kneel and repent for its
Bounty you know and really what they are
the reason they they kind of they don't
say it quite in that way but that's
really the underpinning kind of thing
because they've replaced god with gov
they really think of the US government
as God you know the conservative will
think of the US government as like the
all-powerful military abroad and the
progressive will think of it as the
benign all-powerful you know like
nurturing parent at home okay but in
this context they're like how come you
as you know some tech bro could possibly
think you could ever do basic science
without the funding of the US government
has it not developed all basic science
right and the answer to this is actually
say well what if we go further back the
1950 did science happen before 1950 well
I think it did Bernoulli and you know
Maxwell and Newton were they funded by
and SF you know no they weren't right
what were Aviation railroads automobiles
gigantic you know industries that arose
and they both were stimulated by and
stimulated development of pure science
did they were they funded by NSF no they
were not right therefore NSF is not
a necessary condition for the presence
of science neither is even the United
States obviously a lot of these
discoveries Newton was before you know
like uh the I believe is for the
American oh let me find the exact
it's actually Less Old than people think
okay so Newton died 1727 right so I knew
that
um you know it was like in the 1700s so
noon was before the American Revolution
right obviously that meant huge
Innovations could happen before the US
government before NIH before NSF right
which means they are not a necessary
condition number one that itself is
crucial because a lot of people say the
government is necessary for the for
basic science it is not necessary for
basic science
it is one possible Catalyst and I would
argue that mid-century it was okay
because mid-century was the time when
you the middle of the centralized
Century uh 1933 1945 1969 you have
Hoover Dam you have the Manhattan
Project you have Apollo that generation
was acclimatized to a centralized U.S
government that could accomplish great
things probably because technology
favored centralization going into 1950
and then started favoring
decentralization going out of it I've
talked about this in the book Sovereign
and digital has talked about this but
very roughly you know you go up into
1950 and you have mass media and mass
production
um and just centralization of all kinds
giant nation states slugging it out on
the world stage and you go out in 1950
and you get cable news and personal
computers and Internet and mobile phones
and cryptocurrency and you have the
decentralization and so
this entire centralized scientific
establishment was set up at the peak of
the centralized century and it might
have been the right thing to do at that
time but is now showing its age and it's
no longer actually geared up for what we
have where are the huge Innovations
coming out well Satoshi Nakamoto was not
to our to our knowledge a professor
right that's this revolutionary thing
that came outside of it
um early in the pandemic there's
something called project Dash
evidence.github.io which accumulated all
of the evidence for the coronavirus
possibly having been a lab leak when
that was a very controversial thing to
discuss right Alina Chan to her credit
you know Matt Ridley and Alina Chan have
written this book you know on
um whether the coronavirus was a lab
leak or not I think it's plausible that
it was
um
I I can't say I'm 100 sure but I think
it's at least it's certainly it is a
hypothesis worthy of discussion okay
um though of course it's got political
overtones point being that the
pseudonymous online publication at
project evidence github.io happened when
it was taboo to do so so we're back to
the age of pseudonymous publication
where only the arguments can be argued
with the person can't be attacked okay
this is actually something that used to
happen in the past like you know
um someone there's a famous story where
Newton sold a problem someone said I
know the lion by his claw or something
like that right people used to do
pseudonymous publication in the past so
that they would be judged on part by
their scientific ideas and not the
person themselves right and so
um so I do disagree that this is the
incremental stuff this is actually the
Innovative stuff the incremental stuff
is going to be the institutional
gerontocracy the that's Academia where
it's like you know do you know who I am
I'm a Harvard Professor yeah I don't I I
think I agree with everything you said
but I I
um I'm not I'm not going to get stuck on
technicalities because I think I was
referring to your vision of data sets
and importing code sure and so that
forces just knowing how code works it
forces a structure and structure usually
favors incremental progress
like if you Fork code
you're not going to uh descent
descentivizes Revolution
you want to go from scratch okay so I I
understand your point there okay
um and I also agree that some papers
like Francis Crick on the cloud stream
or there's are theoretical they're more
about like where to dig than the data
itself and so on and so forth right so I
agree with that still I don't um the
counter argument is
rather than a thousand people reading
this paper to try to rebuild the whole
thing and uh do it with errors
when they can just import they can more
easily build upon what others have done
right oh yeah yeah so the the paper
should be forkable but yeah yeah so
here's what you know like uh you know
python has this concept of batteries
included for the standard library right
because it lets you just import import
and just get to work right that means
you can fly
whereas if you couldn't do all those
things and you had to rewrite string
handling you would only be able to do
incremental things libraries actually
allow for greater Innovation that's my
account I I think you create I I think
that paints the picture I hope that's a
picture that fits with science it
certainly does it fits with code very
well I just wonder how much of science
can be that which is you import how much
of it is possible to do that certainly
for the things I work on you can which
is the machine learning world the uh all
the computer science world but whether
you can do that for all right you can
fix biology it seems to yes I think so
chemistry I think so and then you start
getting into weird stuff like psychology
which some people don't even think is a
science no
um just love for my psychology friends I
I think
as you get farther and farther away from
things that are like hard technical
Fields it starts getting tougher and
tougher and tougher to have like
importable code Okay so
let me give the strong form version
right so there's a guy who I think is uh
you know great machine learning guy uh
creator of actually Keras
um who just he disagrees with me on
Francois yeah he's been on his podcast
twice yeah okay great so he just
disagree with him on a lot of stuff yes
me too I think we have mutual respect
you know uh follow each other on Twitter
whatever I think yes I think he does
respect and like you here is something
which I totally agree with him on and he
actually got like trolled or attacked
for this but I completely agree within
10 20 years nearly every branch of
science will be for all intents and
purposes a branch of computer science
computational physics computational
chemistry computational biology
computational medicine even
computational archeology realistic
simulations Big Data analysis and ml
everywhere that to me is incredibly
obvious why first of all all we're doing
every day is PDFs and data analysis on a
computer right
and so every single one of those areas
can be reduced to the analog digital
step and then It's All Digital then
you're flying you're in the cloud right
you put a date do you say how long or 10
20 years I think arguably it's already
there right and here's the thing you you
were saying well you know you might drop
off when you hit psychology or history
actually
um I think it's the softer sciences that
are going to harden up why
um one of the things I talk about a lot
in the book is for example with history
the concept of crypto history makes
history computable one way of thinking
about it is remember my Britney Spears
example right where Queen Brittany right
yeah okay so at first it's kind of a
funny thing to say a computer
scientist's term for history is the log
files until we realize that what would a
future historian how would they write
about the history of the 2010s
well a huge part of that history
occurred on the servers of Twitter and
Facebook yeah so now you go from like a
log file which is just the individual
record of like one server's action two
decade a decade worth of data on
literally billions of people
all of their online lives like arguably
that's why I say that's like actually
what the written history was of the
2010s was this giant digital history as
you go to the 2020s and 2030s more of
that is going to move from merely online
to on chain and then cryptographically
verifiable so that soft subject of
History becomes something that you can
calculate things like Google Trends and
engrams and stuff like that yes
beautifully put
then I would venture to say that Donald
Trump was erased from history uh when he
was removed from Twitter yeah and many
social platforms and all his tweets were
gone
I think someone who has an archive of it
but yeah I understand your point yeah
well as the flood of data about each
individual increases censorship it
becomes much more difficult to actually
have an archive of stuff but yes for
important people like a president United
States yes uh let me in that uh topic
ask you about uh Trump you were
considered for a position as FDA
commissioner in the Trump Administration
and I think one of in terms of the
network state in terms of the digital
world one of the seminal acts in the
history of that was the Banning of trump
from Twitter can you make the case for
it and against it sure so first let me
let me talk about the FDA thing sure so
I was considered for a senior role at
FDA but I do believe that and this is a
whole topic we can talk about the FDA
um I do believe that just as it was
easier to create Bitcoin than to form
the FED right reforming the FED
basically still hasn't happened right so
just as it was easier to create Bitcoin
than to reform the FED it will literally
be easier to start a new country than to
reform the FDA it may take 10 or 20
years I mean think about Bitcoin it's
only about 13 years old right it may
take 10 or 20 years to start a new
network state with a different
biomedical policy but that is how we get
out from this perhaps the single worst
thing in the world which is
harmonization regulatory harmonization
can describe regulatory harmonization
regulatory harmonization is the
mechanism by which
U.S regulators
impose their regulations on the entire
world so basically you have a monopoly
by U.S Regulators uh this is not just
the FDA it is SEC and FAA and so on and
so forth and for the same reason that a
small
company will use Facebook login that
will Outsource their login to Facebook
a small country will Outsource their
regulation to the USA okay with all the
attendant issues because
I mean you know the names of some
politicians can you name a single
regulator at the FDA no no right yeah
they will brag on their website that
they regulate I forget the exact numbers
I think it's like 25 cents out of every
dollar something along those lines okay
it's like double digits okay
that's a pretty big deal
and the thing about this is you know
people will talk about quote our
democracy and so on but many of the
positions in quote our democracy are
actually not subject to democratic
accountability uh you have tenured
professors and you have tax-exempt
colleges you have the salzburgers that
New York Times who have dual class stock
you have
um you know a bunch of positions that
are out of the reach of the electorate
and that includes Regulators who have
career tenure after just a few years of
not necessarily even continuous service
they're not accountable to the
electorate they're not named by the
Press
and they also uh aren't accountable to
the market because you've got
essentially uniform Global regulations
now the thing about this is it's not
just a government thing it's a
regulatory capture thing big Pharma
companies like this as well why because
they can just get their approval in the
US and then they can export to the rest
of the world right I understand where
that comes from as a corporate executive
it's such a pain to get you know access
in one place so there's a team up though
between the giant company and the giant
government to box out all the small
startups and all the small countries and
lots of small Innovation right there are
cracks in this now right the FDA did not
acquit itself well during the pandemic
for example it denied I mean there's so
many issues but one of the things that
even actually New York Times reported
the reason that people thought there
were no covid cases in the U.S early in
the pandemic was because the FDA was
denying people the ability to run covet
tests and the emergency use
authorization was you know emergency
should mean like right now right but it
was not it was just taking forever and
so some Labs did Civil Disobedience and
they just disobeyed the FDA and just
went and tested academic Labs with
threat of federal penalties because
that's what they are they're like
they're like the police okay and uh and
so we're sort of retroactively granted
immunity because nyt went and ran a
positive story on them so nyt's
Authority is usually greater than that
of FDA if they come into a conflict nyt
run stories then FDA kind of gets
spanked right
um and it's not you know probably
neither party would normally think of
themselves that way but if you look at
it when nyt goes and runs stories on a
company it names all the executives and
they get all hit when it runs stories on
a regulator it just treats the regulator
usually as if it was just some abstract
entity it's Zuckerberg's Facebook but
you can't name you know the people who
the career bureaucrats at FDA
interesting right it's very interesting
it's a very important Point like that
person who's like named in their face is
is known like you just as an example you
know Zuckerberg's face and name most
people don't know Arthur G Salzburg they
couldn't recognize him right he's a guy
who's inherited the New York Times
company for his father's father's father
that is unaccountable power it's not
that they get great coverage that they
get no coverage they don't even think
about them right and uh so it's
invisibility right
there's some aspect why fauci was very
interesting because in my recent memory
there's not been many faces of
scientific policy of science policy yeah
he became the face of that and you know
as as uh there's some of it is meme
which is uh you know basically saying
that he is science or to some people who
represent science but in in the
quote-unquote Sciences yeah the positive
aspect of that is that there is
accountability when there's a face like
that right but you can also see the
factory example shows you why a lot of
these folks do not want to be public
because they enter a political you know
and media Minefield I'm actually
sympathetic to that aspect of it what
I'm not sympathetic to is the concept
that in 2022 that the unelected
unfireable anonymous American regulator
should be able to impose regulatory
policy for the entire world we are not
the world of 1945. you know it is not
something where these other countries
are even consciously consenting to that
world just as Give an example you know
there's a concept called challenge
trials okay the the moderna vaccine
was available very very early in the
pandemic you can just synthesize it from
the sequence and challenge trials would
have meant that people
who are healthy volunteers okay they
could have been soldiers for example of
varying agents who are there to take a
risk their lives for their country
potentially okay it could have been just
healthy volunteers not necessarily
soldiers just Patriots or whatever kind
in any country not just the us but those
healthy volunteers could have gone and
in the early stages of the pandemic we
didn't know exactly how lethalu was
going to be because you know Lee Wen
Liang and you know 30 year old
30-somethings in China were dying from
this it seemed like it could be far
worse how lethal the the the virus would
be yeah it may be by the way that those
who are the most susceptible to the
virus died faster earlier it's as if you
could imagine a model where those who
were exposed and had the lowest
susceptibility also had the highest
severity and died in greater numbers
early on if you look at the graph like
deaths from covet were exponential going
into about April 2020 and then leveled
off to about 7 500 10 000 a day and then
kind of fell right but it could have
gone to 75 000 at the beginning so we
didn't know how serious it was so this
would have been a real risk that these
people would have been taking but here's
what they would have gotten for that
basically in a challenge trial somebody
would have been given the vaccine
and then exposed to the virus
and then put under observation and then
that would have given you all the data
because ultimately the synthesis of the
thing I mean yes you do need to scale up
synthesis and Manufacturing and what
have you but the information
of whether it worked or not and was safe
and effective and like that could have
been gathered expeditiously with
volunteers for challenge you think
there'd be a large number of volunteers
absolutely what's the concern there was
is there an ethical concern of taking on
volunteers well so let me put it like
this had we done that
we could have had vaccines early enough
to save the lives of like a million
Americans especially seniors and so on
okay soldiers and more generally First
Responders and others
um you know I do believe there's folks
who would have stepped up
um you know to to take that risk the
heroes Walk Among Us yeah that's right
like if military service is something
which is a ritualized thing
um people are paid for it but they're
not paid that much they're really paid
an honor you know and in in Duty and and
pictures that is actually the kind of
thing where
um I do believe some some fraction those
folks would have raised their hand for
this important you know task I don't
know how many of them but I do think
that we the volunteers would have been
there there's probably some empirical
test of that which is a there's a
challenge trials website there's a
Harvard profit put out this proposal
early in the pandemic and he could tell
you how many volunteers he got
um but but something like that could
have just shortened the the time from
pandemic to functional vaccine right to
today's even if you'd actually really
acted on it the fact that that didn't
happen and that the Chinese solution of
lockdown that actually you know at the
beginning people thought the state could
you know potentially stop the virus stop
people in place it turned out to be more
contagious than that basically no NPI no
non-pharmaceutical intervention really
turned out to work that much right
and actually at the very beginning the
pandemic I said something like look it's
actually February 3rd about a month
before people you know I was just
watching what was going on in China I
saw that they were uh doing digital
quarantine like using WeChat codes to
like block people off and so on I didn't
know it was going to happen but I said
look if the coronavirus goes pandemic
and it seems it may the extreme Edge
case becomes The New Normal it's every
debate we've had on surveillance
de-platforming and centralization
accelerated pandemic means emergency
powers for the state even more than
terrorism or crime and sometimes a
solution creates the next problem my
rough forecast for the future the
coronavirus results in quarantines
nationalism centralization and this may
actually work to stop the spread but
once under control States will not see
their powers so we decentralize and I
didn't know whether it was going to stop
the spread but I knew that they were
going to try to do it right and you know
look it's it's hard to call every single
thing right and you know I'm sure you
know someone will find some errors but
in general I think that was that was
actually pretty good for like early
February of 2020 right so it's my point
though the point is rather than copying
Chinese lockdown what we should have had
were different
regimes around the world to some extent
Sweden defected you know from this right
they had like no lockdowns or what have
you but really the the the access that
people were talking about was lockdown
versus no lockdown
um the real action should have been
challenge trials versus no challenge
trials we could have had that in days
okay and that those are two examples on
both vaccines and testing there's so
many more that I can point to so those
are kind of decentralized Innovations
and that's what fdh stand for ipta can
stand for it or something like FDA right
ah so let's talk about that right
something like FDA so this is very
important in general the way I try to
think about things is
V1 V2 V3 as we've talked about a few
times so FDA V
well right so what was before FDA right
so there was both good and bad before
FDA because people don't necessarily
have the right model of the past okay so
you know if you ask people what was
there before the FDA they'll say
um and by the FDA itself emits the right
their pronouns are just FDA FDA okay
um so but basically why is that
important it's just something where
why is that either humorous or
interesting to you
they have a sort of in-group lingo where
when you're when you are kind of talking
about them the way that they talk about
themselves it is something that kind of
Peaks interest it's kind of like uh you
know in in La people say the 101 or the
you know right whereas in Northern
California they'll say 101 uh or people
from Nevada will say Nevada right it
just instantly marks you as like Insider
or Outsider okay in terms of how the
language works right and that's go ahead
that means just makes me sad because
that lingo is part of the mechanism
which creates The Silo the bubble of a
particular thoughts and that ultimately
deviates from the truth because you're
not open to new ideas I think it's
actually like uh you know in glorious
bastards there's a scene in the bar do
you want to talk about it no but it's
good uh you can't uh just just to censor
you this is like a Wikipedia podcast
like Wikipedia you can't cite
um Quentin Tarantino films no okay okay
okay sorry so basically like English
start going like one two three four five
and I believe it's like the Germans
start with like the thumb
something that you'd never know right
I'm even misremming it but I think
that's right okay so uh so that's it has
got the lingo all right right so FDA
scheduling so coming back up basically
just talk about FD and then come back to
your question on on the platform so V
what was V zero FDA C1 what's what does
the future look like V1 V1 was quote
patent medicines okay that's what some
people say but V1 was also Banting in
best okay Banting and Best they won the
Nobel Prize in the early 1920s right why
um they came up with that GR4
um insulin supplementation to treat
diabetes and they came with a concept
they experimented on dogs they did
self-experimentation they had healthy
volunteers they experimented with the
formulation as well right because just
like you'd have like a web app and a
mobile app maybe a command line app you
could have you know drug that's
administered orally or via injection or
cream or you know there's different
formulations right dosage all that stuff
they could just like iterate on okay
with willing doctor willing patient
these uh you know these uh these folks
who were affected uh just spraying out
of bed the insulin supplementation was
working for them and within a couple of
years they had won the Nobel Prize and
Eli Lilly had scale production for the
entire North American continent okay so
that was a time when Pharma moved at the
speed of software
when it was willing buyer willing seller
okay because the past is demonized as
something that our glorious regulatory
agency is protecting us from okay but
there's so many ways in which what's
really protecting you from is being
healthy okay as you know I mean there's
there's a zillion examples of this I
won't be able to recapitulate all of
them just in this podcast but if you
look at a post that I've got it's called
regulation disruption and the future
um Technologies of 2013 Coursera PDF
okay
um this lecture uh which I'll kind of
link it here so you can put in the show
notes if you want
um this goes through
like a dozen different examples of crazy
things the FDA did from
the kind of stuff that was dramatized in
Dallas Buyers Club where they were
preventing people from getting AIDS
drugs to you know their uh you know
various uh attacks on
um you know raw milk where they were
basically saying here's here's a quote
from FDA uh you know
um filing in 2010 uh there's no
generalized right to bodily in physical
health there's no right to consume or
feed children any particular food
there's no fundamental right to freedom
of contract
they basically feel like they own you
you're not allowed to make your own
decisions about your food there's no
generalized right to bodily and physical
health direct quote from their like
written kind of thing okay
the the general frame is usually that
FDA says it's protecting you from the
big bad company but really what it's
doing is checking it's preventing you
from opting out okay now with that said
and this is where I'm talking about V3
as critical as I am of FDA or the FED
for that matter I also actually
recognize that
um like the Ron Paul type thing of End
the Fed is actually not practical and
the FED will just be laughed at what
Bitcoin did was a much much much more
difficult task of building something
better than the fed that's really
difficult to do because the fed and the
FDA they're like the Hub of the current
system people rely on them for lots of
different things okay and
um you're going to need a better version
of them and how would you actually build
something like that so with the fed and
with you know SEC and and the entire you
know the banks and whatnot crypto has a
pretty good set of answers for these
things and over time
all the countries that are not or all
the groups that are not the U.S
establishment or the CCP will find more
and more to their liking in the crypto
economy so that part I think is going
okay we can talk about that
what does that look like for biomedicine
well first what does exit the FDA look
like right so there actually are a bunch
of exits from the FDA already
um which is uh things like right to try
laws okay CLIA labs and laboratory
developed tests compounding pharmacies
off little prescription by doctors and
countries that aren't fully harmonized
with FDA for example you you know Kobe
Kobe Bryant before he passed away went
and did uh stem cell treatments in in
Germany okay stem cells have been pushed
out you know I think in part by the Bush
Administration by other things so
um those are different kinds of exits
right to try basically means you know at
the state level you can just try the
drug okay
um
CLIA labs and ldts that means that's a
path where you don't have to go through
FDA to get a new device approved you can
just run run it in a lab okay
compounding pharmacies these were under
attack I'm not sure actually where the
current you know statute is on this but
this is the idea that a pharmacist has
some discretion and how they you know
prepare mixtures of of drugs
um off little prescription by MDS so MDS
have enough like weight in the system
that they can kind of push back on FDA
an awful little prescription is the
concept that a drug that's approved for
purpose a can be prescribed for purpose
B or C or D without going through
another you know whole new drug approval
process
um and then countries that aren't
harmonized right so those are like five
different kinds of exits from the FDA on
different directions
um so first those exits exist so for
those people who are like oh my God
we're all going to die or he's going to
poison us with you non-fda approved
things or whatever right like uh those
eggs exists you've probably actually use
tests or treatments from those you don't
even realize that you have right so it's
it hasn't killed you number one number
two is actually testing for safety um
you know there's safety efficacy and
like comparative safety is uh it's
actually relatively easy to test for
there's very few drugs that are like
um there's tgn1412 that's a famous
example something there's actually
really dangerous to people right with an
early test so those do exist just
acknowledge they do exist but in general
testing for safety is actually not that
hard to do okay and if something is safe
then you should be able to try it
usually okay now what is that
decentralized FDA look like well
basically you take individual pieces of
it and you can often turn them into
vehicles and um
this is like 50 different startups let
me describe some of them first have you
got any drugs or something like that
recently I mean like prescribed drugs
prescription drugs and it was like no
that you clarify the answer is no yeah
uh prescribed drugs uh no okay so not
not along me antibiotics a long time ago
maybe but I don't know so you you know
how you have like a sort of like a
wadded Up chemistry textbook the package
insert that goes into these right yes
okay it's plotted Up chemistry text me I
love it that's what it is right that's
what a terrible user interface we don't
usually think of it that way why is your
interface so terrible that's a web of
Regulation that makes it so terrible and
uh you know there's actually guys who
try to innovate just on user interface
call like help I need help that was like
the name of the company a while back and
it was it was trying to explain the
stuff in plain language okay
just on user interface you can innovate
and why is that important well
um you know there's a company called uh
pillpack which innovated on quote the
user interface for drugs by giving
people a thing which had like a daily
blister pack so it's like here is here's
your prescription and you're supposed to
take all these pills on the first and
second and basically whether you had
taken them on a given day
was manifest by whether you had opened
it for that specific day okay this is
way better than other kinds of so-called
compliance methodologies like they're
guys who tried to do like an iot pill
where when you swallow it it like gives
you measurements this was just a simple
Innovation on user interface that
boosted compliance in the sense of
compliance with a drug regimen
dramatically right
um and I think they got acquired or
would have you for a lot of money and
hopefully utilized effectively utilize
effective right oh sometimes sometimes
these companies that do incredible
Innovation it really makes you sad when
they get acquired that that leads to
their death not their scaling sure I
mean they did a lot of other good things
but this is one thing that they they did
well right so pillpack just shows what
you can get with improving on user
interface
why can't I mean we get reviews for
everything right one thing that you know
like people are sort of in my view
someone quoted context are like obology
thinks you should replace the FDA with
the help for drugs actually there's
something called phase four okay of the
FDA which is so-called post-market
surveillance do you know that that's
actually something where in theory you
can go and fill out a form on the FDA
website which basically says I've had
you know a bad experience with a drug uh
like theirs but for drugs yeah so it's
like it's called medwatch right
um and so you can do like voluntary
reporting and uh you can get like uh you
know like a PDF and and just like upload
it right is this a government uh like is
this.gov yes form 3500 B well I love it
it's HTML it's gonna be like from the
90s there it's gonna have an interface
yeah designed by somebody who's the
Cobalt slash Fortran programmer right
here we go here we go so basically the
3500b I hope to be proven wrong on that
by the way but so 3500b consumer
voluntary reporting when do I use this
form you were heard or had a bad side
effect use a drug which lets unsafe use
syrup the point is FDA already has a
terrible Yelp for drugs yeah it has a
terrible version of it yeah what would
the good version look like the fact that
you've never I mean this fact you have
to fill out a PDF to go and submit a
report how do you submit a report at
Yelp or Uber or Airbnb or Amazon you tap
and their star ratings right so just
modernizing FDA 3500b and modernizing
phase four okay
is a huge thing is it can you comment on
that is there what incentive mechanism
forces the the modernization of that
kind of thing here's how it would work
or one possible to create an actual Yelp
yeah here's here's here's how that would
work right you go to uh you know the
pharmacy or you know wherever and you
hold up your phone and you scan the
barcode of the drug okay what does you
see instantly you see global reports
right by the way because your biology or
physiology that's Global right
information from Brazil or from Germany
or uh Japan on their physiological
reaction to your the same drug you're
taking is useful to you it's not like a
national boundaries thing so the whole
nation-state model of only collecting
information on by other Americans so
really you want a global kind of thing
just like you know Amazon book reviews
that's like that's a global thing other
things are aggregate at the global level
Okay so
what you want is to see every patient
report and every Doctor around the world
on this drug that might be really
important to your rare or semi-rare
condition just that alone would be a
valuable site who builds that site it's
uh it's it sounds like something created
by capitalism sounds like you could do
it would have to be a company yeah you
can definitely do see these well we
don't have a world where a company is
allowed to be in charge of that kind of
thing well I don't know if Health one
went down it just seems like a lot of
the
so it depends right basically this is
why you have to pick off individual
elements right there's essentially a
combination of first recognizing that
um DFT is actually bad even be able to
say that that let me put it like this it
does a lot of bad things it is something
which you need to be able to criticize
you might be like well that's obvious
right well in 2010 for example there's a
book that came out if anybody wants to
understand FDA it's called reputation
and power yeah a lot of people don't
want to criticize FDA yeah because they
will retaliate against your biotech or
Pharma company yeah and that retaliation
can be initiated by a single human being
absolutely the best analogy is you think
about the TSA okay have you flown
recently okay do you make any jokes
about the TSA when you're in the TSA
line
uh usually you don't want to but they're
a little more flexible you know what can
I tell a story sure which is
it's similar to this I was uh in Vegas
at a club I don't go to clubs they got
kicked out for the I think the first
time in my life for making a joke with a
balancer
and um because I had a camera with me
and you're not allowed to have a cam
camera and and I said okay cool like
I'll I'll take it out but I made a funny
joke that I don't care to retell but he
was just a little offended he was like
you're you're out I don't care who you
are I don't care who you're with
uh and he proceeded to list me the the
famous people he has kicked off but
there is I mean all of those the reason
I made the joke is I sensed that there
was a an entitlement to this particular
individual like uh where the authority
has gotten to respect my authority yeah
right I almost wanted to poke at that
right and I think the poking The
Authority I quickly learned the lesson
well you I have now been rewarded with
the pride I feel for having poked
Authority but now I'm kicked out of the
club that would have resulted in a fun
night with friends and so on instead I'm
standing alone crying in Vegas which is
not a unique Vegas experience sure
actually a fundamental Vegas experience
but that I'm sure that basic human
nature happens in the FDA as well that's
exactly right so just like with the TSA
you know just to extend the analogy when
you're in line at the TSA right you
don't want to miss your flight that
could cost you hundreds of dollars and
so you comply with apps ludicrous
regulations like oh three ounce bottles
well you know you can take an unlimited
number of three ounce bottles and you
can combine them into a six ounce bottle
to the terrorist technology called
mixing yep okay Advanced right and uh
the thing about this is everybody in
line actually some fairly High you know
let's say call it influence or net worth
or whatever people fly right millions
and millions and millions of people are
subject to these absolutely moronic
regulations it's all but you know I
think uh a security theater is is
shire's term right A lot of people know
this term so millions of people are
subject to it it costs Untold billions
of dollars in terms of delays and why
not if you just walk up to right it um
it irradiates people and there's another
FDA thing by the way this is an FDA TSA
team up okay in 2010 the TSA body
scanners there were concerns expressed
but when it's a government to government
thing see a.com is treated with extreme
scrutiny by FDA but it's another.gov
well they're not trying to make a profit
so they kind of sway them on through
okay so these body scanners were
basically like applied to millions and
millions of people and this huge kind of
opt-in experiment it's almost I think
it's quite likely by the way that
if there was even a slightly increased
cancer risk that the net you know
morbidian mortality from those would
have outweighed the deaths from
terrorism or whatever that were
prevented right you can work out the
numbers but under you can just get the
math under reasonable assumptions it's
probably true
um if it had any increased Mobility
mortality I've not seen the recent
things but I've seen that a concern
expressed you know 12 years ago
point being that despite the cost
despite how many people are exposed to
it despite how obviously patently
ludicrous it is you don't make any
trouble nor do people organize protests
or whatever about this because it's
something where
um people the security theater of the
whole thing is is part of it oh well if
we took them away there would be more
terrorism or something like that people
think right but it is fascinating to see
that the populace
puts up with it because it does one of
my favorite things is to listen to
Jordan Peterson who
um I think offline but I think also on
the podcast
you know is somebody who resists
Authority in every way and even he
goes to TSA with a kind of suppressed
like all the instructions everything
down to when whenever you have like the
yellow thing for your feet they they
force you to adjust it even slightly if
you're off just even I mean it's like uh
it's a cough it's a Kafka novel we're
living like TSA it makes me smile it
brings joy to my heart because I imagine
uh Franz Kafka and I just walking
through there because it's it's it
really is just deeply absurd but and
then the the whole motivation of the
mechanism becomes distorted by the
individuals involved the initial one was
to reduce the number of terrorist
attacks I suppose right now it's guns
and drugs basically it's like what they
essentially what they've done is they've
repealed the Fourth Amendment right
search and seizure they can do it
without probable cause everybody is
being searched everybody's a potential
terrorist so if they've got probable
cause for everybody in theory and so
what they do they'll post on their
website the guns and drugs or whatever
that They seized in these scanners well
of course if you search everybody you're
gonna you're gonna find some criminals
or whatever but the cost of doing that
is dramatic moreover the fact that
people have should have been trained to
have you know compliance it's like the
Soviet Union right where
um you know just grudgingly are I go
along with this extremely stupid thing
what's my point the point is this is a
really stupid regulation that has
existed in plain side of everybody for
20 years we're still taking the off our
shoes
okay because some shoe bomb or whatever
number of years ago okay all of this
stuff is there as opposed to there's
resilient other things you could
potentially do different paradigms for
airport security but now apply that to
FDA just like t a lot of what TSA does
is security theater arguably all of it a
lot of what FDA does is safety theater
the difference is there's far fewer
people who go through the aperture
they're the biotech and Pharma CEOs okay
so you don't have you don't have an
understanding of what it is to deal with
them number one number two is the
penalty is not a few hundred dollars of
missing your flight it is a few million
dollars or tens or hundreds of millions
of dollars for getting your company
subject to the equivalent of a
retaliatory wait time just like that
bouncer threw you out just like the TSA
officer if you make a joke or you know
they can just sit you down and make you
lose your flight right so too can the
FDA just silently
impede the approval of something and
choke you out financially because you
don't have enough Runway to get funded
right so just impose more wait time
guess what we want another six months
you know data is going to take you
another six months your company doesn't
have the time you die right if you live
you have to raise around at some diluted
valuation and now the price gets jacked
up on the other side that's the one
thing that can give by the way in this
whole process
when when you push out timelines from
days to get a vaccine approved with your
vaccine evaluator rather via challenge
trials to months or years the cost
during that time when you when you it
just increases non-linearly right
because you can't iterate on the product
it all the normal observations if it
takes you 10 years to launch a product
versus 10 days what's the difference in
terms of your speed of variation your
cost Etc right so this is part of what
it's not the only thing there's other
things there's AMA and CPT there's other
things but
um this is one of the things that jacks
up prices in the US medical system okay
so now you have something where these
CEOs they're going through this aperture
they are uh they can't tell anybody
about it because if you read reputation
and power okay I'm gonna just quote this
because it's amazing amazing book right
it's written by a guy you know Daniel
Carpenter smart guy but he's an FDA
sympathizer he fundamentally thinks it's
like a good thing or what have you
nevertheless I respect Carpenter's
intellectual honesty because he quotes
the CEOs in the book you know verbatim
and you give some paragraphs and
essentially from their descriptions it's
like um think about like a Vietnam War
thing where you've got a pow and they're
like blinking through their eyes I'm
being tortured okay that is the style
when you read Carpenter's book you read
the quotes from these um from these CEOs
oh let me see if I can find it do you
recommend the book it's a good book yeah
or it's it's now a little bit outdated
okay
because it's like you know almost 10
years old still as a history of the FDA
it is well worth reading and by the
reason I say it like the FDA is so
insanely important it's so much more
important than many other things that
people talk about but they don't talk
about it right I just want to read his
little blurb for it right this is 2010.
the U.S Food and Drug Administration is
the most powerful regulatory agency in
the world how did the FDA become so
influential and how does it wield its
extraordinary power reputation power
traces the history of FDA regulation
Pharmaceuticals uh revealing how the
agency's organizational reputation as
being the primary source of its power is
also one of its ultimate constraints
Carpenter describes how the FDA
cultivated a reputation for confidence
and vigilance throughout the last
century and how this organizational
image has enabled agency to regulate
while resisting efforts to curb its own
authority first of all just that
description alone you're like wait a
second
he is describing this as an active
player it's not like
a DMV kind of thing which is passed
through it's it's talking about
cultivating a reputation it's power
resisting efforts to curb its own
authority right the thing is
now you're kind of Through the Looking
Glass you're like wait a second this is
kind of language I don't usually hear
for regulate Regulatory Agencies the
thing is the kind of person who becomes
the CEO of a giant company what do they
want to do they want to expand that
company
they want to make more profit
similarly the kind of person who comes
to run a regulatory agency or one of the
subunits or that person wants to expand
its Ambit
okay whether is that always obvious
decided to interrupt but for the CEO of
the company I know that
the philosophical ideal capitalism is
you want to make the thing more
profitable but
we're also human beings do you think
there's some fundamental aspect to which
you want to do a lot of good in the
world sure but the fiduciary duty will
push people to get the ambitious you
know the profit maximizing expansionist
CEO is selected for
right basically they believe crucially
they're not just this important they're
not just I mean some of them are Grand
Theft Auto make as much money as
possible but they believe in the mission
okay they've come to believe in the
mission and that is a person who's
selected Chomsky actually had this good
thing which is like I believe that you
believe what you believe but if you
didn't believe what you believe you
wouldn't be sitting here right so they
select for the kind of people that are
able to make a lot of money
and in that process uh those people are
able to have construct a narrative that
they're doing good even though what they
were selected for is the fact that they
can make a lot of money yeah and they
may actually be doing good but the thing
is with CEOs we have a zillion images in
television and media movies of the evil
Corporation and the greedy CEO we have
some concept of what Co failure modes
are like okay now when have you ever
seen an evil regulator
have you can you name a fictional
portrayal of an evil regular can you
name an evil see a lot a lot a lot a lot
but that's so interesting I'm trying I'm
searching for a deeper lesson here
you're right
you're right I mean there is co there is
of portrayals especially in sort of
authoritarian regimes or of the Soviet
Union where there's bureaucracy you know
Chernobyl you can kind of see within
that there's a direct the story of the
regulator but
um
yeah it's it's not as plentiful and it's
also doesn't have often doesn't have a
face to it it's just like bureaucracy is
this amorphous thing that results any
one individual you see they're just
obeying somebody else there's not a face
to it I'll be evil that's right the evil
is the entire machine that's right
that's what I call the school of fish
strategy by the way it's something where
you are an individual and you can be
signaled out but there's more
accountability for one person's bad
tweets than all the wars in the Middle
East right because it's a school of fish
yeah right so if the establishment is
wrong if the bureaucracy is wrong
they're all wrong at the same time who
could have known whereas if you deviate
then you are a deviation who can be
hammered down okay now the school of
fish strategy is unfortunately very
successful because uh you know truth is
whatever if you just always ride with
the school of fish and turn when they
turn and so on unless there's a bigger
school of fish that comes in you
basically can never be proven wrong all
right and this is actually you know of
course someone who believes in truth and
believes in you know Innovation and so
on just physiologically can't ride with
the school of fish you just have to say
what is true or do what is true right
still you've described correctly you
know how it's faceless right so I will
give two examples of fictional
portrayals of evil regulators
one is actually the original
Ghostbusters
okay I did not expect that one but yes
yeah so the EPA is actually the villain
in that where they flip a switch that
lets out all the ghosts in the city and
essentially the guys coming in with a
head of steam as this evil regulator
that just totally arrogant doesn't
actually understand the private sector
or or the consequences of their actions
and they force the and crucially they
bring a cop with them with a gun so it
shows that a regulator is not simply you
know some piece of paper but it is the
police right and that cop with the gun
forces the Ghostbusters to like release
the game and the whole thing spreads the
second example is Dallas Buyers Club
which is more recent and that actually
shows the FDA blocking a guy who with a
life-threatening illness uh you know
with AIDS from getting the drugs to
treat his condition and from getting it
to other people right
those are just two portrayals but in
general what you find is when you talk
about FDA with people
one thing I'll often hear from folks is
like why would they do that
right they have no mental model of this
they kind of think of it as
why would the why would this uh thing
which they think of as sort of the DMV
they don't think the DMV as like this
active thing okay why would the FDA do
that well if it is because it's filled
with some ambitious people that want to
keep increasing the power of the agency
just like the CEO wants to increase the
profit of the company right I use that
word Ambit right why Ambit because these
folks are we know the term greedy right
these folks are power hungry
they want to have the maximum scope and
sometimes Regulatory Agencies collide
with each other right even though FDA is
under HHS sometimes it collides with HHS
and they've got regulations at conflict
um you know for example HHS says
everybody's supposed to be able to have
access to their own medical record FDA
didn't want people to have access to
their own personal genomes that
conflicts okay
um and both of those are kind of
anti-corporate statutes that were put
out but HHS this thing being targeted at
the hospitals and FDA being targeted
with the personal genomics companies but
those conflicted right
um it's a little bit like cftc and SEC
have a door jam over who will regulate
cryptocurrency right sometimes
Regulators fight each other
but they fight each other there they
fight companies they are they're active
players this reputation and power book
The reason I mention it is
um I'm gonna see if I can find this
quote so let me see if I can find this
quote reputation and power
organizational image and pharmaceutical
regulation at the FDA
so genentech's executive G Kirk Robb
right Rob would describe regulatory
approval for his products as a
fundamental challenge facing his company
and he would depict Administration a
particularly Vivid metaphor I've told
the story hundreds of times to help
people understand the FDA when I was in
Brazil I worked on the Amazon River for
many months selling terramycin for
Pfizer I hadn't seen my family for eight
or nine months they're flying into Sao
Paulo and I was flying down from some
little village on the Amazon to Manus
and then to Sao Paulo I was young guy in
his 20s I couldn't wait to see the kids
one of them was a year old baby the
other was three I missed my wife
there's a quonset hut in front of just a
little dirt strip with a single engine
plane of fly me to menus I roll up and
there's a Brazilian Soldier there
the military Revolution happened
literally the week before so this
Soldier is standing there with his
machine gun and he said to me you can't
come in
I speak in pretty good Portuguese by the
time I said my God my plane my family I
gotta come in he said again you can't
come in I said I gotta come in and he
took his machine gun took the safety off
and pointed at me and said you can't
come in and I said oh now I got it I
can't go in there and that's the way I
always describe the FDA the FDA is
standing there with a machine gun
against a pharmaceutical industry so you
better be their friend rather than their
enemy they are the boss if you're a
pharmaceutical firm they own you body
and soul
okay that's the CEO of a successful
company Genentech he says he's told the
story hundreds of times
and Regulatory approval is a fundamental
challenge facing this company because
if you are regulated by FDA they are
your primary customer if they cut the
cord on you you have no other customers
and in fact until very recently with the
Advent of social media no one would even
tell your story it was assumed that you
were some sort of
you know corporate criminal that they
were protecting the public from that
you're going to put poison and milk you
know like the melamine scandal in China
I'm not saying those things don't exist
by the way they do exist that's why
people are like they can immediately sum
into mind all examples of corporate
criminals right that's why I mentioned
those fictional stories those templates
even if Star Wars doesn't exist how many
times have you heard a Star Wars
metaphor or whatever for something right
Breaking Bad you know go ahead yeah but
the pharmaceutical companies are stuck
between rock and a hard place because
the reputation if they go to Twitter
they go to social media they have
horrible reputation so it's like they
don't yes but why is that because
reputation and power FDA beat down the
reputation of Pharma companies just like
EPA helped beat down the reputation of
oil companies and as it says over here
right in practice dealing with the fact
of FDA power meant a fundamental change
in corporate structure and culture at
Abbott and at Genentech Rob's most
Central transformation was in creating a
culture of acquiescence towards a
government agency as was done at other
drug companies in the late 20th century
Rob essentially fired officials at
Abbott who were insufficiently compliant
with the FDA what that means is de facto
nationalization of the industry
via regulation
just to hover on that that's a really
big deal
because if their primary customer is
this government agency
then it has nationalized it just
indirectly right this is partially
what's just happened with
um Microsoft Apple Google Amazon the
other Maga okay they have been yeah
that's funny well done
yeah I didn't even think about that as
well done it was right so it's a so the
you know like I have this trees like
Mega Republicans and mega Democrats
right okay
oh damn it so many things you've said
today will just get stuck in my head um
they changed the way you think catchy
something about a catchy phrasing of
ideas is makes me even more powerful uh
so yeah okay so that's happening in the
text it's happening in Tech so Facebook
is the outlier because Zuck still
controls the company but just like I
mean why had Tech had a good reputation
for a while because there wasn't a
regulatory agency whose justification
was regulating these corporate criminals
right once that is the case the
regulatory agency basically comes back
to Congress each year and if you look at
its budget approvals it's saying we find
this many guys we found this many
violations right they have an incentive
to exaggerate the threat in the same way
that a prosecutor or you know policeman
has a quota right like these are the
police you know one way I describe it
also is like
um you know like a step down
Transformers you have high voltage
electricity it's generated at the power
plant and it comes over the wires and
then there's step down Transformers that
turn it into a lower voltage that you
can just deal with out of your
appliances right similarly you have
something where the high voltage of like
the US military or the police and that
is transmuted down into a little letter
that comes in your mailbox saying pay
your 50 parking ticket
where it's a piece of paper so you don't
see the gun attached to it but if you
were to defy that it's like Grand Theft
Auto where you get one star two star
three stars four stars five stars and
eventually you know you have some some
serious stuff on your hands okay so once
you understand that you know every law
is backed by force like that Brazilian
guy with the machine gun that uh Rob
mentioned these guys are the regulatory
police okay now
see for a time what happened was
you had the captured industry because
all of the folks who were in
Pharmaceuticals were as Carpenter said
um
the the culture of acquiescence towards
the FDA FDA was their primary customer
so just like in a sense it's rational
you know Amazon talks about being
customer obsessed right what Rob did was
rational for that time right what g-cur
Rob did was uh saying our customers the
FDA that's our primary customer nobody
else matters they are satisfied first
every single trade-off that has to be
made is FDA right and uh you know really
that's why the two most important
departments that many pharmaceutical
companies argue all are Regulatory
Affairs and IP not r d right because one
is artificial scarcity of Regulation
which jacks up the price and the other
is artificial scarcity the patent which
allows people to maintain the high price
right so this entire thing is just like
you know college education these things
may at some point have been a good
concept but the price has just risen and
risen risen until it's at the limit
price and Beyond okay
so
what has changed what's changed is in
the 2010s late 2000s and 2010s and so on
with the Advent of social media with the
Advent of a bunch of millionaires
um like who are independent uh with the
Advent of
um Uber and Airbnb right but the Advent
of cryptocurrency with the diminution of
trusted institutions it used to be
really taboo to even talk about the
fda's potentially bad in like you know
2010 2009 okay but now people have just
seen face plant after face plant by the
institutions and people are much more
open to the concept that they may
actually not have it all together and I
think it's a you know you you probably
see some tracking pull or something like
that I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like a 20 or 30 point drop after the CDC
failed to control disease and the FDA
failed and the entire biomedical
regulatory establishment and scientific
establishment was saying masks don't
work before they do this was just a
train crash of all the things that
you're paying for that you supposedly
think are good as I mentioned one
response is to go Q Anon and people say
oh don't trust anything but the better
response is decentralizing FDA Okay so
I will say one other thing which is I
mentioned um you know this concept of
improving the form 3500b where you like
scan good yeah yeah right that just
makes me laugh that I could just tell
the form sucks by the fact that it has
that code name yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly right ux is broken at every
layer yeah so so they have a bad Yelp
for drugs could we make it better why
don't we could make a better one just
modern ux the key Insight here by the
way which is a non-obvious point and
I've got a whole talk on this actually
uh that I should probably release I
actually did like almost eight nine
years ago it's called regulation is
information
product quality is a digital signal okay
what do I mean by that basically
when I talk about exit you know exit the
the fed that's the crypto economy right
what does exit the FDA look like well
one key Insight is that many of the big
scale tech companies can be thought of
as Cloud Regulators rather than land
Regulators what do I mean by that well
first what is regulation people do want
a regulated Marketplace they want a
quality ratings like on a one to five
star scale and B bands of Bad actors
like the zero star frauds and scammers
and so on and these are distinct right
somebody who's like a low quality but
well-intentioned person is different
than a smart and evil person those are
two different kinds of failure modes you
could have in the marketplace right why
is it rational for people to want a
regulated Marketplace especially for
health because they want to pay
essentially one entry cost
and then they don't have to evaluate
everything separately where they may not
have the technical information to do
that yes right you don't want to go to
Starbucks and put a dipstick into every
um
coffee to see if it's poisoned or
something like that you sort of want to
enter a Zone where you know things are
basically good and you pay that one
diligence cost on the Zone itself right
whether it's a digital or physical Zone
and then the regulator's taking care of
it and they've baked in the regulatory
cost into you know some subscription fee
of some kind right so the thing is the
model we've talked about is the land
regulator of a nation-state in a
territorially bounded thing but the
cloud regulator what's a cloud regulator
that is
Amazon star ratings that's
um Yelp that is eBay that is Airbnb that
is Uber and Lyft and and so on and so
forth It's also actually Gmail and
Google why because you're doing spam
filtering
and uh you are doing ranking of emails
with priority inbox right uh with Google
itself they ban malware links right so
the Bad actors are out and they're
ranking them right how about Apple the
app store right they ban Bad actors and
they do star ratings when you start
actually applying this lens PayPal you
know they've got a reputation
every single web service that's at the
scale of like tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people has had
to build a cloud regulator
and The crucial thing is it scales
across borders so you can use the data
from Mexico to help somebody in Moldova
or vice versa right because it's
fundamentally International right those
ratings you have a network effect and
um there's another aspect to it which is
these are better Regulators than the
land Regulators for example Uber is a
better regulator than the taxi
medallions why
every write is GPS tracked there's
ratings on both the driver and the
passenger side both parties you know
know that payment can be rendered in a
standard currency right if you have
below a certain star rating on either
side you get de-platformed and so on to
protect either a rider or driver and on
and on right
what does that do think about how much
better that is in tax medallions rather
than a six-month or annual inspection
um you have reports from every single
writer okay before Uber it was the you
know the taxi drivers and taxi
Regulators were in a little Monopoly
locally okay because they were the
persistent actors in the ecosystem taxi
Riders had nothing in common didn't even
know each other some you know New York
some guy gets a taxi another guy they
had no way to communicate with each
other so the persistent actors in these
were the regulators and the drivers and
they had this cozy kind of thing and
Medallion prices just kept going up and
this was a sort of collaboration on
artificial scarcity afterwards with Uber
and Lyft and other entrants you get
something interesting a different kind
of regulator driver Fusion if you assume
regulatory capture exists and lean into
it
Uber is the new regulator
and Uber drivers are the drivers Lyft is
the compete competing regulator and Lyft
driver show the new drivers okay so you
have a regulator driver Fusion versus
another regulator driver Fusion you no
longer have a monopoly you have multiple
parties okay you have a competitive
market this is the concept of like
polycentric law right where you have
multiple different legal regimes in the
same jurisdiction overlapping that you
can choose between with a tap of a
button right all these Concepts from
like libertarian Theory like you know
polycentric law or taxi all these things
are becoming more possible now that the
internet has increased microeconomic
Leverage
and um because that exit is now possible
now
you may argue oh well Lyft and Uber
they're not profitable anymore and
there's two different criticisms of them
one is oh they're not profitable or oh
they're charging too much or and I think
part of this is because of certain kinds
of the the regulatory state is caught up
to try to make them uncompetitive for
example they don't allow people in some
states to identify themselves as
independent contractors even if they are
part-time okay
um there's various other kinds of rules
and regulations you know in Austin for a
while Uber was even banned what have you
right net net though like uber grab
gojack Lyft DD like ride sharing as a
concept is now out there and whatever
the next version is where it's
self-driving like well it's like a very
hard-fought battle and the regulatory
State keeps trying to push things back
into the garage
this is a fundamentally better way of
just doing regulation of taxis similarly
Airbnb for hotels I mean it's basically
the same thing okay and
um now Airbnb could use competition I
think that it would be good to have you
know like competition for them and there
are other kinds of sites opening up but
the fundamental concept of the cloud
regulator now let's apply it here once
you realize regulation is information
the way you would set up a competitor to
FDA or SEC or FAA or something like that
is you just do better reviews
okay just start with that that's pure
information you're under free speech
that's like still you know the most
defended thing literally just publishing
reviews and not just reviews by any old
person it turns out that FDA typically
will use expert panels where there's
extra panels it's like professors from
Harvard or you know things like that
um so what that is is this concept of a
reputational bridge
what you want to do is you want to have
folks who are let's say biotech
entrepreneurs or they're you know uh
profs like Sinclair or what have you you
do want to have the reviews of the crowd
okay but you also want to have
especially in medicine right there so
you want to have the reviews of Experts
of some kind so there's going to be
defectors from the current establishment
okay just like you know there are props
who defected from computer science
Academia to become Larry and Sergey and
whatever you know or they weren't
Prosper they were grad students right
um in the same way you'll have defectors
uh who have the credentials from the old
world but can build up the new just like
there's folks from Wall Street who have
come in cryptocurrency and helped
legitimate it right just like there's
folks who left
um salzburger to come to substack okay
um you know we have we have these folks
who by defecting they help and then
they're also supplemented by all this
new talent coming in right that
combination of things is how you build a
new system it's not completely by itself
nor is it trying to reform the old at
some fusion okay so in this new system
who do you have you have like the most
entrepreneurial and Innovative MDS you
have the most entrepreneurial and
Innovative professors and you have the
founders of actual new products and
stuff and they're giving open source
reviews of these products and they're
also building a community
that will say look we want this new drug
or we want this new treatment or we want
this new device and we're willing to
crowdfund 10 000 units
so please give us the thing and we'll
write a very fair review of it and we'll
also all evaluate it as a community and
so on so you turn these people from just
passive patience into active
participants in their health that's a
community part and they've got the kind
of biomedical technical leadership there
now what is the kind of prototype of
something like this something like Vita
Dow is very interesting things like
molecule Dow are very interesting it'll
start with things like longevity right
and why is that because
the entire model of FDA this 20th
century model is
wait for somebody to have a disease and
then try to cure them
okay versus you know saying an ounce
prevention is worth a pound of cure
right why are we not actually tracking
folks and getting a constant dashboard
on yourself so you can see whether
things are breaking and then you you
deal with it just like you've got server
uptime things you don't wait necessarily
for the site to go down you start seeing
Oh response rates are spiking we need to
add more servers right you have some
warning okay even 10 years ago there's
this article called the measured man in
the Atlantic where this guy physicist
Larry smart Okay what he was doing is he
was essentially doing a bunch of
measurements on himself
and he was finding that uh there were
predictors of inflammation that were
spiking and he went to the doctor showed
the charts and the doctor was like I
can't do anything with this then that
turned out to be an early warning of
like a serious condition and he had to I
think go for like you know surgery or or
something and he was starting to think
well look the way that we're doing
medicine right now is it's not quite
um like pre-germ theory of disease
but it is
pre- continuous Diagnostics
okay continuous Diagnostics just to talk
about this for a second this is I I
mentioned one angle on which you go
after FDA which is like the the better
phase four right I've mentioned the
concept of better reviews in general
okay
I mentioned Vita Dao which is like a
community that is going after longevity
let's talk about continuous Diagnostics
so
basically
We Know Better what is going on in
Bangalore or Budapest in our own body
that's actually kind of insane to think
about the stuff that you know is all the
other side of the world ten thousand
miles away but you know a few
millimeters away you don't really know
what's going on right and that's
starting to change with all the
Quantified Self devices the hundreds of
millions of Apple watches and fitbits
and stuff right you're also starting to
see continuous glucose meters which is
very important they're starting to give
you readouts people are seeing wow this
is spiking my insulin or rather this is
like my my blood sugar and uh it might
be something you didn't predict it
varies for different people for some
people you know banana isn't a big deal
for others it's actually quite bad for
the blood sugar what happens when you
extend that well about 10 years ago a
guy Mike Snyder
um professor at Stanford did something
called the integrome where he just threw
the kitchen sink of all the Diagnostics
he could at himself over the period of I
think a few weeks or a few months I've
got the exact duration he's able to do
things where you could see during that
period he like got a cold or something
and he could see in the expression day
the gene expression data that he was
getting sick before he felt sick he
could also see that something about that
like viral infection like uh
made him develop diabetes-like symptoms
if I'm remembering it accurately so you
could see oh wait a second these are
things that are
um that I can see in my readouts that I
would only have the vaguest
interpretation of as like a human being
right
and moreover he could take uh you know I
don't think he did this but if you took
treatments if you took drugs right
you could actually show what your steady
state was if you tracked over time show
what your disease state or six state was
and then this drug pushes you back into
non-disease State you can actually get a
quantitative readout of what you know
like steady state was right so that and
and that stay safe you know your
expression levels across all these genes
uh your small molecules basically
everything you can you could you can
measure
that's going to vary from person to
person right what's healthy and natural
for you may be a different Baseline than
for me for example people who are small
example people who are South Asian
um or have dark skin tend to have
vitamin D deficiency why because we need
a lot of sunlight so often inside you're
tapping on your screen so what do we do
take like actually significant vitamin D
infusions okay
that's like a small example of where
baselines differ between people okay so
continuous Diagnostics what could that
mean that could mean you know things
like the continuous glucose meter it's
Quantified Self it's like continuous
blood testing right so you have a
so-called mobile phlebotomist this is
something which uh phlebotomist takes
blood right mobile phlebotomy would come
to your office come to your remote
office this is a great business for
people I think you know you can revisit
this in in 2022 if people tried this in
the 2010s but I think it's worth
revisiting mole phlebotomist comes every
week or every month takes blood runs
every test right maybe that's you know a
few thousand dollars a year maybe
eventually gets to a few hundred dollars
a year
um and that's expensive in some ways but
boy that's better health insurance in
other ways yeah I mean it's amazing so
one there's a bunch of companies that do
this and actually would love to learn
more about them what what one of them
it's a company called inside tracker
that sponsors this podcast they do that
but the reason I really appreciate them
they're the first ones that introduced
me to like how easy it is but it's also
depressing how little information
exactly as you beautifully put once
again how little information we have
about our own body
in a continuous sense yes and actually
also sadly even with inside tracker as I
collect that data how not integrated
that data is with everything else right
if I wanted to opt in I would like
I I get just like Roofing off the top of
my head but I would like Google Maps to
know what's going on inside my body
maybe I can't Intuit at first why that
application is useful but there could be
an incredible like that's where the
entrepreneurial Spirit builds is like
what can I do with that data can I make
the trip more less stressful for you and
adjust the Google Maps thing kind of
thing that's right yeah so I mean one of
the things about this by the way is
because there are so many movies made
about darnos okay that's one of the
reasons why people have sort of been
scared off from doing Diagnostics uh to
some extent okay why because visas are
like oh this is another theranos and
like the diligence and everything
everyone's looking at it oh blood
testing one drop of blood huh hurts the
recruiting essentially
um a lot of the media and stuff around
that basically it's pathologized the
thing that we want to have a lot more
entrance in right now you know one way
of thinking about it is
FDA is killed way more people than
theranos has all right way more just
take drug lag alone okay whenever you
have a drug that works and reduce
morbidity and mortality after it was
actually generally available but was
delayed for months or years
the integral under that curve is the
excess morbidian mortality attributable
to fda's drug lag
you could go back and do that study
across lots and lots of different drugs
and you probably find quite a lot Alex
tabarok and others have written on this
right Daniel Henninger is written on
this okay that's just like one example I
mean I gave the pandemic example the
fact that they held up the euas for the
tests and didn't do challenge trials
that's like you know they're not that's
like a million American Dead that could
be in order to magnitude less if we had
gotten the vaccine out to vulnerable
population sooner okay so you're talking
about something that has a total
Monopoly on global health and
um you know you can't know what it is
without that unless you have zones that
are FDA free but that have some form of
Regulation as I mentioned it's a V3 it's
not going back to zero regulation
everybody in a man for itself but it's a
more reputable regulator
just like um you know Uber is a better
regulator than the taxi medallions right
yeah I mean you're painting such an
incredible picture you're making me wish
you were FDA commissioner but I I there
are a bunch of people who tweeted
something like that after the you know
with the pandemic
um whatever go ahead yeah is that is
that possible like if you were just
given uh if you became FDA commission
could you could you push for those kinds
of changes or is that really something
that has to come from the outside the
short answer is no and the longer answer
meaning they'll that'd be funny if you
like the short answer is no the long
answer is yes
so so basically see a CEO of a company
it's well it's very difficult they can
hire and fire right so in theory they
can do surgery on the organism and like
you know Steve Jobs took over apple and
was able to hire and fire raise money do
this that he basically had root over
Apple that he was a system administrator
right he had he had full permissions
okay as FDA commissioner you do not have
full permissions over FDA let alone like
the whole structure around it right if
your FDA commissioner you are not the
CEO of the agency okay lots of these
folks there uh have career tenure they
they can't be fired
um they can't even really be disciplined
there's something called the Douglas
factors you ever heard the Douglas
factors it's like the Miranda rights for
federal employees okay you have the
right treatment size so basically if
you've heard that federal employees
can't be fired the Douglas factors are
how that's actually operationalized when
you try to fire somebody
it's this whole process where they get
to appeal it and so on and so forth and
they're sitting in the office while
you're trying to fire them and they're
complaining to everybody around them
that this guy's trying to fire me he's
such a bad guy blah blah right and
everybody around even if you know they
may think that guy is doing a bad job
they're like wait a second he's trying
to fire you he might try to fire me too
and so anybody who tries to fire
somebody at FDA just gets a face full of
lead for their troubles what they
instead will do is sometimes they'll
just transfer somebody to the basement
or something so they don't have to deal
with them if they're truly bad okay but
the thing about this is there is only
one caveat Douglas Factor number eight
the notoriety of the offense or its
impact upon the reputation
of the agency there's that word again
reputation of reputation and power so
the one way you can truly screw up
within a regulatory bureaucracy is if
you sort of endanger the like annual
budget renewal think of it as like this
mini death star that's coming to dock
against the max Death Star for it's like
annual refuel and it's talking about all
the corporate criminals that it's
prosecuted the quotas like the police
quotas the ticketing you know and
if they don't have a crisis they will
like invent one just again just like TSA
just like other agencies you're more
familiar with you can kind of map it
back look at the guns and drugs we've
seized sir and save an incentive for uh
you know creating these crises or
manufacturing them or exaggerating them
and if you endanger that refueling that
annual budget renewal or you know what
have you then the whole agency will
basically be like okay you're you're bad
and you can be disciplined or sometimes
you know with rare except you know you
can be booted but what that means is
that FDA commissioner is actually a
white elephant it's a ceremonial role
really right you know you know the term
white elephants like uh basically you
know the Maharaja gives you an out a
white elephant as a gift
seems great next day it's eating all of
your grass it's pooped on your lawn it
has like just put a foot on your car and
smashed it but you can't give it away
it's a white elephant the Maharaja gave
it to you right that's what being like
FDA commissioner is it's the kind of
thing where
if
and a lot of people are drawn in Like
Moths To The Flame for these titles
of the establishment I want to be head
of this I want to be head of that right
and really what it is it's like
I don't know becoming head of Kazakhstan
in the mid-1980s in the Soviet Union the
Kazakhstan SSR right Soviet Socialist
Republic before the thing was going to
like crumble potentially right in many
ways it's becoming you know folks who
are just totally status obsessed getting
these positions but
um like a lot of the Merit all the folks
with Merit are kind of leaving the
government and going into you know
attack or crypto or what have you right
so even if these agencies were Hollow
before and somebody's becoming Hollow
were because they have less Talent there
right so a you can't hire and fire very
easily you can hire a little bit you
can't really fire
um
B A lot of the talent has left the
building but was there see we're
entering the decentralizing era and D
you know like be like Satoshi Satoshi
founded Bitcoin because he knew you
could not reform the FED there's
everybody is trying to go and reform
reform reform the reason they're trying
to reform is we haven't figured out the
mechanism to build something new and now
perhaps we have that so I've named a few
of them right I'll name one more
related to deodorants Fitness is
actually the back door to a lot of
medicine okay why is that
um you go to any you know conference it
could be neurology it could be
cardiology you'll find somebody who's
giving a talk that says something along
the lines of Fitness is the ultimate
drug Maybe not today when people are
saying oh fat phobic whatever but not
too many years ago you'd see somebody
um people saying Fitness is the ultimate
drug if we could just prescribe Fitness
in a pill that would improve your
cardiovascular function your no large
functional depression by the way in that
case the the use of the word drug means
medicine so medicine yeah yeah sure uh
Fitness is the ultimate medicine yeah
yeah the ultimate medicine right so
if they could just prescribe the effects
of it it's just like boom just massive
effect right like you're fit enough you
do resistance training it helps with you
know preventive diabetes every kind of
thing in the world you see a significant
treatment effect
yet your Fitness is your own
responsibility you go to some gym 24
Hour Fitness what do they have they have
on the wall exhortations like your body
is your responsibility right am I right
yeah yeah and you know uh good but no
it's just it's hilarious yes yes it's
funny but it's true right yeah it's
funny because it's true and so your
Fitness your diet that's your
responsibility but when you go into a
doctor's office suddenly it becomes lie
back and think of England
okay suddenly you become passive
suddenly oh your doctor your doctor is
Dr Google well your doctor must be a
[ __ ] you're you're going and trying to
take care of yourself you're Googling
symptoms oh how stupid you are I have a
medical degree and that doctor
see the thing is if you come in and you
you've self-diagnosed or you've done
some of your own research if you're
right there and if they've got an ego
about it they're undermined and if
you're wrong they're like you know haha
you know arrogant but either way they
have is if they've got this kind of
mindset they have an incentive to resist
the patient taking care of themselves
isn't that the doctor's job right and
they're kind of taught to behave like
this many of them
so what that means then is that
intervention of that 15 or 30 minute
appointment with the doctor whatever
drug they prescribe better hit you like
Thor's hammer to put you back on the
straight and narrow because that's only
with you for like a few seconds you know
a few minutes or whatever the doctor's
only with you for a few minutes the drug
is only you know some drugs are very
powerful so they actually do work like
this okay but
your Fitness is your own responsibility
and that's a continuing forcing function
every day and again we get back to
decentralization right the
decentralization responsibility from
somebody thinking themselves merely as a
patient to enact a participant in their
own health who's doing their own
monitoring of their own health right and
logging all their stuff who's eating you
know properly and looking at the effect
of their diet on things like their you
know continuous glucose monitor is a V1
but other things right
um who is you know as fit as they can
possibly be like these are kind of
obvious things but why is this the back
door to medicine because
since FDA only regulates those things
that are meant to diagnose and treat a
disease
all the stuff that is meant to improve
an otherwise healthy person is
potentially out of their purview
supplements are one interesting aspect
that they were carved out uh in the in
the mid 90s and that's why the
supplement industry is Big because FDA
isn't it doesn't have as tired of rain
on that but all of the Fitbit uh CGM
continuous glucose meter type stuff you
can crank out all kinds of things that
help people get fitter
that will also actually have just
general health value but you're not quit
marketing them to diagnose or treat you
know a disease see what I'm saying
you're marketing them for the purpose of
Fitness this is a market why because
psychologically people they don't like
paying to get back to normal
but they will absolutely pay tons of
money to get better than normal they'll
pay for Fitness they'll pay for makeup
they'll pay for hair they'll pay for
this and that right so that's actually
the back door and you can do tons of
things there where obviously being
healthier
is also protective you can actually show
the studies on this so this way you
build out all the tooling to get
healthier and that actually helps on
this axis
fewer things are kind of U.S medical
system while I'm Onyx you got me on this
topic I love this okay so this is uh
this is the most eloquent exploration of
the U.S medical system and how to
improve it how to fix it and what the
future looks like yeah so love it so
basically so part of it is
decentralizing control back to the
individual right now I've talked about
FDA at length but let me talk about some
other other broken parts of the U.S
system right
um there's like AMA there's CBT there's
cpom there's this you know like all
these regulations which see normally
in capitalism you have a uh a buyer and
a seller right duh in medicine you have
third party regulation and fourth party
pricing and
um fifth party payment okay so
third-part regulation FDA is regulating
it fourth party pricing it is
um you know the the CPT codes right
fifth party payment it's the insurance
companies all right and just to discuss
these bits of the system
first
why are some people against capitalism
in medicine I actually understand why
they're against it because they are
visualizing themselves on a gurney when
they're being wheeled in and now
somebody at their moment of
vulnerability is charging this insane
price for their care and many people in
the US have had this horrible experience
where they're bankrupted or scared of
being bancrypted by medical bills
therefore the concept of adding more
capitalism venison scares them and they
think it's horrible and you're some like
awful greedy Tech bro kind of thing all
right
let me let me say I understand that
concern let me you know kind of let me
pull tease that apart a little bit right
basically the most capitalistic areas of
medicine are the most functional areas
of medicine so that say the places where
you can walk in and walk out okay
whether that's Dentistry Dermatology
plastic surgery even veterinary medicine
which is not human okay where you can
make a conscious decision say Okay I
want this care or I don't want this I
see a price list I can pay cash right if
I don't like it I go to another
dermatologist there's few Dermatological
emergencies that's why dermatologists
have a great quality of life okay by
contrast when you're being wheeled in on
a gurney you need it right now okay and
you're unconscious or would have you or
you're not in a capacity to deal with it
right
and so these are the two extremes it's
like ambulatory medicine you can walk
around and pick and like ambulance
medicine okay and what what that means
is the more ambulatory the medicine the
more legitimate capitalism is in that
situation people are okay with a
dermatologist basically turning you down
because you don't have enough money and
you go to another dermatologist because
you can comparison shop there it's not
usually an emergency right
whereas if you're coming in with an
ambulance
then people don't want to be turned down
and I understand why okay what this
suggests by the way is that you should
only have insurance for the edge cases
Insurance should only cover the
ambulance not the ambulatory and most
people are losing money on insurance
right because most people are paying
more in in premiums than they are
getting out it's just that this huge
flight of dollars through the air that
no one can make heads or tails out of oh
the other aspect that's obviously broken
you know is employer provided health
insurance just started after World War
II so you know auto insurance is in a
much more competitive market you don't
whip out your auto insurance card at the
gas station to pay for your gas right
you only whip it out when there's a
crash right that's what quote health
insurance should be and the Singapore
model is actually a pretty good one for
this where they have sort of a mandatory
HSA you have to like put some money in
that and um that pays for your
Healthcare bills but then it's cash out
of that it's like a separate pocket sort
of four savings to pay for health
savings account health savings account
right the thing about this is once you
realize well first ambulatory medicine
is capitalistic medicine ambulance
medicine is socialist medicine okay you
want to shift people more towards
ambulatory guess what that's in their as
well now that brings us back to the
monitoring
right the continuous monitoring where
whether eventually it's Mike Snyder's
integrone the V1 is the Quantified
itself and the Apple watch and the you
know continuous glucose meters and a VN
is the Mike Snyder inch chrome there's a
site called Q dot bio which is doing
this also right eventually this stuff
will hopefully just be in a device that
just measures tons and tons of variables
on you right there's ways of measuring
some of these metabolites and you know
without breaking the skin
um you know so so it's like it's not you
don't have to keep breaking the skin
over and over there's various various
ways of doing that so now you've got
something where you've got the
monitoring you've got the dashboards
you've got the alerts and just like this
Larry smart guy that I mentioned the
measured man you might be able to shift
more and more things to ambulatory and
one of the things about this also is the
medical system is set up in a bad way
where the primary care physician is the
one who is like not the top of their
class but the guys who are at the bottom
of the pinball machine the surgeons and
the Radiologists once your stuff is
already broken okay they're the ones who
are paid the most so a lot of the skill
collects at the post-break stage right
right where you actually want Doogie
Hauser MD is that the the Upstream stage
okay so you want this amazing amazing
doctor there right how could we get that
I mentioned the app that doesn't exist
which is like a better version of the
3500b right here's another app that
doesn't exist and this is one that FDA
is actively quashed why can't you just
take an image of a mole or something
like that you know with the incredible
cameras we have a huge amount of Medical
Imaging should be able to be done at
home and it goes to doctors whether it's
in the U.S or the Philippines or India I
mean tele-radiology exists right why can
you not do that for Dermatology for
everything else you should be able to
literally just hold the thing up and
with a combination of both Ai and MDS
just diagnose that should exist right
um answer is
there's a combination of both American
doctors and the FDA that team up to
prevent this or slow this
um and you know one argument is oh the
AI is not better than a human 100 of the
time because it's not deployed yet
therefore it could make an error
therefore it's bad even if it's better
than 99 of doctors 90 of the time
another argument is the software has to
go through design control okay now
basically once you understand how FDA
Works basically imagine the most
bureaucratic Frozen process for code
deployment at any company ever
and that is the most Nimble thing ever
relative to fda's design review so just
to review a talked about how FDA was
blocking all this stuff B talked about
why ambulatory medicine is capitalist
medicine uh ambulance medicine and
socialist medicine C talked about how
with the diagnostic stuff we can shift
it over to ambulatory D talked about how
there's lots of things where you could
have a combination of doctor and Ai and
an app
um that you kind of quickly
self-diagnose some of this is happening
now the the some of the telemedical
telemedicine laws were relaxed during
covet where now people you know a doctor
from Wyoming can prescribe for somebody
in Minnesota like some of that stuff is
relaxed during covet okay there's other
broken things of alcoholism I'll just
name two more and then kind of move on
okay I mentioned like AMA and CPT okay
those are two regulatory bodies Amy
American Medical Association CPT current
procedural terminology okay basically uh
you know Marx's labor theory of value
where people are supposed to be paid on
their effort right
um of course the issue with this is that
you'd be paying a physicist to try to
dunk and you know they'd be trying but
they wouldn't actually probably be able
to do it they'd be trying real hard
whereas you actually want to pay people
invasive results right cheaply attained
results are actually better than
expensively attained non-results perhaps
obvious okay nevertheless the way that
the U.S medical system has payouts it's
based on so-called rvu's relative value
units and this is something where
there's a government body
that sets these prices uh and it is in
theory only for Medicare but all the
private insurers key off of that and
um AMA uh basically publishes a list of
these so-called um the CPT codes which
is like the coding the biomedical coding
of this
and what each medical process is worth
and whatnot so it's like
I don't remember all the numbers but um
it's like a five digit code and it's
like okay I got a I got a test for
Cystic Fibrosis or a test for this or a
test for that God help you if you're
um medical billing is erroneous why the
insurance company will reject it
um because it doesn't pay for that this
is this giant process of trying to
encode
um you know every possible ailment and
condition into these CPT codes and that
you can literally get degrees in medical
billing just for this okay this enormous
inefficient industry yeah okay like
literally medical billing is a whole
field okay yeah now what do you want to
do when you grow up I want to work in
medical billing in medical billing okay
where everybody's mad at you at all
times yeah part of what happens is when
you give a treatment when a doctor gives
a treatment to a patient
they can't like repo the treatment okay
like a car you sell a car you can Theory
repo the car so patient has a treatment
now
um what happens well the insurance
company uh
you know that that treatment is perhaps
right look it's a lab test provided by a
company right the company bills the
patient
the company is supposed to charge a high
price why the insurance company wants it
to try to collect from the patient the
patient is scared oh my God they see
this huge price they um they sometimes
don't pay sometimes the insurance
company doesn't pay either and uh when
when a company is stiff by an insurance
company uh when a diagnostic I mean
shipment step by insurance company it
has to jack up the price on everybody
else right everything boils down to the
fact that you don't have you know a
buyer and a seller the doctor doesn't
know the price of what is being sold uh
the buyer doesn't know the price of what
is being bought at the time it's being
bought uh neither party can really even
set a free price because there's this
rvu system that hovers above the buyer
feels they've already bought it because
they've bought Insurance the insurance
company doesn't want to pay for it
everybody is trying to like push the
price onto somebody else and you know
not actually show the sticker price of
anything and hide everything and so on
and so forth oh the other thing about it
is obviously lawsuits are over
everything everybody's mad out about
everything it's Health people are dying
okay so everything is just optimized for
Optics as opposed to results right
similarly actually many drugs are
optimized for minimizing side effects
and Optics rather than maximizing
effects which are totally different
criteria right you might have for
example a drug that only cures a
thousand people but doesn't have any
side effects versus one that cures a
million people but that has 10 really
serious side effects a year right and
the second one would probably not happen
because those side effects would be so
so big okay
how do you attack this I name a few
examples but I actually think the reform
is going to come in part from outside
the system in particular India is coming
online
okay why is that important well
you may have encountered an Indian
doctor or two okay maybe an Indian
programmer one or two all right and I do
think telemedicine
could explode right where you could have
an Indian doctor
um you know in India and there's a U.S
doctor okay who's like a dispatcher
you see what I'm saying they've got all
these other Indian doctors behind them
they've got a telemedical app and you
are now doing something where uh these
relatively inexpensive Indian doctors
who are vetted by the American doctor or
the doctor in the jurisdiction of the
license become the back end doctors of
the world to some extent that's already
there with Tel radiology and other kinds
of things right but now that you've got
literally like a billion Indians who've
just come online okay you have this huge
pool of folks who have a different
attitude towards medicine for example
it's a lot more cash payment over there
for example India is big on generic
drugs for example during covet it had
something called uh has something called
a rogia sethu which is a national
telemedicine app okay this wasn't able
to ship that in some ways India's
digital infrastructure again you'll have
to read a post called uh the internet
country by
tigerfeathers.subsack.com and you'll see
that actually India's national software
infrastructure is surprisingly good it's
not as good as China's in some ways but
it's like better than the US's which is
like healthcare.gov and like
non-existent it's like kind of
impressive how good some of India's
software is the fact it exists is good
so you have all these new doctors coming
online India cranks out generics right
telemedicine is now more legal in the US
and you have a cash payment in India
right and in a lot of other places you
don't have the whole Insurance employer
help thing and this Market is growing
so you could have a sort of parallel
Market that starts evolving right which
is and people are already doing some
medical tourism or anything that's
another exit from the FDA you have a
parallel Market that starts evolving
that just starts from fundamentally
different premises it's just cash
cash for everything right there's
downsides with cash for everything
there's a huge upside with cash for
everything cash for everything means you
give customer service from the doctor it
means the prices are actually visible
it ideally pushes you again towards more
ambulatory medicine rather than
ambulance medicine
it is monitoring constant monitoring
with the Quantified Self and whatnot as
opposed to just let your system fail and
then wheel you in right
um there's a reputational bridge because
now we've had a couple of generations
almost of Indian doctors in the US so
people know that there's you know
there's some very competent Union
doctors they're a good chunk of AMA and
so that they can serve Lobby for this
and uh you have plenty of Indian
Engineers now I'm not saying India alone
is a Panacea but I do think that this is
a large enough parallel Market to start
doing interesting things now you could
see uh sort of medical tourism medical
migration to where it gives India an
opportunity to basically
uh let go of the constraints of the FDA
yeah because and innovate aggressively
and and I mean it's just such a huge
opportunity to define the future of
medicine and make a [ __ ] ton of money
from a market that's desperate for it in
the United States because of all the
over the regulation that's right and I
think basically it's something where the
reason it needs that would fix the fdsr
to interrupt yes we fixed FDA by exiting
the FDA right and then the FDA would dry
out and then it would hopefully it might
reform it might dry out right and this
is you know why people are for example
they're traveling across borders you
know they're getting orders from
Canadian pharmacies you know a lot of
this type of stuff we can start to build
Alternatives right I mean India's
generic industry is really important
because it just doesn't enforce American
IP there
so generic drugs are cheaper right and
it's quite confident it's been around
for a while so there's enough proof
points there where
um again I'm not seeing a Panacea it's
going to be something which will require
like American and Indian collaboration I
think there's gonna be a lot of other
countries and so on that are involved
but you can start to see another poll
getting set up which is a confident
enough civilization
that is willing to take another
regulatory path right and that is in
some ways doing better on National
software than the US's and it has enough
of a bridge to the US that it can be
that stimulation which you need which is
kind of something that outside poke
right I want to talk about India but let
me just kind of wrap up on this big FDA
biomedical kind of thing right
with the book the network State the
purpose of the network State you know
you know I I want people to be able to
build different kinds of network States
I want people to build
the vegan Village I want people to be
able to build a you know if they want to
do the bendig option like a like a
Christian number if people want to do
different kinds of things I'm open to
many different things and I will fund
lots of different things
um for me the motivation is just like
you needed to
start a new currency Bitcoin
it was easier to do that than reform the
FED I think it's easier to start a new
country than reform the FDA and so I
want to do it to in particular get to
longevity right meaning longevity
enhancement right and what does that
mean so
in an interesting way and this will
sound like a trite statement but I think
it's actually a deep statement or let me
hopefully try to convince you it is
crypto is to finance or what longevity
is to you know the current state of
medicine why it inverts certain
fundamental assumptions okay so at first
crypto looks like traditional Finance
it's got the charts and the bands and
you're buying and selling so on but what
Satoshi did is he took fundamental
premises and flipped them for example
in the traditional macroeconomic
worldview hyperinflation is bad
but deflation is also bad so a little
inflation is good right in the
traditional macroeconomic worldview
um it's good that there are custodians
banks that you know kind of intermediate
the whole system right and the
traditional you know worldview
um
every transaction needs to be reversible
because somebody could make a mistake
and and so on and so forth right in the
traditional worldview you don't really
have root access over your money
Satoshi inverted all of those things
okay
obviously you know the big one is
hyperinflation is bad but he also
thought mild inflation was bad and
deflation was good that's just a
fundamental shift okay
he gave you Rude access over your money
you're Now assistant Ministry of your
own money you can room Dash RF your
entire fortune or send Millions with a
keystroke you are now the system
administrator of your own money that
alone is why cryptocurrency is important
if you want assist Administration access
at times to computers you'll want it to
currency right to be sovereign
you know there's other assumptions where
like the assumptions every transaction
is private in the existing system by
default or it's visible only to the
state whereas at least the initial you
know the Bitcoin blockchain everything
is public right there are various kinds
of things like this where he just
inverted fundamental premises
and um and then the whole cryptosystem
is in the crypto economy is in many ways
of teasing out of what that means
just to give you one example the US
dollar
people have seen those graphs where it's
like inflating and so it just like loses
value over time and you've seen that
okay
whereas uh and and most the time it's
just sort of denied that it's losing any
value the
um the most highbrow way of Defending it
is the US dollar trades off
temporary short-term price stability for
long-term depreciation
and Bitcoin makes the opposite trade-off
in theory at least long-term
appreciation at the expense of
short-term price instability
because like you know there's the whole
plunge Protection Team and so on
basically there's there's various ways
in which price stability has tried to be
maintained in a medium term at the
expense of long-term depreciation you
need like a reserve assets to keep you
know stabilizing the dollar against
various things so
what does crypto medicine look like
relative to Fiat medicine to make the
same analogy right the existing medical
system it assumes that
um a quick death is is bad and early
death is bad
but also that living forever is either
unrealistic or impossible or undesirable
that you should die with dignity or
something like that okay
so a little death is good that's the
existing medical system
whereas the concept of life extension
and you know David Sinclair and you know
what they call you call it health span
says rejects that fundamental premise
and it says actually the way to defeat
cancer is to defeat aging aging is
actually a program biomedical biological
process and we can we have results that
are showing stopping or even reversing
Aging in some ways and so now just like
uh just like with the with the other
thing you say a quick death is bad
and so is actually death itself right so
we actually want significant life
extension this is similar it's very it's
very similar to what uh you know the
rejection of the the Fiat system right
the Fiat system says a low inflation is
good
Fiat medicine says a little death is
good
Bitcoin says actually no inflation just
get more valuable over time and crypto
medicine says actually let's you know
extend life this leads to all kinds of
new things where you start actually
thinking about all right how do I
maintain my health with
um you know Diagnostics how do I
um you know take control of my own
health the decentralization of medicine
all the stuff that I've been describing
sort of fits like longevity is
traditional medicine as crypto is to
traditional currency if we take those
assumptions separately so we take
cryptocurrency aside
is that to you obvious that this letting
go of this assumption
about death is that is that an obvious
thing is longevity
Obviously good versus for example the
The Devil's Advocate to that would be
what we want is to keep death and
maximize the quality of life up until
the end well like so that uh you ride
into the sunset or healthy somebody who
is listening to whole pocket should say
well balji just a few hours ago you were
saying this gerontocracy runs the US and
they're all old and they don't get it
blah blah now you're talking about
making people live forever so there's
never any new blood to watch about haha
what a contradiction right it's funny
that
you're so on point across all the topics
we and uh all the topics we covered and
the possible criticism I love it well
just trying to anticipate you know
something good well done so done sir the
I think the argument on that is so long
as you have a frontier it is okay for
someone to live long okay so long as
people can exit to a new thing number
one number two is in order for us to go
and you know colonize other planets and
so on you know if you do want to get to
Mars if you want to become you know Star
Trek and you know what have you
um probably going to need to have
you know like you know just to survive a
long flight so to speak you know
multiple light year flight you're going
to need to have life extension so to
become a pioneering you know
Interstellar kind of thing I know that
like it's it's the kind of thing which
sounds like okay yeah and when we're on
the moon we're gonna need shovels you
know it's it sounds like
a
piling a fantasy on top of a fantasy in
that sense but it's also something where
if you're talking about the vector of
our civilization where are we going well
I actually do think it's either an arc
of primitivism or optimalism
transhumanism either we are shutting
down civilization as degrowth it's you
know Unabomber Etc or it's the stars and
escaping the prime number maze it's like
to me
it's obvious that we're going to if
we're to survive expand out into space
yes and it's obvious
that once we do we'll look back at
anyone which is currently most people
that didn't think of this future didn't
anticipate as future work towards his
future as as luddites like as people who
did totally didn't get it it would
become obvious if right now it's
impossible and then it will become
obvious yes it seems like yes longevity
in some form I mean there could be a lot
of arguments of the different forms
longevity could take but in some form of
longevity is almost a prerequisite for
the expansion out into the cosmos that's
right expansion of longevity there's
also like a way to bring it back to
Earth to an extent which is how where
societies used to be judged you may
remember people used to talk about life
expectancy as a as a big thing right
life expectancy is actually a very very
good metric why it's a ratio scale
variable you know there's like four
different class of variables statistics
let's talk about ratio scale is like
years or meters or kilograms okay then
you have interval scale where plus and
minus means something but there's no
absolute zero then you have ordinal
where there's only ranks and plus and
minister of anything and then you have
categorical like uh the Yankees and the
the the Braves are categorical variables
they're just different but you all you
have is the comparator operator whether
you have a quality you don't have a rank
okay so ratio scale data is the best
because you can compare it across space
and time if you have a skeleton that is
like you know two meters tall
that's from 3000 years ago you can
compare the height of people from many
many years ago different cultures and
times right whereas their currency is
much harder to Value that's not like a
ratio scale variable other things are
harder to Value across space and time
right so life expectancy is good because
as a ratio scale variable is a very
clear definition right like when someone
born and died you know those are
actually relatively clear
um
by the most other things aren't like
that you know you uh that's why murder
or you know death that you know it can
be scored it's an ambiguous you know
it's done when it's done whereas when
did somebody get sick oh they were kind
of sick or they were sick today they
were sick at this hour the boundary
conditions many other kinds of things
are not like clear-cut like that right
and I should just briefly comment that
life expectancy does have this quirk
a dark cork that it uh when you just
crudely look at it is incorporates uh
child mortality or mortality yes at age
of one or age of five and
um maybe it's better and clearer to look
at mortality after after five or
whatever and that's still those metrics
still hold in interesting ways and
measure the progress of human
civilization in interesting ways yeah
that's right you actually want longevity
biomarkers a lot of people are working
on this there's a book called the
picture Dorian Gray right and the
concept is sell your soul to you know
ensure the picture rather than he will
age and fade right and uh so the concept
is that that thing on the wall just
reflects his age and you can see it okay
so there's a premise that's in bed in a
lot of Western culture that
to gain something you must lose if you
if you're Icarus and you try to fly then
you will you know you'll fly too high
and you'll melt your wings but guess
what we fly every day commercial air
flight right so the opposite of like the
Icarus or picture of durian gray kind of
thing is the movie Limitless which I
love because it's so nietzschean and so
unusual relative to the dystopian you
know Sci-Fi movies where there's a
without giving I mean the movie's kind
of old now but
um there's a drug in it that's a
neurotropic that boosts you know your
cognitive abilities and it's got side
effects but at the end he Engineers out
the side effects amazing just like you
know yeah their planes are crashing we
land right okay so why'd I mention the
picture during great well there's
another aspect of it which is
longevity biomarker the point is to kind
of estimate how many years of life you
have left by
um you know that that Q dot bio or into
Chrome or you take all these analyzes on
on somebody right one of the best
longevity biomarkers could be
um just your face right you image the
face and you can sort of tell oh
somebody looks like they've aged oh
someone looks younger et cetera Etc and
um this is actually data that you've got
on millions and millions of people where
you could probably start having AI
predict okay what is somebody's life
expectancy given their current face and
other kinds of things right because you
have their name your birthday you have
their you know did they passed away if
they've already they've already passed
away right and you have photos of them
through their life right so just Imaging
might give a reasonably good longevity
biomarker but then you can supplement
that with a lot of other variables
and now you can start benchmarking every
treatment by its change and how much
time you have left if that treatment
that intervention
boosts your estimated life expectancy by
five years
you can see that in the data you can get
feedback on whether your longevity is
being boosted or not okay
and so what this does is just
fundamentally changes the assumptions of
the system now with that said
uh you know life extension may be the
kind of thing I'm not sure if it'll work
for Our Generation we may be too late it
may work for the next Generation
wouldn't that make you sad
well I've got something to the last
generation could be but I've got
something for you which is uh I call it
genomic reincarnation
okay this one you probably haven't heard
before I've tweeted about it okay so by
the way good uh
uh time to mention that your Twitter is
one of the greatest twitters of all time
so people should follow you well Lex
Friedman has won the greatest podcasts
of all time you guys should listen to
The Lex Friedman podcast which you may
be doing right which you may be doing
right now yes yeah uh well thank you so
uh what was the term again sorry genomic
uh sir I call it genomic not
Resurrection but genomic reincarnation
okay so here's the concept you may be
aware that you can synthesize strands of
DNA okay
um there's sequencing of DNA which is
reading it and synthesizing DNA which is
like creating strands of DNA
uh what's interesting is you can
actually also do that at the full uh
chromosome level for bacterial
chromosomes remember that thing I was
saying earlier about the minimum life
form you know that Craig Venter made so
people have synthesized like entire
bacterial chromosomes and they work like
they can literally essentially print out
a living organism all right now when you
go uh from bacteria to eukaryotes which
are the the
kingdom of life that we're part of right
yeast are part of this Kingdom and so on
it becomes harder because the
chromosomes are more complicated
but folks are working on eukaryotic
chromosome synthesis and if you spot me
that sci-fi assumption that eventually
we'll be able to take your genome
sequence and just like we can synthesize
a bacterial chromosome we can synthesize
not just one eukaryotic chromosome but
your entire complement of chromosomes in
the lab right because you have you know
23 and you know 46 whatever you take the
pairs what you can do is potentially
print somebody out from disk
reincarnate them
insofar if your sequence determines you
and you can argue with this epigenetics
and our stuff okay but let's just say to
first order your DNA sequence is Lex you
can sequence that okay you can do full
genome sequencing and log that to a file
then here's the you know the karma part
your crypto community
where you've built up enough Karma among
them
if when you die your karma balance is
high enough
they will spend the money
to reincarnate the next Lex who can then
watch the everything that happened in
your past life
and you can tell them something
I described there I mean if you spot me
eukaryotic chromosome synthesis
that's the only part that like you know
I think I think will be possible Right
folks are working on it I'm sure there's
someone multiple messages you'd be such
a clone it's like a clone right but it
is
um it is you in a different time
you're in a different time but you don't
unfortunately have the memories well you
could probably watch the like the digest
of your life
and it would be pretty interesting right
I mean yeah the the you know that's
actually a process for psychology to
study if you create a blank mind what
would you need to show that mind to
align it very well
with the experiences with the
fundamental experiences that Define the
original version such that the resulting
clone would have similar Behavior
patterns worldviews perspectives
feelings all those kinds of things
potentially right including sadly enough
traumas and all that or what have you
right but basically just like in a very
simple version of it you know by the
time one is age 20 or 30 or something
tell me your 20s you'll sort of learn
your own personal operating system
you're like oh
alcohol really doesn't agree with me or
something like that you just by trial
and error you know things that are
idiosyncratic to your own physiology
you're like oh you know I I'm totally
wrecked if I uh get seven hours of sleep
versus nine hours or whatever it is
right you people will have different
kinds of you know things like this that
manual can be given to your next self so
you can know don't do this do this don't
do this do this right to some extent
personal genomics already gives you some
of this where you're like oh I'm a
caffeine nun you know or a slow
metabolizer oh that explains X or Y you
know or I have a weird version of
alcohol dehydrogenous oh okay that
explains you know my alcohol tolerance
so you know this is part of the broader
category of what I call practical
Miracles right so it's longevity it's
genomic reincarnation it is restoring
sight and it is curing deafness with you
know the uh you know artificial eyes and
artificial ears it is
um the super soldier serum did I show
you that so like myostatin null a tweet
about this basically X-Men or real so
here is a study from any gym from
several years ago okay uh what is this
is like the mid-2000s
this was in
2004 okay so it's now 17 years later
it's probably this is almost certainly a
teenager by now so this kid
basically was just
totally built
yeah okay extraordinarily most like very
muscular at a at a very young age yes so
the child's birth rate was in the 75th
percentile he appeared extraordinarily
muscular with protruding muscles in his
thighs motor and mental development has
been normal now at four and a half years
of agency continues to have increased
muscle ball constraint and so
essentially myostatic mutation
associated with gross muscle hypertrophy
in a child so this is like real life
X-Men okay and um it has pictures of
animals
yes this is coming called variant bio
that is looking at people who have
exceptional health related traits and it
is looking for essentially this kind of
thing but maybe more disease or or
whatever related right for example
people who have natural immunity to
covid understanding how that works
perhaps we can give Elder people
artificial immunity to covet right
um if you scroll up you see my kind of
tweet super soldier Serum is real where
it's like wild-type mouse and a
myostatin null
and look at the chest on that thing you
see the before and after wow okay this
is what's possible you know this could
be us but you regulating
you know right you're not saying like
this could be SP play this could be us
but the FDA regulating right all this
okay oh yeah on steroids but it's not
that's the thing it's not still it's
well that's the thing is people when
people again you go back to the Icarus
thing they think oh steroids well that's
definitely going to give you cancer
screw up your hormones etc etc and it
could but you know what like have we
actually put in that much effort into
figuring out like the the right way of
doing testosterone supplementation or
the right way of doing this uh obviously
we managed to put a lot of effort into
marijuana increasing the potency of it
or what have you could we put the effort
into these kinds of drugs right or these
kinds of compounds Maybe
I think that would actually be a really
good thing the thing about this is I
feel this is just a massively
underexplored area
um rather than people drinking caffeine
all the time that's like a very mild
enhancing drug okay uh nicotine is also
arguably kind of like that you know some
people have it even without the
cigarettes right
why can't we research this stuff one way
of thinking about it is you know Lancer
Armstrong the the cyclist
yes he violated all the rules
um you know he shouldn't have won the
Tour de France or anything like that
but as chemists and I say this somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but also you know his
chemists are candidates for like the
Nobel Prize in chemistry
because they brought a man back from
like testicular cancer
to like winning Tour de France's against
a bunch of guys who probably you know a
bunch of them are also Juiced or
whatever right
whatever it was done there take it out
of the competition framework there's a
lot of testicular cancer patients or
cancer patients period who would want
some of that
and we should take that seriously we
should take that Pursuit really really
really seriously Yes except again just
like the thermo stuff all this
pathologized oh it's a balico scandal oh
it says oh my God you know and yes of
course within the context of that game
they're cheating when the context of
life you want to be cheating death yes
right so
um it's just a kind of a reframe on what
is good right and it is just taking away
these assumptions at mild inflation is
good or mild death is good and going
towards Transcendence so that gets me
done with the giant FDA biomedical etc
etc longevity yeah that's beautifully
beautifully done you have you had two
questions one was on Trump and d
platforming and the other was on crypto
in the state of crypto and the third is
on India which one should we do all
right since we talked about how to fix
government we talked about how to fix
Health Medicine FDA
longevity
let us briefly talk about how to fix
social media perhaps sure since we kind
of talked about it from different
directions but it'd be nice to just look
at social media and if it could perhaps
first as an example maybe it's not a
useful example but to me it was one that
kind of shook me a little bit uh is the
removal of trump
and since then other major figures but
Donald Trump was probably the biggest
person ever to be removed from social
media do you understand why that was
done can you still man the case for it
and against it and if there's something
broken about that how do we fix it Steel
Man the case four is kind of obvious in
the sense of
um you are seeing a would-be dictator
who is trying to run a coup against
democracy who has his
um supporters go and storming the seat
of government who could use his app to
whip up his followers across the country
to reject
um you know the will of the people and
uh so you're an executive and you know
you'll take actions that while perhaps
controversial are still within the law
and you'll make sure that you do your
part to defend democracy by making sure
that at least this guy's megaphone is
taken away and that his supporters
cannot organize more rights right that's
basically the case you know for the
de-platforming okay
um would you agree with that that's like
really steel Manning it you asked the
steel man so I'm giving the four case
yeah well I think is I guess I would
like to separate
The would-be Dictator
oh I guess if you're storming the
capital you are a dictator I I see I see
um so those are two are interlinked
right you have to have somehow a
personal Judgment of the person bad
enough to be worth this
you know significant step yeah it's not
just their actions or words in a
particular situation but broadly this
person did everything that led up to
this moment and so got it right yeah so
that's that's a four case right now the
against case there's actually several
against cases right there's obviously
the Trump supporters you know against
case there is the
um sort of the libertarian slash
um left libertarian you know against
Case and there is the uh rest of world
against Case okay there's actually three
because it's not just two factions
there's multiple right so what is the
Trump supporter against case there's an
article called The Secret bipartisan
campaign that saved the 2020 election
right which came out um a few weeks
after uh the inauguration like February
4 2021 and essentially uh the Trump
supporter would read this as basically
saying uh in the name of Defending
democracy the corrupted democracy
um you know whether it was actually vote
counts or just changes of all the rules
for mail-in ballots and stuff there were
regular meetings between the Chamber of
Commerce and you know AFL or and the
unions in particular they admit that the
BLM Riots of you know the mid-2020s were
actually on a string and they could say
stand down right so that's actually
that's a quote from this article where
it's like the word went out Stand Down
protect the results announced that it
would not be activating the entire
National mobilization Network today
remains ready to activate if necessary
code hoser credits activists for their
restraint so basically the activists
rearranted the protected results protest
towards a weekend of Celebration
so point being that the fact that the
Trump supporter would say the fact that
they could tell them to stand down meant
that the previous you know unrest was in
part you know coordinated and so say
okay so that makes it illegitimate in a
different way right plus you know was
one Riot on Jan 6 versus the attacks on
the White House and stuff you know the
storming the White House in mid 2020 and
uh didn't actually stormed the White
House but they're setting fires outside
and it's quite quite a lot of stuff
right
so the second against Case is the let's
say libertarian left libertarian who'd
say
um do we really want uh giant
corporations regardless of what you
think about Trump and you don't have to
be a trump supporter do you really want
giant corporations to be determining who
can say what on the internet and if they
can de-platform a sitting president and
the quote most powerful man in the world
he's not the most powerful man in the
world in fact
um the quote people are electing a
figurehead and actually it's the heads
of network that are more powerful in the
heads of state
right that the fact that the CEOs of
Facebook and Twitter and Google and
apple and Amazon all made those
decisions at the same time to not just
de-platform Trump from Twitter which
literally billions of people around the
world saw but also censor or stop on
Facebook and to have Google and apple
pull parlor out of the App Store and
Amazon shut down the back end that would
be corporate collusion By Any Other Name
it's actually very similar to the
so-called business plot against FDR FDR
was
a complicated figure who can in some
ways best be thought of as the least bad
communist dictator or socialist dictator
of the 20th century why because he
nationalized the economy repealed the
10th Amendment right tried to pack the
courts he you know sicked the government
on all of his enemies from Huey Long to
Andrew Mellon obviously he interned the
Japanese which shows that wasn't really
totally a good guy right we don't
usually think about the same guy who did
this did that earlier in his life most
people don't know this when he led a
whole Navy thing to entrap gay Sailors
and did you know about this one no yeah
Google FDR entrapment of gay Sailors
basically he got young men to try to
find folks within the Navy who were gay
and then
um basically entrap them so that they
could be prosecuted and what have you
right FDR did a lot of stuff but
fundamentally nationalized the economy
in and set up the alphabet soup is what
they called at the time and that's like
all these agent agencies or whatever and
in some sense he's you know like
continues like it there's there'd been a
rising trend of centralization Woodward
Wilson obviously centralized Lincoln
centralized right even actually you know
1789 was a degree of centralization over
the more you know like loose thing that
was 1776 1789 so he was on that trend
line but he was definitely a huge kind
of dog leg up so the thing is that
because of all the lawsuits that were
flying many you know Forks like uh Amy
schles you know has written a book uh
the Forgotten man and essentially her
thesis and thesis of many others at that
time like John T Flynn who's this
journalist who you know was Pro FDR and
then was against was it FDR made the
Great Depression great
okay then it wouldn't have been such a
bad thing without him mucking up the
entire economy and giving it a sickness
it would have recovered quickly without
that right this is a counterfactual
which people just argue about it really
angrily back and forth and you can't
actually run the experiment unless you
could Fork the economy right just like
were the bailout's good or bad I think
they're bad but how could I prove it I
need to actually be able to Fork the
economy crypto actually allows you in
theory to do that like where folks could
actually shift balances this is a whole
separate thing where you actually start
to make macroeconomics into more of an
experimental science rather than simply
arguing from Authority You could argue
from experiment
um some of the virtual economy stuff
that Edward castroneva has done is
relevant to this we can talk about that
point is though with FDR there's a thing
because he had Bridge such a war on
Private Industry at that time and
Justified it with this narrative bold
persistent experimentation there was
something called the quote business plot
where all these captains of industry
that he'd been beating up and again
Teddy Roosevelt had also been doing this
with you know the trust Buster
um the journals at the time I'd Tarbell
had gone in you know basically ran all
these articles and Rockefeller knocked
him down Woodrow Wilson in The Skin
control but FDR the the CEOs were
thinking oh bad this is so terrible
there's a so-called business plot uh to
try to take over the government and uh
stop FDR from you know pushing the
country and what they thought was a bad
Direction Smedley Butler was a general
that they recruited to try to help them
with this but he turned on them and he
went and kind of broke the whole thing
open and told to Congress and so on and
so this guy's you know uh the the whole
plot was broken up all right now one way
of thinking about today or the you know
the whole aftermath of Jan six is it's a
business plot but in reverse because the
generals and the CEOs both were against
Trump and actually
the business plot happened and now all
the CEOs just you know they pulled all
this all the push all the buttons that
they needed to and now the network was
Prime over the state okay now why why is
that an interesting way of looking at it
because
one thing I have in the book is you can
kind of think of 1950 as like issues
Peak centralization you go forward and
backward in time things decentralize you
know for example and and you start
getting Mirror Image events that happen
with the opposite outcome for example
1890 the frontier closes 1991 the
internet Frontier opens internet becomes
open for Commerce okay you go backwards
in time you have the Spanish Flu
forwards in time covet 19. right
um backwards in time you have the uh
captains of industry the robber barons
fours in time you have the tech
billionaires and there's so many
examples of this like another one is
um backwards in time the New York Times
is allying with Soviet Russia to choke
out Ukraine now today they have
reinvented themselves as cheerleaders
for Ukraine against you know nationalist
Russia right and of course I think you
could absolutely support Ukraine on
other measures but it's pretty
hypocritical for the guys who profited
from the hull de more you know the ox
ellisburg family literally profited from
you know knowing to hold more to now
make themselves cheerleaders for
Ukrainian sex with this insane thing
which we can talk about a tiny tangent
on the yeah you put it brilliantly and a
reminder for anyone who listens to me
talk about Ukraine it is possible to
have empathy for a nation and not be
part of the machine that generates a
mainstream narrative yes that's right
like basically you know I I was actually
one of the first three Estonian ee
residents okay and I completely
understand why Estonia and the baltics
and all these countries including
Ukraine that just recently within living
memory got their independence from the
Soviet Empire would not want to be
forcibly reintegrated
into a place that they just escaped from
you know and so that is something which
is sort of outside the American left
right you know tired kind of thing where
when you understand from that point of
view right then there's like a fourth
point of view which is like India's
point of view or like much of the
developing world or what I call you know
parts of it are you know ascending parts
or descending whatever but much of the
rest of the world outside of that border
region says look uh we're sympathetic to
the ukrainians but we can't allow our
people to starve so we're gonna maintain
trade and guess what actually you know
we've got a lot of wars in our neck of
the woods and human rights crises that
Europe just didn't even care about so it
can't be that Europe's problems are the
world's problems but the world's
problems are not Europe's problems right
so that's like a fourth point of view
then a fifth point of view is China
which is like guess what we're going to
be the Iran of the Iraq War you know
where like who won the Iraq War Iran
arguably extended their influence into
Iraq right so China's like guess what
we're going to turn Russia into our gas
station and build a pipeline they're
building there's a power Siberia is like
the name of the Eastern Russia your
pipeline just like nordstream is you
know Nordstrom one and North stream too
I think they're building a new pipeline
you know through Mongolia so Xi Jinping
and Putin and the Mongolian head of
state were all photographed kind of
thumbs upping this pipeline we'll see if
it goes through but it's ironic that you
know Russia wanted
to make Ukraine their you know Colony
but the outcome of this war may be that
Russia becomes China's Colony you know
so that's at least like five different
perspectives right there's like the U.S
establishment perspective there's the
you know Tucker Maga perspective there's
the baltics and Ukrainian perspective
there's like the Indian and like poor
countries perspective and there's a
chain Spectrum then of course there's
the Russians right so
um just respect to that by the way
that's another example of History
happening in Reverse this is the sign of
Soviet partnership except this time
China is a senior partner and Russia is
a junior partner and this time they're
both nationalists rather than communist
and there's so many flips like this and
you know there's I'm going to list a few
more actually because there's so so so
many of them do you have an explanation
of why that happens yes let me list a
few of them this is in the network State
book it's in the chapter called
fragmentation Frontier fourth turning
Futures our past right so I give this
example of like a fluid unmixing all
right just watch this for a second right
this is from Smart every day on mixing
color machine Ultra lamina reversible
flow smart every day 217. and so you can
mix something and then like this thing
that you don't think of as reversible
you can unmix it which is insane right
that it works okay the physics of that
situation it just works right so uh for
people just listening that there is
whatever the mixture this is all this is
ultra laminar reversible flow so this
probably has to do something to do with
the material
we're used to mixing not being a
reversible process exactly that's what
that shows and then he he then reverses
the mixing and table to do it perfectly
that's right so that's like the Futures
are past these it shows that Free Will
is an illusion just kidding okay well
basically there's there's you know some
environments where you know the
equations are like time symmetrical so
you can right
um and this is one model sort of it's an
interesting visual model for what's
happening in the world as we
redecentralize after the centralized
entry right so
um basically you know I mentioned the
internet Frontier over opens back in the
Western frontier closed today we
experienced covid-19 back then we
experienced a Spanish Flu Tech
billionaires and the other Captain
street right today Founders like Elon
and Dorsey
are starting to win against
establishment journalists back then Ida
Tarbell demagogued and defeated
Rockefeller I think net net Founders win
this time versus the journals back then
the journalist won over the founders
okay
um today we have cryptocurrencies back
then we had private banking today this
is an amazing one we have a populist
movement movement of digital gold
advocates
back then because Bitcoin maximalists
and so on where gold has become populist
because it's against the printing money
and so and so forth back then we had a
populist movement against gold in the
form of William Jennings Bryan in the
cross of gold speech gold was considered
a tool of big business now gold is the
tool against big business and big
government right uh digital gold yeah
digital gold right
say we have the inflation and cultural
conflict of Weimar like America back
then we had the inflation and cultural
conflict of Weimar Germany
America we have Ryan left fighting in
the streets same unfortunately in Weimar
Germany Peter church has written about
you know today we have what turchan
considers Antebellum like polarization
like preborn polarization back then you
know if you go further back time we had
what we now know to be Antebellum
pearlization right okay we have Airbnb
back then we had flop houses today we
have Uber back then we had Gypsy cabs
um you know so today we see the
transition from neutral to yellow
journalism back then we saw the
transition from yellow to neutral
journalism right
um and you know today figures like Mike
Moritz you know wrote about China's
energetic and America's laconic but back
then Bertrand Russell actually wrote
this whole long book actually you know
the mathematician brother and Russell
right wrote this whole long book which I
didn't even realize he wrote about these
kind of topics
um about uh the problem of China and one
of his observations was uh you know
again this I'm not saying this is I'm
just saying he made this observation he
was saying that America was energetic
and China laconic at the time because
everybody was in opium dens and and so
on and so forth okay more examples the
one I just mentioned where the Chinese
and Russians are again lining up against
the West except this time the Chinese
are the senior partner relationship
rather than Junior partner today I think
in the second Cold War there will also
be a third world but this time I think
that third world might come in first
because it's not the non-aligned
movement it's the Align movement around
web 3 protocols
that's fascinating yeah that's what
India comes in by the way it's something
we haven't mentioned Africa that there
could be very interesting things in
Africa as well Nigeria is actually
Nigeria says First Tech unicorn
um and I'm investing there I've uh and I
think you know it's one of these things
where China's risen India is like about
10 years behind uh you know China but I
think this is uh the Indian decade in
many ways we can come back to that point
um but there's absolutely you know
Sparks of light in Africa I mean it's a
huge continent it almost like the more
behind side to interrupt the more behind
you are
the more opportunity you have to leap
for all sometimes that's right and pays
a is a classic example where they did
this in in East Africa but uh but I
think there's more possibility there
um so what is uh the fact this uh
there's a kind of symmetry there's a
history right what is that um how do how
did that take us from uh um
Trump the the the different perspective
you took the libertarian perspective of
uh it doesn't really matter yeah because
the libertarian perspective or the left
left libertarian perspective would say
is it really a good idea to have
total corporate power against the quote
elected government even if you know you
may disagree do you want to open the
door to Total you know corporate
oligarchy and it's like the opposite
that's why I mentioned it's like the
opposite of business plots and they
pulled on that thread Okay so
um the the macro explanation that I have
for this future is our past thesis and
there's more it also gives some
predictions right if you go backwards in
time the U.S federalizes into many
individual states like before the Civil
War people said the United States are
and after they said the United States is
before FDR the 10th Amendment reserved
rights to the states afterwards it was
just Federal Regulation of everything
as we go forwards in time you're seeing
States break away from the feds on gun
laws drug laws right Sanctuary cities
okay
um many other kinds of things you know
and now Florida for example has its own
guard that's like not uh a National
Guard but like a state guard other other
cities uh other states are doing this
and that's the force of decentralization
is saying that parallels yes in Reverse
in Reverse right so you're having before
make America States again
nice okay that's what's I think
happening right but I'm not saying I
well I think there's aspects of that
that are good there's aspects that are
bad but
um just like that's kind of the the
angle right
but then that's I mean from your
perspective that's probably not enough
right that's that's not um it's part of
the Future Let's just say whether I
think you said something trouble you
suggested all kinds of ways to build
different countries I think that's
probably one of them you said like start
micro micro countries or something like
this I forgot the terminology yeah
micronations yeah I actually think of
them as is better term as microstates
because they're actually not Nations
that's why they don't work but
microstates are better right uh coming
back to the difference between the
nation the state the nation is like
the nation state is a term that people
use without expanding it but Nation
comes from the same root word as like
natality so it's like common descent
common birth right common origin like
the Japanese Nation that's a group of
people that have you know come down from
history right hence nationalism yeah
whereas the state is like the
administrative layer above them it's
like labor and capital like labor and
management okay the American state stood
over the Japanese nation in 1946 after
the war right oh so you weren't talking
about traditionally you know that that
doesn't matter
like I thought you meant nation is a
thing that carries across the
generations that there's a tradition
there's a culture and so on and state is
just the management the uh the layer I
mean that's also that's also another way
of thinking about it right there's a
reversal there as well okay yeah so so I
mean one way of thinking about it is
um you know one nation under God
indivisible is no longer true it is
America is at least two Nations the
Democrat and Republican in the sense of
their own cultures where I can show you
graph after graph you've seen the
polarization graphs I can show you
Network diagrams where you know like
there's this graph of polarization in
Congress where there's red and blue
they're separate things there's this
article from 2017 showing
um how uh you know shares on Facebook
and Twitter are just separate sub graphs
they're just separate graphs in The
Social Network and they're pulling apart
those are two Nations uh they're not
under God because people in the US no
longer believe in God and they're very
much divisible because
uh 96 of Democrats won't marry
Republicans in a high percentage other
way and in one gen what that means is in
one generation ideology becomes biology
these become ethnic groups it takes on
the character of hudu and Tootsie or
Protestant and Catholic SUNY and Shiite
it's not about ideology if you think
about old flips during covid right where
people were on one side where cells are
said it's Tribal it's just tribe on
tribe and so it's not Universalist that
identity of American makes less sense
than the identity of Democrat and
Republican right now or perhaps they
didn't evangelial states where I think
that's a good or bad thing I think
that's unfortunately you know whatever
it is the hour of History right on the
opposite side of things India is
actually was 562 princely States at the
time of Indian unification
um in 19 from 1947 to 19 1947 when they
got independence from the British it was
562 princely States most people don't
know their part and got your outside and
you don't know the part it got unified
into a republic only by like 1950. and
India is like actually a modern create
India is like Europe it's kind of like
the European Union in the sense that we
didn't have a unified India in the past
it was something a lot of different
countries like
Northern South India or like Gujarat and
Tamil Nadu are as different as
Finland and Spain okay but India has
moved in the direction of much more
unification like much more you know
um centralization or what have you
whereas the US is decentralizing you go
okay
a few more things there are Flips and
I'll finish this off today we're seeing
the rise of the pseudonymous founder and
startup societies back all the way back
in the 1770s we saw pseudonymous
founders of startup countries namely the
US right Federalist Papers
um today we're seeing so far
unsuccessful calls for wealth seizures
in the U.S back then we saw FDR's
executive order 6102 which was a
successful seizure of gold I expect we
may see something like that an attempted
seizure of digital gold and I think
that'll be one of the things that
individual states like Florida or Texas
may not enforce that and I think that's
actually the kind of thing where you
could see you know like a breakup
potential in the future right one other
thing that kind of Rhymes is in many
ways like the modern U.S establishment
the story that you hear is the victories
in 1945 and 1865 legitimate the current
establishment that is being the Nazis
being the Confederates right so you beat
the ethnic nationalists abroad and they
beat the quote secessionist at home
right and uh the ethnic nationalists
were you know Aryan Nazis and the
secessionists were you know slave slave
owners and against freedom and so on and
so forth okay I'm not disputing that I'm
just saying that that's just like
they're the way people think about it
there's a possibility and I'm not saying
it's 100 at all okay but if you're a
Sci-Fi writer
there's a possibility that the U.S loses
to the ethnic nationalists abroad except
this time they're Chinese Communists
non-white Communists as opposed to Aryan
Nazis which seemed like the total
opposite okay
and uh there's a possibility that there
is a
um Financial secession at home where
it's you know Bitcoin maximalist states
that are advocating for Freedom the
opposite of slavery
see what I'm saying
oh boy that's dark you're uh you're
looking for major things in history that
don't yet have a cognate going forward
right and that's a nice way to think
about
the future it is only one model and you
know any mental model or something like
that that's why I say as a Sci-Fi
scenario it's like a scenario one could
contemplate right where the new version
has I mean the Chinese Communists do not
think of themselves as Aryans right
um but they are alternationalist and you
know the Hitler comparisons people talk
about Hitler endlessly you know like
Saddam is a new Hitler everybody's a new
Hitler et cetera
if there is a comparison to quote Nazi
Germany it is
you know CCP China in a sense why they
are non-english speaking manufacturing
Powerhouse with a massive military build
out under one leader that is a genuine
peer competitor to the US on many
dimensions and in fact you know
exceeding on some dimensions of
technology and science right that is
like the problem is it's a boy who cried
wolf people say this a zillion times
right
um and you know that is like uh you know
I'm not saying this by the way crucially
I am there's like I think China is
uh very complicated and there's hundreds
of millions of people probably half in
China that disagrees with the current
alternationalist kind of thing right and
so I kind of hate it when
innocent Chinese people abroad or
whatever are just like attacked on this
basis or what have you plus the other
thing is that many times people say well
look relative to you know where we were
when uh Deng took over in 1978 we built
up the entire country we're not starving
to death anymore and the West wants to
recolonize us and so understand where
that's coming from this way you want to
be able to argue different points of
view with that said
there's one huge difference right which
is Nazi Germany was like 70 million
people
and the US was 150 million and the
Soviet Union was 150 million and the UK
was like 50 million so they were
outnumbered like five to one
China outnumbers the U.S
four to one this is going to be a fun
Century things are going to be under
this model under this model things are
going to be potentially crazy plus you
know people are like oh I think this is
uh you know again I have nothing
personal you know there's a guy Peter
Zion he writes these books right
I probably agree about 20 or 30 but I
disagree with a lot of the rest and a
bunch of it is basically about
how China is really weak and America is
really strong and the rest of the world
is screwed and
um you know I think there's absolutely
problems in China and uh you know like
the current management is actually
messing a lot of things up we could talk
about that
but I do think that
you know the US is like fighting its
Factory
so one thing you know Zion will talk
about is how oh America has this Blue
Water Navy all the aircraft carriers and
China has nothing it's got books Etc
well China ships things all around the
world
right it probably has you know one of
the most active fleets out there in
terms of you know it's commercial
shipping
um and uh in terms of building ships
here's a quote China's Merchant
shipbuilding industry is the world's
largest building more than 23 million
gross tons of shipping in 2020. U.S
yards built a mere 70 000 tons the same
year though they typically average
somewhere in the 200 thousands that is a
100 to 300X ratio just in shipbuilding
pretty much everything else you can find
in the physical world is like that okay
we're not talking like 2x we're talking
they can put together a subway station
in nine hours with with prefab and the
US takes three years okay
when you have a thousand X difference in
the physical world
the reason the US was won against you
know Nazi Germany in a serious fight is
they had this giant manufacturing plant
that was overseas and they just out
produced right and they supplied the
Soviets also with lendlies and the
Soviets talked about how they would not
have won the war without the Americans
people are like oh the Russians you know
fought the Germans the Russians armed by
Americans fought the Germans like it's a
Soviet Union they're not actually able
to make high quality stuff there
obviously are individual people in
Soviet Russia who were Innovative right
I'm not taking that away there's a
there's a tradition of amazing I just
want to be like
um there's individual Russians who
obviously I admire Mendeleev and uh you
know clamor Grove and and so on there's
amazing Russian scientists engineers so
I'm not saying that I mean in general
from from uh yourself that criticized
communism is too easy to say
nothing communism produces is good which
of course is not true yes a lot of
brilliant people in in a lot of even you
know there's a lot of amazing things
have been created yeah so they had some
amazing mathematicians amazing
scientists and so on right however great
branding on the you know red and the
yellows yeah yeah so branding is Stellar
so Nazi Germany to excellent branding
with the flag and so on you know so
the tongues and ends there in terms of
compliments yeah well actually they
copied a lot of stuff from each other
you know like there's this movie called
the Soviet story it basically shows a
lot of Nazi and Soviet propaganda things
next to each other and you can see guys
almost in like the same pose it's almost
like uh you know how AI will do like
style transfer you can almost see
because the Socialist realism style of
like the muscular brawny worker very
similar to like the style of the Aryan
Superman you know like pointing at the
Vermin or whatever and then there's the
crappy open source version that tries to
copy which is Mussolini yeah that's just
like that does the same exact thing but
does it kind of shittier so right anyway
so my main thing about this is basically
like trying to fight your factory in the
physical world is probably not going to
work people are I think overconfident on
this stuff right with that said I think
we want to at all you know the future is
not yet determined right at All Odds you
know we want to avoid a hot war between
like I mean a hop war between the US and
China would would be
do you think it's possible that we get a
war we're doing these things like Pelosi
going to Taiwan and trying to trying to
cause something like look again this is
one of these things which is complicated
because obviously if you're there's more
than one perspective on this right again
you've got the U.S establishment the U.S
conservative the Taiwanese perspective
the Chinese perspective all the
bystanders over there there's more than
one perspective on this okay if you're
you know China's one of China's many
neighbors
you look at China with apprehension like
Vietnam for example has sort of fallen
into uh or not fallen into is partnering
with India because they're mutually
apprehensive China China is not making
like great friends with its neighbors
it's kind of you know it's demonizing
Japan it's it's so ultra-nationalist
nowadays
um and so if you're Taiwanese you're
like uh yeah I do not want to be under
the Chinese surveillance State I
completely understand that some people
are pro-reunification others aren't but
there's more you know Trend you know um
in some ways for for Independence okay
fine
but there's also an increasing
temperature across the entire world as
we sit here today there's speeches by
Vladimir Putin about the serious
possibility of a nuclear war
and that escalates kind of
the heat in the room of geopolitics it
escalates the human room of course right
and the thing is people have this belief
that because something hasn't happened
it won't happen or it can't happen but
like there were a lot of measures people
took during the Cold War
to
make sure our nuclear exchange didn't
happen the whole mutually assured
destruction thing and communicating that
out and like the balance of Terror there
were smart guys on both sides who
thought through this and there were near
near misses right there you know like
there's that story about like the Soviet
Colonel who didn't order a nuclear
strike because he thought it was just
like an error in the instruments right
okay what's the point point is
you know for example Pelosi going to
Taiwan that didn't strengthen Taiwan
they didn't like that if if you're gonna
go and provoke China I thought scholar
stage as a Twitter account had a good
point which is you should if you're
actually gonna do it then you strengthen
Taiwan with like huge battalions of like
arms material and you make them a
porcupine and so on and so forth instead
her kind of going and Landing there and
mooning China and then flying back in
the middle of a hot war with Russia
that's absolutely you know in the middle
of an economic crisis or it just it just
okay you know can you can pick battles
or whatever right it's like you don't
have to fight Russia and China at the
same time
it's like kind of insane to do that okay
plus even with Ukraine
um some people were like oh this was
like a a victory for the U.S military
policy or something there's a guy who
I'm not trying to beat him up or
anything he's like this is in March
threat on U.S security assistance to
Ukraine it's working Ukraine might be
one of the biggest successes of U.S
security assistance and the reason is
you know U.S didn't focus on some
high-end shiny objects but on core
military tasks that focus should remain
and it's like
how is this a success the West gave
massive arms to Ukraine only after the
invasion but not enough before to deter
and now Ukraine is like this syria-like
Battleground with you know a million
refugees or whatever the number is right
the country is blown to Smithereens
thousands of people dead whatever
thousand dollar gas in in Europe with
like 10x energy radicalized Russians the
threat of World War III or even nuclear
war you know shooting somebody
isn't that's not like the point of a
military the point is you know there's a
million ways to smash Humpty Dumpty into
pieces and you know unleash the blood
drench Tides right and have people all
shooting each other and killing each
other it's really hard to maintain
stability that's what competence is
deterrence and stability right there's
not like a success in any way
um this is like an absolute tragedy for
everybody involved right yeah I mean
deterrence of course is the the number
one thing but the you know there's a lot
to be said there
um but I'm a huge not fan of declaring
Victory as we've done many times when
it's the wrong yeah I mean look I mean
the other thing about this is the whole
mission accomplished thing during this
[ __ ] accomplishes what I meant yeah
exactly mission accomplished was
obviously you know the thing is
Russia lives next door to Ukraine and so
I mean just like Iraq lives next door to
Iran and Afghanistan is next to Pakistan
and China and so if the U.S eventually
gets tired of it and leaves those guys
are next door right and so you know who
knows what's going to happen here okay
um but one of the problems is like you
know the whole Afghanistan thing or the
Iraq thing is the lesson for people was
the uncertainty they're like is the US
going to fight don't know is will the US
winifit fights don't know therefore roll
the dice that uncertainty is itself like
tempting to folks you know like like
pewter right so point is coming all the
way back up we were talking about how
history Futures are passed and FDR like
the business plot the FDR failed but
like the tech companies were able to
de-platform Trump right and the left
libertarian would say do we want that
much corporate power okay and so that's
so we gave the forecast for Trump to
platforming protecting democracy the
Trump supporter case against which is on
the secret history of the Shadow
campaign the state of the 2020 election
that article the left libertarian or
libertarian case against and then to me
what is uh you know like I am more
sympathetic to
the libertarian slash left libertarian
against and then also maybe the fourth
group which is the non-american case
right which is to say
every you know you know you know amlo
he's the uh he was a you know head of
state of Mexico I think at that time
okay
um amlo macron you know other folks
everybody who's watching this around the
world basically saw
let's say U.S establishment or democrat
aligned folks just decapitate you know
the head of state from digitally right
like just boom gone okay and they're
like well if they can do that in public
to the US president who's ostensibly the
most powerful man in the world
what is the Mexican president stand
against that
nothing right like these U.S media
corporations use tech companies are so
insanely powerful everybody's on Twitter
or what have you other than China
leaving them aside they've got their own
root system if somebody tried to
de-platform decision ping off of Sino
weibo they'd probably just fall through
a trap tour you know their whole family
right but for the rest of the world it's
on the that that is hosting their
business their Politics on these U.S
tech companies they're like
regardless of whether it was Justified
on this guy that means they will do it
to anybody now the seal is broken just
like the bailouts as exceptional as they
were in the first everybody was shocked
about them then they became a policy
instrument and now there's bailouts
happening every single bill is printing
another whatever billion dollars or
something like that right you can ask on
your thoughts and advice on this topic
um if if I or anyone were to have a
conversation with Donald Trump
first of all should one do so
and uh if so how do you do it and it may
not necessarily be trump it could be
other people like Putin and Xi Jinping
and so on let's say people that are
censored right like people that
Platforms in general see as dangerous
Hitler you can go uh we keep bringing it
up of course that's the Ultimate Edge
case right um in the sense of is that
saying like something must be done this
is something they're for this must be
done right
I've heard that one before
no but I love it so this is just can I
just use that as an explanation with
confidence for everything I do yeah sure
there you go right something must be
done this is something therefore must be
done therefore this must be done so that
is the like the two all kinds of
regulations all kinds of things are kind
of Justified in that basis right there's
a version of that which is uh punchinati
I decide who's a Nazi you're a Nazi
therefore I I punch you and that's
Justified yeah yeah and you know like
people say oh uh how many people are
calling Israelis you know like these
these things right
um and so
the problem with argumentum ad hilarum
is it just I mean people will say
Obama's a Nazi everybody say everybody's
a Nazi right but there is a social
consensus about who let's let's set
Nazis aside but who's dangerous for
society okay but now let's talk about
that all right so basically I think a
more interesting example than Hitler in
in this context is Herbert Matthews so
Fidel Castro before he became the
Communist dictator of Cuba was on the
Run he was like Osama Bin Laden at the
time he's like a terrorist that the
Cuban regime had seemingly defeated and
what Herbert Matthews did is he got an
intro to him he went to the you know
place where he was hiding out he gave an
interview and he printed this
hagiography in the New York Times with
this like you know photo of Castro
looking all you know Mighty and so on
and he's like Castro is still alive and
still fighting okay and uh there's this
book on this called the man who created
Fidel okay where basically nyt's article
was crucial positive press that got
Castro's point of view out to the world
and helped lead to the Communist
Revolution that actually impoverished
Cuba led to like gay people being you
know like uh discriminated against there
led to people fleeing you know and
drowning trying to escape right that's
an example of where platforming somebody
led to a very bad outcome in fact
many of the Communist dictators in the
20th century had like their own personal
journalist right for example there's a
guy John Reed he's an American he's
buried uh you know if I get this right I
think he's buried at the Kremlin wall
okay
um why is an American
buried there okay
um because he wrote a book called 10
days that shook the world that
whitewashed the entire Soviet Revolution
and uh the you know the Russian
Revolution in 1917 October Revolution
and made these guys out to be the good
guys when they were actually genocidal
Psychopaths okay he got their point of
view out of the world and it was a
totally misleading point of view all
right do you think what do you think he
was thinking
he's like he saw the psychopathy you
know sometimes it's not obvious like
well the French Revolution had already
happened so people kind of knew that
this sort of Psychopathic you know
Killing In The Name of equality could
produce bad results right and uh but but
it's more than that right so it's John
Reed it's Herbert Matthews it's um Edgar
snow okay so these are all people who
should be extremely famous right
um so Edgar snow is Mao's journalist
okay so he wrote
um you know here's a there's actually a
article in this how 1930s reporter from
Missouri became China's ideal ideal
journalist okay and he wrote various
books including like red star over China
okay and it's just a geography of of Mal
right yeah and uh then of course you've
got Durante he is like Stalin's
biographer right just to recap John Reed
brought Lennon's message to the world
mail instead
Durante helped Stalin starve out the
ukrainians Maryland's Dead uh Edgar snow
uh was Mao's biographer
um and uh Herbert Matthews was like
Castro's and this guy David David
halberstam in Vietnam who was
effectively Ho Chi minh's he basically
went and uh took leaks from a communist
spy I'll give you the exact name
Farm I'm going to mispronounce this but
it's perfect spy the incredible double
life of Pham Swan on Time Magazine
reporter and Vietnamese communist agent
that guy was the source of many
fabricated Stories the David halberstam
printed in the New York Times that led
to the undermining of the South
Vietnamese regime and you know for
example stories of Buddhists being
killed and so on Ashley rinsberg in the
great lady wink writes this whole thing
up at length so you can go and read it
for his account
but basically all of these communist
dictators had a journalist right
alongside them as their biographer yeah
okay but those are those are tools of
the propaganda machine versus well so my
point is these are five examples that
are on the far left
that should be balanced also against the
times running profiles of Hitler on the
far right we know that base you know the
times actually also ran the whole thing
which was you know Hitler's like
Mountain Retreat or something like that
do you know about that story what year
was this I'll tell you one second
Hitler at home in the clouds
oh boy please tell me it's like early
30s I think it's um oh yeah this is auto
detolicious this is actually a guy that
um Ashley rinsberg writes up in the
great lady wink right 1937 37. there's
another one where I think the date is
wrong but it's 39 you know but
essentially uh these titles are like
where Hitler dreams and plans he lives
simply you know right and uh there's
another one hair Hitler at home in the
clouds okay the thing about this is
absolutely there are folks who are hit
geographers of the far right but whether
you're talking Lennon and John Reed or
uh Stalin and Walter Durante of the New
York Times or Castro and Herbert
Matthews again of the New York Times or
Edgar snow and Mao or David halberstam
and uh you know Ho Chi Minh again of the
New York Times like you start to see a
pattern here where the guys who are
being platformed and given a voice are
these guys who end up being like far
left you know lunatics right and I think
part of the issue here is you know the
thing about how Communists don't
understand self-interest nationalists
don't understand other interests
and so Nationals are more obvious
isn't that good I thought it was good
it's pretty good right pretty good so
the Nationalist is very obvious in the
sense of like they're for the Aryans
they're not even for like the Slavs or
whatever right like you know uh
basically you know had Hitler
constructed a different ideology
um you know then like he might have
gotten more support in Eastern Europe or
whatever right but he also called the
Slavs inferior not just you know
basically everybody was inferior to
darians okay except maybe the English or
whatever but that was it right
um oh and the Japanese are honorary
organs or something
so the Nationalist declares the
supremacy of their own race or culture
or what have you and doesn't understand
people's other interest but he also
pumps up his own guys okay same with you
know in some ways China today same with
Japan back in the day whereas the
Communist has a message that sounds more
appealing
it's a Universalist message ostensibly
but it's it's actually faux universalism
because it's actually particularism like
during the Soviet Union communism this
faux universalism was basically a mask
for Russian nationalism you know where
you know or at least at least Soviet
nationalism where in particular Russians
were pushed into many territories and
you know Russian speakers were you know
like privileged in you know the Eastern
Europe and and the baltics of course
Russians themselves were oppressed at
home as Sultan's rights they were both
victim and victimizer of the regime
their churches were crushed and so on as
compensation they were agents of Empire
it's a tragedy all around right I'm not
you know I think Russians have been hard
done in many ways they've had a very
hard hard Century they've also done hard
by others okay it's complicated those
journalists you mentioned just to
elaborate maybe the skill with me I
wonder what you think sure but I think
conversation like not to sort of glorify
any particular medium but there's
something one of the reasons I like
long-form podcasts or into interviews
long form unedited interviews there's
been shows throughout the 20th century
that do that kind of thing but they seem
to be rare there is that's podcast made
it much more popular in common
is it's somehow
makes it easier not to do this kind of
[ __ ] journalism that the gotcha
stuff yeah I I feel like asking
interesting and deep questions allow I
think you could sit down with Hitler in
1940 1941 1942 and the podcast actually
serve a purpose in 41 and 42 mid World
War II amid World War II a purpose of
one which is very important get good
information for the future so history
can study it and to reveal to the world
the way a man thinks that is beyond the
propaganda
so all this stuff is complicated but
today so the specific issue of the folks
you were talking about like Putin Z
Trump right for those folks they are
very clearly out group for both the U.S
left and right which is it'll say the
Western left and right which are your
um uh your audience there's folks who
are tankies and they're folks who are
Maga who are sympathetic and so what are
dankies tankies are those who are you
know unless they may call themselves
tankies let's say they're
anti-imperialists left and mega right
okay for different reasons are
um against the US establishment and for
Putin or G or something like that as you
know
um as an agent against us establishment
right so leaving those aside
the point is that most your audience is
sort of on guard vaccinated in a sense
right versus Z and Putin and Trump right
like they have they know the counter
arguments and so on and so forth okay in
which case
I wouldn't think interviewing them would
be like that big a deal relatively
because there's so much other coverage
and so on out there it's it's I think
it's probably okay however for something
like
um you know when what John Reed was
doing and so on when he was a sole
source of information about the Russian
Revolution yes right that's different
that's different right so so it's
something about it kind of gets back to
the the competitive environment and so
on there's no dearth of folks who are
writing critical coverage of these these
three men right and so if I felt that
that was insufficient then you might
need more of it right right
um just like you know for example
nowadays with Stalin there are a lot of
articles and books and PDFs and so on on
it but a good time not as much at the
time not as much right that's why I
brought those those guys right because
often it's kind of like have you have
your stock shelves at a supermarket and
so seem totally out of left field no but
shoes but the same thing Sears I used to
work with seriously the thing that is
the most popular is the thing that's not
on the Shelf because it's been sold out
yeah right so in some ways like you know
this is the this is similar to that you
know famous photo that people have or
image that people have on Twitter of the
plane and um you know the parts that are
shot versus not right the the uh
survivorship bias right and one way of
kind of thinking about it is the guys
who you think of as bad guys or possible
bad guys or controversial guys or
whatever
are those you've already got some
vaccination to do that's why you think
of them at all whereas the folks that I
mentioned The Regulators invisible you
don't right salzburger you know
Zuckerberg you know his pros and cons
you know who he is as a person you don't
even know Salzburg exists most people
right despite the fact that he's like
certainly is powerful you know he owns
the New York Times he inherits he also
got dual class talk just like Zuck
um but it's invisible right well that's
why I think studying the knowns the
people that are known can help you
generalize
uh to the way human nature is and then
you start to question are the same kind
of humans existing in places that uh
wield power and you can assume they are
they do exist there and then you can
start to infer that's right and ask
questions so this is kind of what I try
to do is I'm like what is the dark
matter what is the question that's not
being asked or what happens right and so
um you know that's not to say that you
you need to be so anti-memetic that you
only do that but I think you need to do
that as well as understand what is good
about the conventional wisdom and you
know for example if you notice a lot of
what I talk about is like the V1 V2 V3
or as critical as I am of let's say the
FDA I recognize that people want a
regulated Marketplace and how do we do
better as critical as I can be of the
FED I recognize that some kind of
monetary policy is necessary and Satoshi
came up with a better one right
um as harsh as one can be a Critic of
the current system
it is really incumbent as difficult as
it is upon one to come with a better
version just like Academia as much as I
think current science is corrupted what
I propose is a way to actually improve
on that and actually any any true
scientists say yes I want my work to be
reproducible yes I want citations to be
important statements and so on and so
forth and we don't have to get everybody
to agree with that but just enough to
build that better version and not
regress yeah there's a there's an
implied optimism within the V1 V2 V3 yes
framework let me ask you at a high level
about social media because you are one
of its
prominent users to communicate your
wisdom I use Twitter I wouldn't I don't
really think of it as quick
communicating my wisdom per se or
anything like that I use Twitter like I
might use GitHub as a scratch pad for
just kind of floating Concepts and you
know I've got okay here's a frame on
things let me kind of put it out there
and see what people think get some
feedback and so on don't you think it
has a lasting impact that the your
scratch book I think it's good but
basically like
um if I say that's what's my primary
thing on Twitter it's that it's a it's a
scratch pad for me to kind of put some
Concepts out there you know iterate on
them get feedback on them and so on and
so forth do you think it's possible that
the words you've tweeted on Twitter
is the most impact you will have
on the world on the world I don't uh so
possible is it possible
um well my tweets received me it's a
good question I I think the network
state will be I think important uh or I
hope it well the book The Book of the
concept good question the movement the
movement right uh in the sense that
Zionism shows that it is possible to
have a book and then a conference and
then a fund and eventually in the
fullness of time with a lot of time and
effort to actually get a state right and
uh you know as I mentioned earlier a lot
of countries are small countries but I
didn't mention there's a guy who's the
head of Kazakhstan and he made a remark
he's like you know if we allow every
nation that wants to have
self-determination to have a state we'd
have 600 countries rather than 190. yeah
because you know the option one of
there's many opposites of a nation-state
but one of the Opposites is the
stateless nation and she remember the
network state is popular in places like
Catalonia catalonian nationalists in
Catalonia guys are a committed
catalonian nationalists so Catalonia is
region of Spain right
um the the thing is that
again V1 V2 V3 the nation state is V2
and it beat the city-state which is like
V1
and the network State I think of as a
potential V3 which combines aspects of
V1 and V2 so Catalonia or The Basque
region these are underneath the nation
state of Spain but many catalonians
think of themselves as part of a
separate nation not all set many okay
and so they want a state of Their Own
who doesn't if you're a nation you know
meaning that they've got a they've got a
legitimate claim from history language
culture all that stuff right the basks
do as well the Kurds do as well okay
lots of ethnic groups around the world
do so in the game of musical chairs that
was the formation of current national
borders they lost out
right so what do they do well one answer
is they just submit to the Spanish state
and they just speak Spanish and their
culture is erased and their history is
erased and so on the second is they do
some sort of ireland-like Insurgency the
troubles to try to get a thing of their
own which is obviously bad for other
kinds of reasons right you know violent
Etc
what this catalonian nationalist said
he's like look well we can't give up on
our existing path the network state is a
really interesting third option I mean
by the way I hadn't talked to this guy V
partel okay and he's got this site
called via web and uh Vila Villa web
sorry it can be meaning the networks it
can be especially appealing to us
catalans are now embarking on the task
of having a normal and current state in
the old way and this is a project that
we cannot give up but this doesn't mean
that at the same time we are not also
attentive to ideas like this and we do
not try to learn and move forward right
meaning you know the network state right
because that's the Third Way which says
okay maybe this particular region
is not something where you're going to
be able to get
you know a state
but just like there's more Irish people
who live outside of Ireland right just
like you know the Jewish people you know
didn't actually get a state in Poland or
have you they they had one in Palestine
perhaps the catalonians could crowdfund
territory in other places
and have essentially a state of their
own that's distributed okay now again
what people are immediately going to say
as well that's going to lead to conflict
with locals necessarily and so and so
forth
but if you're parallel processing you
don't have the all-in-one bucket aspect
of I must win here and the guy on the
other side is like I must win you have
optionality you can you can have
multiple different nodes around the
world just like there's multiple
chinatowns you could have multiple
catalonian towns right and uh some
places you might be able to just buy an
island and that becomes you know the new
Catalonia right
um just like in I think there's a
there's a region called New Caledonia
um and that's in the Southwest Pacific
so maybe maybe new Catalonia is
somewhere else right so if you're
flexible in that now of course a bunch
of people will immediately say they'll
have 50 different objections to this
they'll say oh you don't get it the
whole point is the land and you know so
on they've been there for Generations
sort of say I do get it
um but this Catalan nationalist who's
like literally ridden in catalonian for
I don't know how many years right uh is
basically saying this is worth thinking
about and so it's a peaceful Third Way
yeah but it's it's interesting I mean it
it to it I mean it's it's a good
question whether Elon Musk SpaceX and
Tesla will be successful without Twitter
yeah I I don't think as as successful I
mean I mean obviously they existed
before Twitter and a lot of the
engineering problems are obviously
non-twitter things right but Twitter
itself is certainly probably helped us
with Tesla sales the engineering no
that's not that's not what I mean the
best people in the world solve the
engineering problems yes but he hires
the people to solve them and he knows
enough about engineering that's the
point I'm making is on Twitter the
legend of Elon Musk is created
the vision
is communicated and the best engineers
in the world come to work for the vision
it's an advertisement of a man of a
company pursuing a vision I think
Twitter is a great place to make viral
ideas that are compelling to people
whatever those ideas are and whether
that's the network state or whether
that's humans becoming a multiple
planetary species here is a remark I had
just before the pandemic related to this
okay but Twitter helping along just
beyond that for a second
maybe centralization is actually also
underexplored in the design space
for example today's social networks are
essentially governed by a single Co but
that Co is a background figure they
aren't leading the users to do anything
what if they did one example could Elon
musk's then 30 million followers somehow
get us to Mars faster
tools for directed collaborative work by
really large groups on the internet are
still in their infancy you can see a
piece of what I was talking about the
scratch Pad thing the network State
being a group with which can do
Collective actions this is kind of the
thing right so Technologies for internet
collaboration that can be very useful to
the software for future network States
operational transformation is held at
Google Docs coordinates edits
um conflict-free replicated data types
is another it's an alternative easier to
code in some ways an operational
transformation microtask like mechanical
Church scale Ai and earn.com before we
sold it blockchains and crypto obviously
the polymath project where a bunch of
people parallel processed and were able
to solve an open math problem by
collaborating
um Wikipedia with its flaws that we
talked about social networks and group
messaging all these are ways for
collaborating they're not just simply
attacking or doing something on the
Internet this is something that Elan
could use right what works and what
doesn't about Twitter if there's
something that's broken how would you
fix it a million things I can say here
so a few things first is fact checking I
had this kind of fun I thought it was a
funny tweet to anyone who wants to quote
ban lying on social media please write
down a function that takes in a
statement and returns whether it is true
if you can start with the remand
hypothesis that would be amazing yeah
okay yeah not put that's kind of funny
right that's funny and uh so now that
joke
landed on like five people sure you want
to explain the joke well no I there's a
lot of problems decidability where the
truth that's what proofs in math is the
truth of the thing is actually
exceptionally difficult to determine and
that's just a really nice example the
problems that persist across centuries
that have not been solved by the most
Brilliant Minds they're essentially true
or false problems that's right and so
when people are saying when they were
saying they want to ban lying on social
media fact check social media the
assumption is that they know what is
true and what do they mean by that they
really mean the assertion of political
power right
with that said do I think it could be
useful to have some kind of quote factor
I can think yes but it has to be
decentralized and open source you could
imagine an interesting concept of coding
trugle like a Google that return was
true it's like a modified version right
it's like gpt3 but the stable diffusion
version where it's open
okay and so now anybody Stables Fusion
shows that it's possible to take an
expensive AI model and put it out there
right so you have you know you don't
Knowledge Graph is like like basically
you know uh you wouldn't actually uh
whether you have it as rdf or like a
like a triple store kind of thing or
some other representation it's like an
ontology of a is a b and you know B has
a c and it's got probabilities on the
edges sometimes and other kinds of
metadata and this allows Google to show
certain kinds of one box information
where it's like
um what is so what is Steve Jobs's uh
you know what is what is Laureen Powell
Jobs's uh age or birthday they can pull
that up out of the out of the um the
knowledge graph right and uh so you can
imagine the true goal would have both
deterministic and statistical components
and crucially it would say whether
something is true according to a given
Knowledge Graph
and so this way at least what you can do
is you can say okay here's the things
that are consensus reality like the
value of the gravitational constant will
be the same in the Maga Knowledge Graph
and the US establishment Knowledge Graph
and the CCP Knowledge Graph and the the
I don't know the resilient Knowledge
Graph and so on and so forth okay but
there's other things that will be quite
different
and at least now you can isolate where
the point of disagreement is and so you
can have a form of decentralized fact
checking that is like according to who
well here is the authority and it is
this knowledge graph right so that's
like a kind of thing right yeah yeah so
that is
um so that's one concept of like what
next social media looks like there's
there's actually so much more another
huge thing is decentralized social media
okay social media today is like China
under communism in a really key sense
there's a great article called The
Secret document that transformed China
do you know what China was like before
1978 I know about the atrocities sure so
but some flesh on the yeah bone so to
speak okay
so basically there's a good book um
because I think a lot of documents
became public recently and so there's a
window when it opened up now it's
probably closing back down again but but
you know great biographies because of
that were written like I'm currently
reading Mao's Great Famine by Frank de
Carter yeah which is uh
who boy
it's crazy okay yeah here's the thing is
capitalism was punishable by Death
in living memory in China just to
explain what that meant okay I mean
that's what communism was right it was
literally the same China that has like
the CC you know the entrepreneurs and
Jack Ma and so on and so 40 something
years ago capitalism was punishable by
death but to put to give in a concrete
example this is a famous story in China
maybe apocryphal but it's what you know
the folks have talked about there's a
village in xiaogang and basically all
the green that you were produced was
supposed to go to the collective and
even one straw belonged to the group at
one meeting with Communist Party
officials a farmer asked what about the
teeth in my head do I own those answer
no your teeth belong to the collective
okay now the thing is uh that when
you're taking a hundred percent of
everything okay work hard don't work
hard everyone gets the same so people
don't want to work right so what
happened
these Farmers gathered in secret and
they did something that was like would
have gotten them executed they they were
a contract amongst themselves and said
we all agree that we will be able to
keep some of our own grain we will give
some of them to the regime so when it
comes to collect grain they've got
something we'll be able to keep some of
it and if any of us are killed for doing
this then the contract said that the
others would take care of their children
okay so to keep some of what you earned
I mean just think about how it formed
the many capitalism Society within the
Communist secret cap of some Society so
amongst five people yeah right so now
that they could keep some of what they
earned right it seems returned they had
a bumper Harvest and you know what
happened with that bumper Harvest that
made the local officials really
suspicious and mad they weren't happy
that there was a bumper Harvest they're
like what are you doing you're doing
capitalism right and in you know a few
years earlier they might have just been
executed and in fact many were that's
what it means when you see Millions dead
Millions dead means guys were shot for
keeping some grain for themselves okay
it means like guys came and kicked in
the door of your Collective farm and you
know raped your wife and took you off to
a prison camp and so forth that's what
communism actually was okay it hasn't
been depicted in movies there's a great
post um by Ken Billingsley in in the
year 2000 called uh I got this right
Hollywood's missing movies
okay this is um
basically here I'll paste this links you
put in the show notes all right this is
worth reading it's still applicable
today but now that we have stable
diffusion now we have all these people
online now that Russia and China are
America's national bad guys
um you know as they were before they are
again perhaps we'll get some movies on
what communism actually was during the
twin century and how bad it was right
and you know vaccinate people against
that as well as against Nazism which
they should be okay the point of this uh
go ahead uh no because I'm I'm
congratulating myself on the nice
because you're sending me excellent
links on WhatsApp and I just saw that
there's an export chat feature yes great
because we also have disappearing
messages on so I was like all right this
is great great I'll be able to get it
this your your ability to reference
sources is incredible so thank you for
this anyways otherwise if I if I say
something it sounds too surprising so
that's why I want to make sure I have it
on this top yeah so like yeah I mean
people would be like shot for for
holding some grain so what happened
though was
ding Xiaoping
said okay
um we're not going to kill you in fact
we're going to actually set up the first
special economic zone in Shenzhen he
didn't try to flip the whole country
from communist to capitalist in one go
and said he's like we can reform in one
place
and in fact he fenced it off from the
rest of China and it did trade with Hong
Kong and he spent his political capital
on this one exception it grew so fast
that gave him more political Capital you
know some people think actually that the
you know sino-vietnamese War uh was
deng's way of just distracting the
generals while he was turning China
around to get it back on the capitalist
Road and what he did was
um the opposite of a rebranding he did a
reinterpretation like a rebranding is
where the substance is the same but the
logo is changed okay you know you're now
you were Facebook you're now meta that's
a rebranding right
reinterpretation is where the logo and
The Branding is the same they're still
the CCP they're still the Chinese
Communist party but they're capitalist
now the engine under the hood it's
deniable okay and this is a very common
once you realize those are different
things it's like swap the front end swap
the back end yeah
go ahead go ahead put it right it's
really good yeah yeah
enjoying your metaphors and way of
talking about stuff yes I get yeah yeah
swap you could yeah when branding and
swap the front end my interpretation
swap the back end that's right once you
you know once you realize that you're
like okay I can just like as an engineer
you can kind of okay sometimes I want to
do this on the front end sometimes in
the back end sometimes this is explicit
and sometimes user doesn't need to see
it and it's on the back end lots of
political stuff uh you know is arguably
not just best done in the back end but
always done on the back end one of the
points I make in the book is left is a
new right is a new left is
um you know if you look through history
the the Christian King the Republican
conservative the CCP entrepreneur
um the um the WASP establishment these
are all examples of a revolutionary left
movement becoming the ruling class right
okay like the Republican conservative
just is that one example I go through
extend description of this in the book
but the Republicans were the The Radical
Republicans the left of 1865 they won
the Revolution and their moral Authority
LED them to have economic Authority in
the late 1800s you wouldn't want a
Democrat Confederate Trader as the head
of your you know Railroad Company would
you right so all the Confederate Traders
Etc were boxed out from the plum
positions in the late 1800s uh and so
what happened was the Republicans turned
their moral Authority into economic
Authority made tons of money the
Democrats then started repositioning not
as a party of the Southern racist but
the the poor right and you know the
cross of gold speech by William James
Brown was part of that there's a gradual
process that reaches but let's say a
crucial Mark with the election of FDR
whereas actually not the 1932 but 1936
election that uh black voters switched
over to FDR okay that was actually the
the like the major flip to like 70 you
know to to to the Democrats now they've
reposition it as a party the poor not
the party of the South okay and
Republicans
had lost
um some economic Authority or rather
they had moral authority to turn into
economic Authority they started to lose
some moral Authority the loss of moral
30 was complete by 1965. that was
actually mop-up people dated you know
the Civil Rights Movement as a big way
where the Republicans lost mortality
it's not really that was a mop-up
because uh 1936 30 years earlier was
when black voters switched to the
Democrats okay 1765 was another 10
points moving over of black voters to
Democrats Roslyn said completely lost
moral Authority 100 years after the
Civil War okay then the next 50 years
that loss of moral Authority meant that
they lost economic Authority because now
you wouldn't want a republican bigot as
a c of your tech company anymore would
you right so by 2015 2020 now now you
have it's like two sine waves that are
staggered right moral Authority leads to
economic Authority leads to loss of uh
moral Authority leads to loss of
economic Authority and so now you have
the uh the Democrats you know have you
know completed 155-year Arc from the
defeated party in the Civil War to the
dominant party in the US establishment
all the woke capitalists are now at the
very top and now the same repositioning
is happening where if you're so woke why
are you rich
you get it right like you know if you're
so smart why aren't you rich is the
normal kind of thing right if you're
still woke if you're so holy why is like
for example the BLM founder why do they
have this million dollar mansion right
if you're so woke and it's all about
being good and you're anti-capitalist
how come you seem to be raking in the
money Etc right
this is an argument which I'm not sure
how long it will go
um it might take years to play out it
might take decades to play out I think
probably on the order of a decade you're
going to see in my view the
repositioning if the Democrats are the
world capitalists the Republicans will
eventually become are becoming the
Bitcoin maximalists why because
you know if one guy picks left the other
guy picks right it's literally like
magnets kind of repelling they're sort
of forced into the other corner here
right in the Bitcoin Maximus will
essentially where this guy says
centralization they say decentralization
where they defend the right of capital
to do anything the maximalist will say
actually you're all cantillionaires
um you're all benefiting from printed
money you don't have anything that's
legitimate you don't actually own
anything is all a handout from the
government and so on and so forth right
and um so that's the counter positioning
that will basically attack the wokes
about how much money they're making
they're not contesting the ideology so
when one guy signals economics you
signal culture when uh their guy signals
culture you signal economics that's
actually that's the whole thing I can
talk about should I talk about that for
a second sure is is this uh integrated
into the forces that you talk about
you've talked about the three forces
that Trifecta forces that affect our
society which is the wokes let's say
what
you've talked so fast it's uh and I
think so slow no no no uh woke Capital
communist capital and crypto capital
uh can you explain each of those three
we actually talked about each of the
three in part but it'd be nice to bring
them together in a beautiful triangle
and then I'll also come back up and I'll
talk about how the CCP story relates to
social media and decentralized social
media okay all right so nyt CCP BTC is
what capital economy's capital crypto
capital and communist capital is the
simplest is you must submit the
Communist party is powerful CCP is
powerful and you are not if you're in
China you just CCP is an embodiment of
communist Capital that you're talking
about well yeah so basically and by the
in China they call it CPC you know so
basically they don't like it usually if
you say CCP right so uh like Communist
Party of China as opposed to Chinese
kind of sort of there basically that is
capitalism that is uh that it's a
Chinese pool of capital that billion
person pool okay that that's WeChat and
it's
um you know it's Alibaba and it's the
entire kind of thing that is one just
social network with currency the whole
thing is vertically enjoyable when we
say communist what do you mean here why
is the word communist important why
don't you just say China so it's it's
communist an important way well it's
just a catchy label it's a catchy level
but I think it's also important because
it seems It's paradoxical right so I had
a threat on this the future is communist
Capital versus Capital versus crypto
Capital each represents a left right
Fusion that's Bizarre by the standards
of the 1980s consensus it's PRC versus
mmt versus BTC all right and why is it
Bizarre by the standards of 1980s
consensus well in the 1980s you wouldn't
think the Communists would become
capitalists but they did you wouldn't
think that the wokes the progressives
right
um would become so enamored with giant
corporations and and their power right
they've seen something to like in that
right
um and you also wouldn't think that the
non-americans or the post-americans or
the internationalists would be the
champions of capital because
you'd think it's the American Nation
right so rather than the conservative
American nationalists
being the Defenders of capital
you have the
liberal
Americans who are with capital you have
the Communist Chinese here with capital
and you have the international sword
with capital and it's the conservative
American nationalists who are in some
ways against that which is which is kind
of funny right so uh so it's like this
weird ideological flipping that
um if you if you look if you take the
long lens you have these polls that kind
of repel each other okay so just on the
CCP nyt BTC thing
nyt by the way is Wolf Capital yeah what
is nyt so its formula is a little
interesting if CCP is just you must
submit because they're powerful okay and
then you bow your head because the
Chinese Communist party is strong well
capital is you must sympathize why do
you bow your head Lex oh because you're
a white male therefore you're guilty you
sympathize you must bow your head
because you are powerful
yet notice it ends in the same place in
your your head looking to the ground
right in China it's because they are
powerful so therefore you must bend your
head
for the wogues it's the left-handed
version where you are powerful and
that's shameful so you should bow your
head
right right okay but it ends in your
head bowed it's an ideology of
submission it's not that subtle but it's
like somewhat subtle and then finally
crypto capital is head held high you
must be sovereign
okay which and one of the things I point
out in the in the book is each of these
polls
is
um negative in some ways when taken to
extreme but also negative in its
opposite for example
obviously just totally submitting to
Total surveillance is bad but a society
where nobody submits is San Francisco
where people just Rob stores and walk
out you know in the middle shoplifting
you know all this all these goods and
nothing happens right a society where
you know you have the vocal level of
sympathy where you get to the kind of
insanity of math is white supremacist
and whatever you know nonsense is is
happening today is terrible but a
society that's totally stripped of
sympathy is also not one that one would
want to be part of right that's just
like the
you know whether it's 4chan's actual
culture or it's fan culture or something
like that or some some weird combination
you that's also not good it's like
Russia in the 90s like nobody trusts
anybody that's also bad
and you know being totally Sovereign
that sounds good and there's a lot that
is good about it and I'm sympathetic to
this corner but being totally Sovereign
you go so capitalist so Sovereign that
you're against the division of labor you
don't trust anybody so you have to pump
your own water and so on so you actually
have a reduced standard of living over
here okay
and conversely survivalist or whatever
survivalist type stuff right and you
just kind of you you just go kind of too
crazy into that corner and then like of
course though the Other Extreme of you
know having no sovereignty is the you
will own nothing and be happy
everything's in the cloud and can be
deleted at any point right so each of
these is kind of has Badness when it's
there but also it's total extreme
opposite is bad and so you want to kind
of carve out like an intelligent
intermediate of these three poles and
that's the you know decentralized center
of the recentralized center I call now
with that said
I think there is a repositioning in
particular of vote Capital that is
happening and I think if the 2000s was
the global war on terror and then the
channel just changed to wokeness in the
2010s and I mean channel change have you
seen Paul Graham's graph or actually
David rosado's graph that Paul Graham
posted no but this is a good chance to
say that Paul Graham is awesome okay
yeah and so here is this graph okay
David rosado's data analysis I think
that put this together so but basically
this is a graph of the word usage
frequency New York Times 1970 to 2018
and he's got some controls there Paul
Graham tweets hypothesis although some
newspapers can survive the switch to
online subscriptions none can do it and
remain politically neutral quote
newspaper or record you have to pick a
side to get people to subscribe and
there's uh a bunch of
plots
on the x-axis is years on the y-axis is
the frequency of use
and sexism has been going up misogyny
has been going up sexist
patriarchy Mass planning toxic
masculinity male privilege all these
terms have been going up
very intensely in the past in in the in
the past decade yeah but really 2013 is
the exact moment you see these things
they're flat and they just go vertical
mansplaining toxic masculinity what
precisely happened in 2013. ah so
I talk about this in the book but I
think fundamentally what happened was
Tech hurt media and their revenue
dropped by uh about 50 billion dollars
over the four years from oh 2012 yeah
Tech helped Obama get reelected and
media was positive on on Tech until
December 2012 they wrote like the Nerds
Go Marching In in the Atlantic then
after January 2013 once Obama was
ensconced then the knives came out
because basically these Tech guys were
bankrupting them they were through
um supporting them and so the journals
got extremely nasty and uh just
basically they couldn't build search
engines or create social networks but
they could write stories in shape and
artists so clear editorial Direction
went down that
um you know essentially took all of this
all these weapons that had been
developed in Academia to win status
competitions and Humanities departments
yeah and and then they just deployed
them right and essentially somebody
observed that wokeness is the
combination of uh focality and
deconstruction and civil rights where
deconstruction takes away you know the
legitimacy of the old order and then
civil rights says okay the only thing
that's good is is this right which is
says the older is also bad in a
different way but this is what's good
and um
that is the underpinning ideology the
the all these words have embedded in
them like in ideology right another way
of thinking about it is
this is not my reference but outside
anyway the glossary of the Greek
um military Junta right the creation and
or use of special terms are employed by
the juntas propaganda tools
um because essentially the word itself
embeds a concept you can rustle
conjugate something one way or the other
right Russell conjugation is this
concept that I sweat you perspire but
She Glows you can always take something
you know you are uncontrollably angry
but uh he is righteously indignant okay
um you have a thin skin they clap back
right so once you kind of realize that
these words have just been chosen in
such a way as to delegitimize their
Target and they all went vertical in
2013 and they were suddenly targeted
against the erstwhile alleys you know in
Tech but also just across the the
country you can see that this great
awokening that's what uh Iglesias called
it by playing Words the Great Awakening
right this kind of spasm of
quasi-religious extremism I wouldn't
call it religious because it's not
god-centered it's release date and
network centered so I call it a Doctrine
which is a superset of religion and
political Doctrine this uh these words
went vertical and the all the terrorism
stuff you just noticed kind of fell off
the cliff that was the obsession of
everything in the 2000s
and just channel change right it's
amazing how that happened yeah it's not
like not like any of the pieces got
picked up some of those Wars are still
raging of course and there's uh victims
to this wilkism movement and um but in a
weird way even though some parts of it
just like you know Siri like there's
wars in the Middle East that still keep
raging there's there's certainly active
fronts of locism you know but in a sense
the the next shift is already on you
know why
it's a pivot for mochism to statism
in many ways nyt is sort of and more
generally the U.S establishment is sort
of kind of coming you may not believe
this they're kind of coming back to the
center a little bit and the same with
that Lenin After the revolution
implemented the New Economic Policy
which you may be aware of right which
was just like X percent more capitalism
you kind of boot on the neck take
control but then ease up for a bit and
the so-called net men during the 20s
were able to eke out something there was
like you know oh okay fine he's going to
be easier on us then an intense fight
again because basically by loosening up
they were able to consolidate control
they weren't putting as much pressure on
right then it went extremely intense
again right uh similar to like Mao's
like 100 flowers saying let a hundred
flowers bloom and you know everybody
came out and then he found out all the
people who were against him and he
executed a bunch of them right so what's
happening now is nyt is and more
generally just establishment is somewhat
tacking back to the center where you
know they're not talking BLM and abolish
the police they're saying fund the
Capitol Police right they've they've
gone from The Narrative of 2020 which
was meant to win a domestic contest
where they said America is a
systemically racist country tear down
George Washington we're so evil to the
red record 2022 which is we're the
global champion of democracy and every
non-white country is supposed to trust
us
now
obviously those are inconsistent right
if if you're in India or you're in
Nigeria and you just heard that the
America is calling itself the same guys
by the way saying it's so
institutionally racist systemically
racist and you're saying well we're the
leader of the Free World and the number
one obviously there's inconsistency
between the domestic propaganda and the
foreign propaganda right there's a
contrast between abolish the police and
put two billion for the capital police
you can reconcile this and you can say
the use establishment is pro-federal and
anti-local and state so abolished the
local police who tend to be you know
Republican or rightist but fund the FBI
fund the capital police who tend to be
you know just like in the
um in the Soviet Union as a national
things like the the KGB right that were
there for the um uh for the state
um but there are all these local
nationalist ethnic insurgencies and like
Estonia and other places right so you
can reconcile them but nevertheless on
its face those those are contradictory
so what are you going to get I think I
think you're going to get
um this rotation where uh a fair number
of the folks on the sort of
authoritarian right are kind of pulled
back into the fold a bit okay these are
the cops and the military and whatnot
some of them because as this decade
progresses you're going to see the
signaling on American statism as opposed
to wilkism okay which is 30 degrees back
towards the center right conversely on
the other side you're going to have the
left Libertarians and right Libertarians
who are signaling crypto and
decentralization and so on okay and so
the next one isn't red versus blue it's
Orange versus green it's a dollar versus
Bitcoin and so you have the
authoritarians the top of the political
Compass versus the quote Libertarians
right and here is the here's the visual
of that
so that's why like you know as I wrote
the book and after I was like you know
I'm already seeing this
um this shift happening from war on
terror to wilkism to American statism
right and here just take a look at this
visual
interesting so uh the visual is an
animation transforming
the
left versus right libertarian versus
authoritarian to uh
Bitcoin dollar versus versus crypto
that's right and some folks switch sides
right because you have folks Like You
Know Jack Dorsey and a lot of the tech
Founders in basically the lower left
corner right who were blue but are now
going to become orange or are orange and
you have folks in the upper right corner
who are going to at the end of the day
pick the dollar and the American flag
over the internationalist ideals of
cryptocurrency the realigning as you
call it let me ask you uh I the briefly
we do need to get a comment your
Visionary view of things
we're at a low point in the
cryptocurrency space from a shallow
analysis perspective or maybe in a
deeper sense if you can enlighten me do
you think Bitcoin will rise again yes do
you think you'll go uh to take on
Fiat you know to go over a million
dollars to go to these Heights I mean I
think it's possible and the reason I
think it's possible is I think a lot of
things might go to a million dollars
because inflation is inflation right
it's an important point right it's a
very important Point yes because you're
seeing essentially
yes but so the choke pointing on energy
is pushing up prices across the board
for a lot of things the supply you know
China's not doing us any favors with the
covid uh lockdowns
um Putin's not doing the world any
favors with this with this giant War
um there's a lot of bad things happening
in the physical world right you know you
have
I mean when China Russia and the US are
all and Europe is you know like there's
folks who are just insane about degrowth
and they're against
um you know they're they're they're
they're pushing for burning coal and
wood right so a lot of prices are going
up in a really foundational and
fundamental way and um with that said
also the dollar is in some ways
strengthening against certain other
things because a lot of other countries
are dying harder right
um you know and you've got riots in Sri
Lanka and riots in Panama and riots in
you know all these places right so it's
it's very complicated because you've got
multiple different Trends going in the
same way you're you're Bitcoin Maximus
would just say infinity over 21 million
and so therefore you print all the
dollars there's only 200 million
Bitcoins so Bitcoin goes to Infinity but
it can be something where lots of other
currencies die and the dollar is
actually exported via stable coins okay
um but I do think it still moves Fiat
still moves somehow into the
cryptocurrencies yeah yeah it's I think
it's kind of like Microsoft where and
windows is still around right I'm
actually still around still a you know
multi 100 billion dollar company it
doesn't mean it he doesn't mean it don't
worry all my machines are windows are
they still boot yeah okay okay I don't
know a single Mech really okay that you
are unusual on that yeah that's um so at
least for hours it's not an ideology
just convenience fine I mean they
actually now post out there they do make
some good stuff right like uh Microsoft
teams is good right like there's a lot
of different stuff and UCO has done a
lot of innovative things like GitHub
yeah then we built this in acquisition
but still it's not giving credit for the
acquisition the pivoting of vision and
motivations and uh focus and all that
kind of stuff anyway yes Microsoft does
an analogy metaphor for something well
yeah so basically just like you know
they didn't need a turnaround but they
are they didn't endure to the present
day they didn't die from Google app I
mean for the massive attacks on them
they didn't die they are less powerful
but they make more money right yes and
um
I think that might be something that I
mean our best case scenario is the use
establishment or CCP has more power over
fewer people
okay I see and so you know but you can
exit if you if you're there you're kind
of knuckling under or whatever but you
can exit right and so I mentioned the uh
those three polls CCP is obviously a
billion people 1.4 aligned under the
digital Yuan and so on right nyt is the
entire you know it's it's the tech
companies it's the US dollar it is this
session and then crypto capital is
everybody else but I actually think that
over time
that third world is web 3 this time and
that's the third poll and that's India
and it's Israel and it's lots of
American conservatives and left
Libertarians and Libertarians and it's
also lots of Chinese liberals all the
folks who are trying to get out of China
because you know the like the you know
it's become so Nationalist and crazy and
difficult for capitalism and so if you
take basically non-establishment
Americans on both left and right okay
the the you know the bottom two
quadrants in the political Compass I
talked about you take the liberal
Chinese you take the Israelis and the
Indians why because they don't both of
them are have a lot of tech Talent right
they're the number one and number two
demographics for Tech founders
and they
want to while they are generally
sympathetic to the West right and
they're more ties to the West they also
are more cautious about national
interests rather than just starting
fights you know where that's how they
would think about it right they just you
know India thinks is a poor country
Israel thinks of itself as a small
country and so therefore it needs to not
just get in every fight just for the
sake of it and so you need to maintain a
cautious distance with China but not
like dude what Pelosi is doing and try
and start start like a big thing okay
I think Israel is similar where it's
maintaining diplomatic relations with
China it's more friendly towards China
than the US's Indian Israel I think are
two sovereign states that have a lot of
globally mobile tech talent that
obviously have ties to the West with the
large diaspora that are hard to demonize
you know in around the sense of
willing to argue on the internet let's
put it like in English right it's very
important and
um them plus enough Americans plus
enough Chinese can set up another poll
that is not for Cold War or military
confrontation but for peace and trade
and freedom and so on and so forth right
that's the center
as opposed to the you know left of the
you know the the woke American U.S
establishment or the right of the ultra
nationalist CCP right that's what I
think about now what I would say here is
the reason I think these are the kind of
the three polls you can argue against
this right you can say it's unipolar
World America is totally dominant that's
one argument you could say it's a
bipolar world it's just the US versus
China no no everybody else will have to
be forced to align with one or the other
jayashanker you know actually explicitly
rejected this he's like look there's a
billion people in India it's coming up
on it will eventually be like the number
three economy it's on the rise
he's got the history and culture he
thinks he's entitled to have India's
Intel to have its own side right in such
a thing it's a funny way of putting it
right yeah but it's also true and uh so
you could say it's unipolar you can say
it's bipolar you could say it's just
multi-polar and everybody is kind of
their you know India Israel these groups
are out there but I actually think it's
going to be tripolar the reasons
tripolar is these three pools are the
groups that have enough media and money
and scale and whatnot to really kind of
be self-consistent civilizations
obviously China's like the vertically
integrated like apple or whatever just
like a stable ideology a stable ideology
that's right right obviously the you
know the books have control of lots of
Institutions they've got the US
establishment and they've got the tech
companies they've got the media
companies and so on but crypto is
basically everybody else and crucially
crypto has inroads in China and America
where it's hard to demonize it as
completely foreign because there's many
many many huge proponents of the
Universalist values of crypto in America
and China because it is
true Global rule of law and free speech
and you know so on it is genuinely
Universalist in a way where America can
no longer be you know the number one
rule of the rules-based order is
America's always number one and China
doesn't even pretend to maintain a rules
base order right yes whereas for all
those countries that don't want to
either be dominated by the U.S media
corporations that can or social media
that can just censor Trump nor do they
want to be dominated by China this is an
attractive alternative a platform they
can make their own right so that's where
I think you know I wrote an article on
this in foreign policy on um here here's
two articles that talk about this a
little bit it's called great protocol
politics
and then here's another one on these
sort of domestic thing Bitcoin is
civilization for Barry Wise okay but I
want to just come up the stack a little
bit and just return to that original
point which I diverged on which was why
I gave the whole example of how uh
we got into China because I talked about
how China had gone from communist
capitalists and letting people have just
a share of what they owned right with
social media
we're still in kind of the Communist era
of social media almost where whatever
you earn on social media like Google
takes its cut Twitter takes 100 you're
nothing for all your tweets or anything
like that not only do you have do you
earn nothing
um you might get a little rev share on
Tick Tock or YouTube you can do okay
right but not only do you earn either
nothing or a little bit you have no
digital property rights even more
fundamentally you are at the just the
whim of a giant Corporation can hit a
button and everything you work for over
Years Gone okay that is even if that is
quote the current state of events the
State of Affairs rather that is not the
right balance of power
to be able to unperson somebody at the
touch of a key and take away everything
in their digital world when we're living
more and more in the digital world we
need to check on that power and the
check on that power is crypto and it's
property rights and it's
decentralization right then when I say
digital search and decentralization I
mean
your money and your digital property is
by default yours and there has to be a
due process to for someone to take that
away from you everything all work is
online all your money is online your
presence is online that can just be
taken away from you with a with the
Press of a key that just gives you know
bad governments bad corporations so much
power that that's wrong right that's why
I'm a medium and long-term Bull on
crypto simply because to check on this
thing and that if you think about in
terms of just abstract decentralizations
one thing but you think about in terms
of property rights it's quite another
and um
now what that also means is once you
have property rights and you have
decentralized social media it'll be like
the explosion of trade that happened
after China went from communist
capitalist literally billions of people
around the world are no longer giving
everything to the collective they own
the teeth in their head now finally
okay is it funny right so you're Lex
friedman.eath you own it the keys are on
your computer the bad part is of course
they can get hacked or something like
that then you can deal with that with
social recovery there's ways of securing
keys but the good part is ta-da uh you
actually have property rights in the
Hernando de Soto sense you have
something you own ownership digital
ownership it's the cloud is great but
crypto gives you some of the
functionality of the cloud
while also having some of the
functionality offline world where you
have the keys so it's a v it's a V3
right it's you know it's continuous
theme right the V1 was offline I've got
a key I own it I have de facto control
V2 is a cloud someone else manages it
for me it's hosted I get collaboration
and so on V3 is the chain where you
combine aspects of those right you have
the global state of the cloud but you
have the local permission and
controlling of the private key okay so
that's why I'm a medium to long term
Ultra Bull on crypto and I've actually
there's a podcast I gave with a Simco
where I talked through how crypto
actually doesn't just go after Finance
so it's gold and it's wire transfers and
it's crowdfunding and it's all a finance
with D5 but it's actually also search
and it's social and it's messaging it's
actually even operating systems
um and uh and eventually cloud and
whatnot do you want me to talk about
that briefly yeah yeah if you can proof
you see social
how broad you see the effect of crypto
so first crypto is fundamentally a new
way of building back-end systems right
so if you think about how big a deal it
was to go from att's corporate Unix to
Linux
it's permissionless right when you went
from as much as I admire a lot of the
stuff that you know Sam Altman and Greg
Brockman have done at open AI I mean
they're phenomenal in terms of research
they've pushed the envelope forward I
give them a ton of credit right still it
was great to see stable diffusion out
there which
was open source AI right and so from a
developer from a power user standpoint
whenever you have the unlocked version
like an unlocked cell phone it's always
going to be better right so
the um what crypto gives you obviously
it's every Financial thing in the world
you can do stocks bonds et cetera it's
not just like the internet wasn't just a
Channel it wasn't like radio and TV and
internet it was internet radio and
internet TV and internet this and
internet that everything was the
internet all media became the internet
crypto is not an asset class it's all
asset classes it's crypto stocks and
crypto bonds Etc in a real sense like
private property arguably didn't exist
in the same way before crypto
international law didn't exist before
crypto how is how are you going to do a
deal between Brazil and Bangladesh
um if a Brazilian company wants to you
know acquire a Bangladeshi company they
usually have to set up a us adapter in
between because otherwise what are the
tax or the you know other obligations
between the two you set up a us adapter
or a Chinese adapter to go between them
but now that Brazilian embodization can
go peer-to-peer because they're using
the blockchain right they can agree on a
system of law that is completely you
know International and that's code so
each party can diligence it without
speaking Portuguese and Bengali right so
that's why I am a long-term Bull on
crypto I just described the the finance
case let me go through the others right
social so
you have the private keys for your ens
you have apps like forecaster you um
basically have decentralized social
media where there's different variants
some you just log in with your crypto
username others the entire social
network and all the likes and posts are
on chain like DSO but uh but there's
several different versions right search
Once uh you know once you realize
um block explorers are an important
stealth threat to search they're very
high traffic sites like blockchain.com
and either scan that Google is just
totally slept on they don't have a block
Explorer you don't have to do anything
in terms of trading or anything like
that Google does not have a block
Explorer why they don't think of it as
search but it is search it's absolutely
searched it's a very important kind of
search engine and once you have crypto
social you have you now show that you're
not just indexing in a block Explorer
like uh on-chain transactions but on
chain Communications
okay so now you suddenly see oh the
entire Social Web that Google couldn't
index It could only index a worldwide
web and not the Social Web now it's
actually the on-chain signed web
remember because every post is digitally
signed it's a new set of signals it's
way easier to index than either the
worldwide web or the Social Web because
it's open in public so this is a total
disruptive thing to search in the medium
term because the new kind of data sets
Index right
so that's how it's a threat to social to
search it is a threat to messaging why
because or it's disrupt eventually
because the ens name as I mentioned is
like a universal identifier you can send
encrypted messages between people that's
a better primitive to base it on you
know WhatsApp is just claiming that
they're end to end encrypted but with an
ens name or with a crypto name you can
be provably auditably and encrypted
because you're actually sending it back
and forth right because the private key
is local right that itself given how
important that is right you know you
could man in the middle signal or
Whatsapp because there's a server there
right if you have you know so n10
encrypted messaging will happen and with
payments and all this other stuff okay
so you get the crypto messaging apps you
get uh operating systems why well the
frontier of operating systems I mean
look you know Windows uh Linux and Mac
OS have been around forever but if you
actually think about you know what is a
blockchain
well there's operating systems there's
web browsers a blockchain is the most
complicated thing since an operating
system or webinars because it's a kind
of operating system why it's got you
know something like ethereum has an evm
it's got a programming language it's got
an ecosystem where people monetize on it
they build front-end apps and they build
back-end apps they interoperate between
each other this is a frontier of
operating systems research people
haven't thought of it that way right
it's also the frontier of a lot of
things in databases
um you will get a crypto LinkedIn where
there's zero knowledge proofs of various
credentials okay uh basically every
single web 2 company I can probably come
up with a web 3 variant of it right like
ethereum is I mean and this is high
praise for both parties but ethereum is
like the crypto stripe prior to the
Webster stripe and you will
um you will see versions of every
everything else that are like this
but you know I kind of described uh
search social messaging operating
systems the phone right Salon is doing a
crypto phone why do you want that again
digital property apple is was talking
about running some script to find if
people were having you know csam like CH
you know child porn or whatever on their
on their phones right and even nyt
actually reported that uh like Google
ran something like this and found false
positive some guy had to take a photo of
a kid for our you know medical diagnosis
it got false you know falsely flagged I
see Sam he lost access to his account
total nightmare imagine just getting
locked out of your Google account which
you're so dependent on right as more and
more of your Digital Life Goes online
you know is it really that much
ethically different if it's the Chinese
state that locks you out or an American
corporation
right basically it's operationally very
similar you just have no recourse you're
unpersoned right so the crypto phone
becomes like insanely important because
you have a local set of private keys
this was the keys to your currency and
your passport and your services and your
life right so like become something you
just hold on you with your person at all
times like your normal phone you might
have backups and stuff but you know the
crypto phone is an insanely important
thing okay and so that's search that's
social that's messaging that's
um operating systems that's a phone
that's a lot right there yeah that's
beautiful can I have 120 seconds to just
finish up a few more thoughts on social
media please okay AI and AR okay just
massive impact obviously of AI and
social media you're going to have
completely new social media companies
gestures other things you know Tick Tock
having you know some of the AI creation
Tools in there is it's just like V1 of
that
um this whole thread with everything
stable diffusion is unlocking but
basically this is going to melt
Hollywood Us Media corporations that
took a hit in the 2010s we're now going
to be able to have everyone around the
world able to tell their story and all
the stuff about AI ethics and AI bias
the ultimate bias is centralized AI
only decentralized AI is truly
representative you cannot be faux
representative you cannot claim that
some that Google is representing
Nigerians and Indians and Brazilians and
Japanese like those folks need to have
access themselves right so that's a
fundamental ethical argument against
centralized AI it's unethical and it's
like you know this faux thing where you
might have like faux diversity in the uh
in the interface but you haven't
actually truly decentralized it this is
the world capitalism right you justify
it with the bookness and you make the
money by centralizing it but the actual
way of doing it is letting it free for
the world and letting people build their
own versions if people want to build a
Asian Lord of the Rings they can do that
they want to build an Indian one they
can do that if they you know whatever
they want right so
that is the argument for
um Ai decentralization and for how that
kind of links to this I love that AI
decentralization fixes the bias problem
and AI which a lot of people seem to
yeah centralization talks about and
focus on yeah centralization is
inherently unrepresentative
fundamentally like you can like
mathematically show it it's not
representing the world
the the decentralization allows anybody
to pick it up and make it their own
right and centralization is almost
always a mask for like that private
corporate interest where it's like one
of the things about the vocabulism thing
by the way is the Deep platforming of
trump is was political other things are
political but you know what D
platforming started with in the late
2000s early 2010s all the open social
stuff was when D platform was being used
as a corporate weapon against meerkat
and Zynga and Teespring right these were
companies that were competing with
features of you know tweet deck et
cetera they're competing with features
of Twitter or Facebook and the API was
cut off and that was when actually
progressives were for net neutrality and
an open internet and open social against
the concentration of corporate power and
so on remember that right and uh so
what's going to happen is both those two
things the political and the corporate
are going to come together why in the
Soviet Union
denunciation was used as a tool to for
example undercut romantic Rivals right
there's a great article called the
practice of denunciation in in you know
the Soviet Union right which talks about
all these examples where the ideological
argument was used to like kick somebody
into the 300 like pit that existed at
like the center of the Soviet Union
anybody could be kicked into the pit at
any moment and ta-da well Ivan's out you
know and now you know hey Anna you know
whatever right okay that same thing is
going to be used by what capitalist is
being used by vocabulous where the woke
argument is used to justify pulling
pushing their competitor out of the app
store or downracking them in search well
again you wouldn't want a a bigot to be
in search who could compete with us or
whatever right and conversely
um so so the wokeness is used to make
money and
um the money is used to advance the
ideology it's like this kind of back and
forth sometimes right now you think of
those as independent things but then
they fuse okay and so that's very clear
with the AI bias arguments where it just
so happens that it's so powerful Lex
this technology is so powerful in the
wrong hands it could be used so we will
charge you 999 for every use of it how's
that how altruistic is that is that
amazingly altruistic it's really good
right so
so once you kind of
um kind of see that as I said whenever
they're positioning an economics you can
go and culture when they're pushing on
culture you can go in economics if
they're so woke why are they Rich if
they're so concerned about
representation why is it centralized
answer they're not actually concerned
about it they're making money right okay
so that is I think in a few words blows
up a lot of the AI bias type stuff right
okay
um they're basically they're biasing AI
all right so the amount of stuff that
can be done with AI now like it also
helps the pseudonymous economy as I was
talking about with the AI Zoom so you
have totally new sites uh totally new
apps that are based on that
um it uh I think it may
um
I mean it changes you're going to have
new Google Docs you know all these kinds
of things you might have
um you know once you can do things with
just a few Taps you might have sites
that are focused more on producing
rather than just consuming because you
know you might with AI you can change
the productivity of gestures you know
you can have a few gestures like like a
for example the image to image thing
with the Seattle diffusion where you
make a little cartoon third graders
painting and it becomes a real painting
a lot of user interfaces will be
rethought now that you can actually do
this incredible stuff with that it knows
what you want it to do right
so um and I saw this funny thing which
was a riff on Peter thiel's line which
is AI centralized and crypto is
decentralized and and somebody was
saying actually it turns out crypto
centralized with the cbdc's and stable
coin and so on but AI is getting
decentralized with civil diffusion haha
right which is funny and I think there's
centralized and decentralized versions
of each of these right and finally the
third poll that actually you know teal
uh you know he talks about Ai and crypto
but the third poll is actually that's
sort of underappreciated because people
think it already exists is social that
just keeping on going right and
obviously the next step in Social is AR
and VR and why is it so obvious because
it's meta you know it's Facebook now I
saw this very silly article it's like oh
my God Facebook is so dumb for putting a
10 billion dollars into you know virtual
reality right and I'm like
okay the most predictable innovation in
the world in my view is the AR glasses
have you talked about this on the
podcast before AR VR um of course a lot
but the AR is not as obvious actually
okay so AR glasses what what are AR
glasses so you take Stamp Set spectacles
Google Glass
um Apple's AR kit Facebook's Oculus
Quest 2 right or Meta Meta Quest 2
whatever okay you put those together and
what do you get you get
um something that has the form factor of
glasses that you'd wear outside okay
which
um can with the tap record or give you
Terminator Vision on something or with
another tap go totally dark and become
VR glasses okay so normal glasses AR
glasses VR glasses recording it says
multifunctional as your phone but it's
hands-free and you might actually even
wear it more than your phone in fact you
might be blind without your AR glasses
because uh you know one of the things
I've shown in the book early on are like
floating sigils did we talk did I show
you that so this
is a really important just visual
concept that right there shows with AR
kit you can see a Globe floating outside
okay secret societies are are returning
this is what nfts will become the the
nft locally on your crypto phone if you
hold it you can see the symbol and if
you don't you can't
by the way for people just listening
we're looking at a nice nature scene
where an artificially
created Globus floating in the air
yes but it's invisible if you're not
holding up the AR kit phone yes right so
so only you have a window into this
artificial world that's right and then
here's another thing which shows you
another piece of it
and this is using ens to unlock a door
so this is an nft use for something
different so the first one was using the
nft effectively to see something and the
second is using the nft to do something
okay so based on your on-chain
communication right
um You can unlock a door that's that's a
door to a room soon it could be a door
to a building it could be the gates to a
community it could be your digital login
okay and so amazing what this means is
basically a lot of these things which
are like individual pieces get
synthesized right and uh you eventually
have a digital just like you have a
digital currency or digital currencies
unify Concepts like uh obviously gold
stocks bonds derivatives every kind of
financial instrument plus Chuck E cheese
tokens Karma everything that's fungible
and transferable the digital passport
unifies your your Google style login
your private Keys your API Keys your
nfts your ens name your domain name all
those kinds of things and your key card
for your door and so on right so the AR
glasses are what probably I don't know
it'll be Facebook's version three year
version four apple is also working on
them Google's also working on them you
might just get a bunch of those models
at the same time it's like predicting
the iPhone just like you know Dorsey
knew that mobile was going to be big and
that's why he had 140 characters for
Twitter because there's like an SMS code
limitation and Twitter was started
before the iPhone AR glasses are an
incredibly predictable invention that
you can start thinking about the future
of social is in part in person okay and
it also means people might go outside
more why because you can't see a monitor
in the Sun but you can hit AR and maybe
you have a you know full screen thing
and you just like kind of you know move
your fingers or something and you can
tap you have to figure out the gesture
you don't have Gorilla arms maybe you do
have a keyboard outside or just even
like a
um you could even have a desk like this
you know if you had
um if you can touch type you could
imagine something where you look down
and you can see a keyboard with your AR
glasses and it registers it and then you
can type like this right and probably
you could have some AI that could you
know figure out what you meant rather
than what you were doing right okay so
that's Ai and social media that's AR and
social media but really
um one last thing I'll say which is a
non-obvious non-techological part is I
think we'll go from
very broad networks which are hundreds
of millions or billions of people like
Twitter and Facebook which have many
small communities in them to much
smaller networks that have a million or
10 million people but are much deeper
right in terms of their associate
affiliation right and this is the
long-term Trend in Tech because you're
going from eyeballs in the 1980s sorry
the eyeballs in 1990s to daily active
users in the 2000s two holders
in the 2010s so you go from just like oh
I'm just a lucky loot to I'm logging in
every day so I'm holding a significant
percentage of my net worth
and then this decade is when the online
community becomes primary you're a
netizen the digital passport is your
main identity and so this is not see the
problem with Facebook or Twitter is it's
a bunch of different communities that
don't share the same values fighting
each other this brings us back to the
network state where you have one
Community with shared values shared
currency
um and it's full stack it's a it's a
social network and it's a cryptocurrency
and it's a co-living community and it's
a messaging app and it's a this and it's
a that and it's like Estonia you know
with a million people you can actually
build a lot of that full stack that is
starts to get to what I call a network
state
I feel like there should be like a a
standing Applause line here this is
brilliant you're an incredible person
this was an incredible conversation we
covered uh how to fix our government
looking at the future of governments uh
moving into Network State we we covered
how to fix medicine FDA longevity that
was just like a stellar
description and really I'll have to
listen to that multiple times to really
think and thank you for that especially
in this time where the lessons learned
from the pandemic
aren't clear to at least me and there's
a lot of thinking that needs to be done
there and then just a discussion about
how to fix social media and how to fix
money this was brilliant so um you're an
incredibly successful person yourself
you taught uh co-taught of course at
Stanford for hot for startups
that's a whole nother discussion that we
can have but let me just ask you
uh there's a lot of people that look up
to you so if there's somebody who's
young in high school early college
trying to figure out what the heck to do
with their life what to do with their
career what advice could you give them
how they could have a career they can be
proud of or how they can have a life
they can be proud of at least what I
would do and then it can take it or
leave it or what have you but uh so
yeah to maybe to your younger self
advice to your younger self you know my
friend novel is uh you know he this is a
lot of what he puts out is the very
practical you know brass tax next steps
and I tend towards the you know macro of
course we both do sort of you know both
kind of thing right
um but let's talk brass tack's next
steps because I actually am practical uh
or at least practical enough you know to
get things done I think it's just like
you said you're breaking up the new book
into three yes is motivation theory and
practice motivation theory and practice
that's right and social practice so
let's talk practice okay in visual scale
right so first what skill do you learn
as you know young kid right
um so let me let me just give what the
the ideal full stack thing is and then
you have to say okay I'm good
quantitatively I'm good verbally I'm
good at this I'm good that right so the
ideal is you are full stack engineer and
full stack influencer or full stack
engineer full stack Creator okay so
that's both right brain and you know
left brain all right so what does that
mean with engineering that means you
master computer science and statistics
okay and of course it's also good to
know physics and continuous math and so
on that's actually quite valuable to
know and you might need to use a lot of
that continuous math with AI nowadays
right because a lot of that is actually
helpful right
um great descent and whatnot but
computer science and stats are to this
Century what physics was to the last why
because for example what percentage of
your time do you spend looking at a
screen of some kind
large processors at the time a large
percentage of the time right probably
more than you know for many people it's
more than 50 of their waking hours if
you include laptop you include cell
phone tablet you know your watch you
know maybe monitor of some kind right
all those together is probably it's a
lot okay which means and then that's
going to only increase with ar glasses
okay which means most of the rest of
your life will be spent in a sense in
The Matrix
okay in a constructed Digital World
which is more interesting in some sense
in the offline world it's because we
look at it more it changes faster it's
right and where the physics are set by
programmers okay and uh what that means
is you know physics itself is obviously
very important for the natural world
computer science and stats are for the
artificial world right and uh why is
that because every domain
has algorithms and data structures
whether it's you Aviation okay you go to
American Airlines right they're gonna
have you know uh planes and seats and
tickets and so on such as data
structures and you're gonna have
algorithms and functions that connect
them you're gonna have tables that those
data is run to if it's Walmart you're
going to have skus and you're going to
have shelves you're going to have so you
have data structures and you have
algorithms connect them so every single
area you have algorithms and data
structures which is computer science and
stats and so you're going to
um collect the data and analyze it right
and so that means if you have that base
of Cs and stats where you're really
strong and you understand you know the
theory as well as the practice right and
you need both okay because you need to
understand you know obviously basic
stuff like Big O notation and whatnot
and uh you need to understand all your
probability distributions okay
um you know good exercise by the way is
to go from the
um Bernoulli trials right to everything
else because you can go Bernoulli trials
to the binomial distribution to the
gaussian you can also from you know
Bernoulli trials to the geometric
distribution and so on you can drive
everything from this right and computer
science includes not just Big O but
software engineering well computer
science is Theory software engineering
is practice right yeah you could argue
probability and stats is theory and then
data science is practice
sure right and so you include all of
that together as a package that's theory
in practice right I mean look it's okay
to use
um libraries once you know what's going
on under the hood right that's fine but
you need to be able to kind of write out
the whole thing yourself I mean it's
uh that could be true could not be true
I don't know are you sure about that
because well you shouldn't you could you
could you might be able to uh get quite
far standing on the shoulders of giants
you can but it depends like you couldn't
build
well okay somebody if you could however
you were going to finish that sentence I
could push back but you could probably
push back right but here's what I was
going to say I was going to say you
couldn't really you couldn't build
Google or Facebook or Amazon or Apple
without somebody at the company who
understood
like computer architecture and you know
layout of memory and you know theory of
compilers but you might want to see the
thing is if you just look at libraries
you might be able to understand the
capabilities and you can build up the
intuition of like what a great
specialized engineer could do that you
can't like you know for example you know
at least a while back facebook.com like
was literally it's just a single C plus
plus compiled binary or so it's not
super close it was like hip-hop they had
a PHP uh compiler where they had just
one giant binary I think I may be
getting this wrong but that's what I
recall right yeah yeah I mean that's
that's it should be simple it should be
simple and then you have guys like uh
John Carmack who comes in
and does an incredibly optimized
implementation that actually well yeah
more than that right like he's I mean
yes right go ahead I mean there's some
cases with John Carmack by being an
incredible engineer is able to bring to
reality things that otherwise would have
taken an extra five to ten years yeah or
maybe even more than that like so you
know this is the great man theory of
History versus like sort of the
um kind of the determinist like you know
waves of History are pushing things
along the way I reconcile those is the
tech tree model of History you know like
Civilization you're a play game
civilization yeah so like Civilization
you got the tech tree and you can go and
be like okay I'm gonna get Spearman or
I'm gonna do
greeneries and pottery right and so you
can think of it as something where
here's everything that Humanity has
right now and then Satoshi can push on
this dimension of the tech tree so he's
a great man because there was weren't
other there wasn't a leadness leibniz to
satoshi's Newton right like vitalik as
you know amazing as he is was five years
later or thereabouts right there wasn't
contemporaneous
um like you know another person that was
doing what Satoshi was doing is truly
swedenours right and that shows you know
what one person can do like probably
Steve Jobs with apple you know given how
the company was dying before he got
there and he built it into the most
valuable or put on the directory becomes
the most valuable company in the world
it shows that there is quote great man
right
um maybe more than just being five or
ten years ahead like truly shaping where
history goes right yeah but on their
hand of course that person Steve Jobs
himself wrote that email that prison was
searching saying that you know he
doesn't grow his own food and he doesn't
uh you know he didn't even think of the
rights that he's got someone else
thought of those and whatnot and so he
kind of it is always a tension between
the individual and Society on this right
but
coming back so Cs and stats that's what
you want to learn
um I think physics is also good to know
because you go one level deeper and of
course all these devices you're not
gonna be able to build
um you know uh lidar or things like that
without understanding physics right you
mentioned that as one side of the brain
what about the other right so CSS is is
that side okay and then you can go in
any domain any company kick butt you
know add value right okay so now the
other side is Creator right becoming a
Creator first online you know because
like social media is about to become far
far more lucrative and monetizable
people are not updated they kind of
think this is it's like over or
something like that or it's old or
whatever but
um with with crypto once you have
property rights in social media now it's
not what Google just allows you to have
but it's what you own right you actually
have genuine property rights
and that's just completely changes
everything just like you know the
introduction of property rights in China
change everything it might take some lag
for that to happen but you can lend
against that borrow against that uh you
you just you own the digital property
right and you can do nfts you can do you
know Investments you can do all this
other stuff right so uh in many ways I
think anybody who's listening who's like
you know I want to build a billion
dollar company I'm like build a building
on a company yes also build
um a million person media operation or a
million person following or something
online right because
a U.S Media company is simply not
economically or socially aligned with
your business I mean the big thing that
I think uh you know Tech and media
actually is funny they there's this
collision and sometimes there's an atom
smashing event and there's like a
repositioning right and media attack
Tech really hard in the 2010s as well as
many other things
and now post 2020 I think it's now
centralized Tech and media versus
decentralized Tech and media and
centralized Tech media is nyt and Google
which have all become vocified the
establishment companies but
decentralized second media is like sub
stack all lots of defectors from you
know uh from the US establishment from
the nyt have gone to substack but also
all the founders and funders are much
more vocal on Twitter whether it's Mark
Anderson Jack Dorsey Jeff Bezos uh
Zuckerberg Zuck is just cutting out the
establishment and just going direct to
you know posting himself or posting the
Jiu Jitsu thing you know which he
recently did or going and talking to
Rogan right
um and so you you now have this sort of
Adam Smash and like kind of
reconstitution why is that important
well look once you realize U.S media
companies are companies and you know the
their employees salzburger's employees
are just dogs on the leash right they're
they're they're hitmen for old money is
assassins for the establishment they're
never going to investigate him okay
there's this thing right now like some
strike that or possible strike that's
going at the New York Times the
obviously the most obvious rich
corporate zillionaire the epitome of
white privilege is you know and and
again another kind of person who thinks
white is an insult right but the you
know the guy who inherited the company
from his father's father's father
in the NFL right you know especially at
the Rooney Rule where you're supposed to
interview diverse candidates for the top
job the you know the other competitors
for the top job of the publisher New
York Times were
two cousins of salzburger so it's three
says straight white males in 2017 who
competed for this top job and everybody
in media was like silent about this car
Nation they had this car Nation article
in in the times about this right so
you have this meritless nepotist right
this literally Rich sis white man who
has makes millions of dollars a year and
it makes like 50x the salary of other
you know nyt journalists okay and uh you
know lives in a mansion and so on while
denouncing this is a born rich guy who'd
announced all the built Rich guys at a
company which is far wider than the tech
companies he's been to dancing okay and
again this is some there's a website
called Tech journalism is less diverse
than tech.com
um which actually shows the numbers on
this right here I can can look at this
numbers right so why why did I say this
well centralized U.S media has lost a
ton of clout
um engagement is down you've seen the
crypto prices down like stock prices
have crashed that's that's very obvious
and quantifiable less visible is that
media engagement has crashed right by
the way uh yeah there's a plot that
shows on the x-axis percent White
and then the y-axis of the different
companies
and the tech companies are basically
below 50 percent white and all the
different media
Tech journalism companies all way above
you know 70 80 90 90 plus percent White
and hypocrisy ladies and gentlemen I
mean again I'm not the kind of person
who thinks white as an insult but these
guys are and they are the Locust whites
on the planet right it's like ridiculous
right I you know it's like
anyone anyone who's homophobic anyone
who's that it feels like it's a personal
thing that they're struggling with maybe
the journalists are actually the ones
who are racist well actually you know
it's funny you say that because there's
this guy am Rosenthal okay and you know
on his gravestone was quote we kept the
he kept the paper straight right and
actually
um he essentially uh went and this is a
managing into the New York Times for
almost you know from uh 69 to 77
executive from 7786 and it was a history
yeah
history of basically keeping you know
gay reporter shot so essentially the way
I think about it is
um Newark post reported that
just just just to talk about this for a
second because it's so insane all right
New York Post reported and I've got some
of this in the book okay but
a Bros Rosenthal managing editor of the
New York Times from 1969 to 1977
executive editor from 1977 to 1986 his
gravestone reads he kept the paper
straight
and then here's Jeet here on this he
kept the paper straight As It Happens
Rosenthal was Notorious homophobic he
made it a specific policy of the paper
not to use the term gay he denied a
Plumb job to a gay man for being gay he
minimized AIDS crisis so like
you know the thing about this is this is
not like a one-off thing okay uh the New
York Times literally won a Pulitzer for
choking out the ukrainians for helping
starve five million ukraines to death
and now has reinvented themselves as
like a cheerleader to stand with Ukraine
right they were four you know
abrozenthals homophobia before they were
against it right they were like if you
saw the link I just pasted in okay
during BLM uh you know it's credibly
reported that I haven't seen this
refuted the family that owns the New
York Times Were slaveholders Somehow
that stayed out of 1619 and BLM coverage
right so they were literally getting the
profits From Slavery to help bootstrap
you know the what what was the times or
you know went into it they actually did
this article on like the compound
interest of
slaveholders in Haiti and how much they
owed people right if you apply that to
how much money they made off of slaves I
mean can anyone name one of salzburger's
slaves like can we humanize that put a
face on that show exactly you know who
who lost such that he may win right and
so you stack this up and it's like you
know for the Iraq War before they were
against it and it's like yeah sure Bush
you know did a lot of bad stuff there
but they also reported a lot of negative
you know not negative coverage like
false coverage right about wmds like you
know the whole Jews military and so it's
like this amazing thing where if some of
the most evil people in history are the
historians if the
um you know they actually ran this ad
campaign in the 2017 time uh period
called uh the truth so giant orwellian
Billboards right
um which say uh you know the truth is
essential here it looks like this this
is this was one this was just a few
years ago 2017. this is in New York
a billboard by the New York Times reads
the truth is hard to know the truth is
hard to find the truth is hard to hear
the truth is hard to believe the truth
is hard to accept the truth is hard to
deny the truth is more important now
than ever
okay this is like uh yeah this is 1984
type of stuff yeah now here's the thing
do you know what other truth yeah big
what truth period big white board
so okay what other National newspaper
proclaimed itself the truth in
constantly every every day you know this
one actually
yeah yeah there you go that's right what
is it what is the Soviet translation
what's the Russian translation of Prada
is that's truth yeah that's true sorry
that didn't even connect in my head yes
[Laughter]
yeah truth
unironically huh and again it just so
happens that is this an onion article
right so it's like you know proveda like
at least you're a communist these guys
have figured out how to get charged
people 99 a year or whatever it is for
the truth wow that's actually even
amazing right so the corporate truth so
you when you stack all that up right
basically Legacy Media has delegitimized
themselves right every day that those
quote investigative journalists don't
investigate salzburger shows that they
are so courageous as to investigate your
boss but not their own yes
total mass drop right that's like just
obvious right now once you realize this
and you know every influencer who's
coming up every Creator realizes okay
well that means I have to think about
these media corporations as competitors
they are competitors they are
competitors for advertisers and for
influence they will try basically what
the media corporations did partially
successfully during the 2010s is they
sort of had this reign of terror over
many influencers where they'd give them
positive coverage if they supported sort
of the party line and negative coverage
if they didn't okay but now
um the soft power has just dropped off a
cliff right and uh you know many kinds
of tactics that you know establishment
journalists do one way of thinking of
them is like as a for-profit stazi why
because they may stock you docs you
surveil you like they can literally put
you know like two dozen people following
somebody around for a year
and
um that's not considered stalking right
uh that's not considered spamming they
are allowed to do this and make money
doing this
whereas if you so much just criticize
them oh my God it's an attack on the
Free Press blah blah right but you are
the free press and I'm the Free Press
like we're the Free Press again it goes
back to the decentralized you know the
free speech is not like some media
Corporation thing it's everybody's right
and what actually happened with social
media what they're against is not that
it is an attacker interaction is that
it's the ultimate democracy because
people have a voice now that didn't used
to have a voice you're not saying
freedom of the freedom of press belongs
to those who own one you write that old
one right or never never argue with a
man who buys Inc by the barrel right
yeah in a real way the entire things
that were that were promised to people
freedom of speech free markets yeah like
a Beggars democracy it's like oh yeah
you can have freedom of speech but not
freedom of reach because you're just
talking to yourself in your living room
and
um you know Buffalo New York right maybe
you can gather some friends around you
didn't have uh the licenses to get uh
you know like a TV broadcast license
radio license you know the resources to
buy a newspaper you don't have practical
reach or distribution okay what happened
was all these people in the US and
around the world suddenly got voices and
they were suddenly saying things that
the establishment didn't want them to
say and so that's what this counter
decentralization has meant both in the
US and in China this Crackdown
but it's as if like a stock went up like
100 x and then dropped like 30 percent
all the Deep platforming stuff yes it's
bad okay it's
um it's it's a it's a rear root move but
in the long Arc I think we're going to
have more speech I think the counter
decentralization May succeed in China
but I don't think it's going to succeed
outside it because you you're trying to
retrofit speech and thought controls
onto an ostensibly free Society right
now that check got cash people actually
have a voice it's not going to be taken
away from them very easily right so how
does this relate to my advice to young
kids once you have that context right
once you realize Hey look
Apple didn't like do deals with
Blackberry okay Amazon didn't
collaborate or give free content to
Barnes and Noble uh Netflix uh was not
going and you know socializing with
employees of Blockbuster these employees
have established media corporations are
your competitors okay they are out for
clicks they are out for money
um they will if if they literally choke
out the ukrainians before making
themselves into champions of the
Ukrainian cause they'll basically do
anything you know and so it when she
realized that you're like okay I need to
build my own voice okay if you're
resilient you're you know Nigerian
you're in the midwest or the Middle East
right if you're uh you know Japanese you
know whatever wherever you are you need
to build your own voice because
Outsourcing that voice to somebody else
and having it put through the distorting
filter which maximizes the clicks of the
distorting kind of thing it's just not
going to be in one its own interest you
don't have to you know even agree with
everything I'm saying or even all of it
to just be like well look I'd rather
speak for myself I'd rather go direct if
I could speak unmediated in my own words
right because the choice for word is
actually very important right so that's
the second big thing you need to and
this is the thing that took me a long
time to understand okay
um because I always got the importance
of math and science and in fact I would
have been
probably just a career academic or
mathematician in another life you know
maybe statisticians something like that
electrical engineer Etc but the
importance of creating your own content
and telling your own stories uh if if
you don't tell your own story the story
will be told for you right
um the sort of flip of winners right
history is if you do not write history
you will not be the winner you must
write a history okay as kind of a funny
way of you know putting it right yeah
chicken or egg yeah contrapositive right
and now what does that mean practically
okay so in many ways the program that
I'm laying out is to build Alternatives
peaceful alternatives to all you know
Legacy institutions right to obviously
to the FED right with with Bitcoin to
Wall Street with defy and with ethereum
and so on to Academia with The Ledger of
record and the on-chain reproducible
research that we talked about to Media
with decentralized social media
decentralized AI you can melt Hollywood
with this Okay Melt the riaa Melt the
MPAA I mean there's there's some good
people there but everybody should have
their own movies you know there's people
should be able to tell their own stories
and not just wait for it to be cast
through Hollywood and Hollywood's just
making remakes anyway okay so you can
tell Original Stories and you can do so
online and you can do so by hitting a
key and the production values will be
there now that the AI content creation
tools are out there I mentioned
disrupting or replacing or building
alternatives to the FED to Wall Street
to Academia to Media I mentioned to
Wikipedia right
um there's things like golden there's
things like uh there's a bunch of web3
ish Wikipedia competitors
um that are combining with AI and crypto
for property rights
um there's you'll also need alternatives
to all the major tech companies that's
that was a list that I went through with
um you know decentralized search and
social and messaging and operating
systems and even the crypto phone okay
um and then finally you need
alternatives to uh us political
institutions and more generally and
Chinese political institutions
um and what are those that's that's
where the network State comes in and the
fundamental concept is if
and as I mentioned uh only two percent
of the world can become president of the
United States about the number of
Americans who are you know native born
and over 35 and so on and so forth but
100's world can become president of
their own network State what that means
is
um and this kind of related to those two
points right if you're an individual and
you're good at engineering and you're
good at content creation okay like
somebody like Jack Dorsey for example or
or Mark Anderson actually a lot of the
founders are actually quite good at both
nowadays you look Bezos he's actually
funny on Twitter when he allows himself
to be he's you know you don't become a
leader of that caliber without having
you know some of both right if you've
got some of both
um now no matter where you are what your
ethnicity is what your nationality is
whether you can get a U.S visa you can
become president of a network State and
what this is It's A New Path to
political power
that does not require going through
either the us or the Chinese
establishment you don't have to wait
till you're 75. you don't have to become
gerontocrat or spout the party line and
so on
um the V1 of this is like folks like you
know Francis Suarez or
Navy Kelly of El Salvador but you know
Suarez is a great example where
um while not a full Sovereign or
anything like that he has many ways and
maybe is the skills of a tech CEO we
just put up a
um you know a call on Twitter and help
Bill Miami recruit all these people from
all over and it wasn't the two-party
system of the end City system he just
helped build the City by bringing people
in okay and that's and when I say as far
as a V1 I you know I love Francis Suarez
I love what they're doing
um the next iteration of that is to
actually build the community itself
rather than just kind of taking an
existing Miami you're building something
that is potentially the scale of Miami
but as a digital community and how many
people is that well like the Miami
population is actually not that large
it's like 400 something thousand people
you could build a digital Community like
that so if you have the
engineering and you have the content
creation and you build your own
distribution you own your own thing you
can become essentially a new kind of
political leader
where you just build a large enough
online community that can crowdfund
territory and you build your vision of
the good
and anybody could build the vision of
the good talking about eight billion
people I mean there's no more inspiring
I mean sometimes
when we look at how things are broken
there could be a cynical paralysis right
but ultimately this is a really
empowering message yes I I think there
is a new birth of global freedom
and that in the fullness time people
will look at the internet as being too
the Americas with the Americas were to
Europe
a new world okay in the sense of this
Cloud continent has just come down okay
and people are you know if you spend 50
of your waking hours looking at a screen
20 you're spending all this time
commuting up to the cloud in the morning
and coming back down you're doing these
day trips and it's got a different
geography and all these people are near
each other's ever far in the physical
world and vice versa right and so this
will because it's this new domain it
gives rise to Virtual Worlds that
eventually become physical and the same
way that most people don't know this
that well but you know the Americas
really shaped the old world many
Concepts like the ultra capitalism and
Ultra democracy of the new world the
French Revolution was in part I mean
that was a bad version okay but that was
in part inspired by the American okay
there are many many movements that came
back to the old world that started here
and the same way you know I don't call
it the mainstream media anymore you know
what I call it the downstream media
because it's Downstream of the internet
that's right right that's right and you
know there's this guy a while back he
had this meme called the one kilo Year
American Empire that everything's
American and so on and his I think
fundamental category are is he considers
the internet to be American but you know
why that's not the case because and
it'll be very obviously so I think in
five or ten years why because the
majority of English speakers online by
about 2030 are going to be India
okay they're all they just got 5G LTE
super cheap internet recently the last
few years it's like one of the biggest
stories in the world that's not really
being told that much okay they've been
lurking and here's the thing and this
took me a long time to kind of you know
figure out like to identifier but to
communicate actually realize this in
2013 but
um these folks don't type with an accent
okay they speak with an accent but they
don't type with an accent and all the
way back in 2013 when I taught this
Coursera course
um I was like who are these folks I had
hundreds of thousands of people from
around the world sign up it's a very
popular course even then okay and
hundreds thousand people signed up
I was like who are these folks and there
were like polish guys and you know like
you know like this lady from Brazil so
and they knew Scumbag Steve and Good Guy
Greg but they didn't know the Yankees or
hot dogs or all the offline stuff of
America they didn't know physical
America they knew the digital
conversation the Reddit conversation and
you know what became the Twitter
conversation for example I just saw this
um this YouTube video where there's a
Indian founder and he just said just
casually like oh I slid into his DMs
like this right it was kind of a joke
but he said in an Indian accent and
everybody laughed everybody knew what he
meant and you're like wait that is a
piece of what people think of as
American internet slang that's actually
internet slang which will soon be said
mostly by non-americans now what does
that mean that means that just like the
US was a was a branch of the UK and it
started with English and certainly
there's lots of antecedents you can
trace back to England but nowadays most
Americans are not English in ancestry
there's Germans and Italians Jewish
people African-Americans you know
everybody right and the same way the
internet is much more representative of
the world than the USA is it may have
started American but he got forked by
the rest of the world that's right and
it is it gives a global equality of
opportunity it's even more capitalist
than America's it's even more Democrat
than America is just as America was more
capitalist and Democratic than the UK
the meme has escaped the cage of its
Captor and by the way that doesn't mean
I mean that so I want to be very clear
about something
when I say this kind of stuff people be
like oh my God you hate America so much
you know and that's not at all what I'm
saying uh it's like first take Britain
okay would you think of the US or Israel
or India or Singapore as being
anti-british not today they're
post-british right in fact they're quite
respectful to I mean look at the queen
and so on people respect the UK and so
everyone's coming there for to pay their
respects that might not be the greatest
example but yes go on well put it like
this yeah broadly speaking they're not
like burning the British flag and Effigy
or anything essentially the point is
each of these societies is kind of
moving along their own axis they're not
defining every action in terms of where
they're pro-british or anti-british
right like once you have kind of a
healthy distance people can respect all
the accomplishments of the UK while also
being happy that you're no longer you
know run by them yes right and then you
can have like a better you know kind of
arms length relationship right and so
that's what post-british means it is not
anti-british not at all in fact you can
respect it while also being happy that
you've got your own sovereignty right
um and you know happy that Britain has
is doing its own thing I'm glad I'm glad
they're doing well right okay and um
they're actually doing some special
economic zone stuff now and in the same
way if you think of it as not being
pro-american or anti-American because
that's the with us or against this
formulation of George Bush you know like
rather than just everything must be
scored as pro-american or anti-American
you can think of post-american that not
everything has to be scored on that axis
like you know uh there are certain
things around the world which should be
able to exist on their own and you
should be able to move along your own
access like is
um like perhaps obvious example like uh
is longevity pro-american or
anti-American you know no it's like it's
on its own axis it's moving on its own
axis and new States and new countries
should be able to exist uh that do not
have to Define themselves as
anti-American to do so they're just
post-american
um friendly to but different from that's
totally possible to do and we've got
examples of that right so when I talk
about this I'm talking about is really
in many ways
U.S and Western ideals you know but
manifested in just a different form
right and and also crucially integrative
of global ideals you know these are in a
sense are Global human rights they're
global
values uh which is freedom of speech
private property protection from search
and seizure
um and actually so that's all the Bill
of Rights type stuff and I saw something
that I thought was really good recently
that's a good
um first cut that's something that I
might want to include I credit him of
course in V to the book a digital Bill
of Rights okay and uh so this was a
really good decent first cut at a
digital Bill of Rights okay and he talks
about
um the right to encrypt the right to
compute the right to repair the right to
portability right so encrypt is perhaps
obvious you know e-commerce and
everything uh compute like your device
it's not like you can't just have
somebody intercept it or you know shut
down your your floating points
um that might sound stupid but in the EU
they're trying to regulate Ai and by
doing that they have some regulation
that says like logic
is is it self-regulated did you see this
no it's hilarious but click the the
tweet that I sent you just before this
one right so I was like
you know in in woke America they're
abolishing accelerated math because math
is quote white supremacist
not to be outdone Europe seeks to
regulate AI by regulating logic itself
you can't reason without a license right
article 3 for purpose of this regulation
the following definitions apply
AI system is software that's developed
with one or more of the techniques and
approaches listed in Annex one and you
know what's in nx1 in Annex one logic
and knowledge-based approaches
so step away from the if statement all
right okay and the thing is
you know if you've dealt with these
bureaucracies the stupidest possible
interpretation I mean think about if you
think oh no that wouldn't make any sense
he wouldn't do that the entire web is
being uglified by the stupid cookie
thing that does absolutely nothing right
the actual way to protect privacy is
with user local data I mean meaning like
decentralized
um systems right where the private keys
are local no I'm just laughing at the
layers of absurdity in this uh step away
from the if statement I mean it's
hilarious
um it's very very clumsy
um they want to be us struggling how to
define yeah the digital Bill of Rights I
suppose and doing it so extremely
clumsily it's funny you know the Europe
like I heard this thing which is like
Europe's like well look the US and China
are way ahead of us in AI but we're
going to be a leader in AI regulation
yeah yeah and something we haven't
mentioned much of in this whole
conversation I think may be implied
between the lines is
the thing that was in the constitution
of the pursuit and happiness and the
thing that is in many stories that we
humans conjure up which is love
I think the thing that makes life worth
living in many ways but for that you
have to have freedom you have to have
um stability you have to have a society
that's functioning so that humans can do
what humans do which is make friends
make family
uh uh make love make uh make beautiful
things together as human beings uh
Balaji this is like an incredible
conversation thank you for uh showing an
amazing future
um I think really empowering to to
people because we can all be part of
creating that future and thank you so
much for talking to me today this was an
incredible obviously the longest
conversation I've ever done but also one
of the most amazing enlightening thank
you thank you brother for everything you
do thank you for uh inspiring all of us
well Lex this is great and
um uh we didn't get through all the
questions we didn't just just for the
record we didn't get I would venture to
say we didn't get to 50 percent
this is great this is great and I have I
had to stop us from going too deep on
any one thing even though it was
tempting like those chocolates those
damn delicious looking chocolates that
was used as a metaphor about 13 hours
ago uh or however long we started the
conversation this is incredible it was
really brilliant you're brilliant
throughout uh on all those different
topics So yeah thank you again for
talking now this is great I really
appreciate being here
sir
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Balaji sunivasan to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from Ray
Bradbury
people ask me to predict the future
when all I want to do is to prevent it
better yet build it
predicting the future is much too easy
anyway you look at the people around you
the street you stand on the visible air
you breathe
and predict more of the same
to hell with more I want better
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time